SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SAID HERE'S SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR HEARING. HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL TODAY.
ALMOST I BELIEVE ALL MEMBERS
ARE HERE AT THE CAPITAL CENTRE
STERN WILL BE- PATISSERIE
PARTICIPATING FROM HIS OFFICE.
BUT IT LOOKS SKEWS THE CENTERS
FOR ME BEING HERE. THOSE TRYING
TO SPRING FOR THE COMMITTEE-
ARE ALSO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. FASTED EVERY
TWO THAT YOU WOULD TO BE
WRECKED THE USUAL THE HAND
FEATURE ON THE PROGRAM EACH
TIME YOU BE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING YOU. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ADMIT POLICE SELECTOR ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. T. PERSONNEL. WOULD YOU BACK
ON ME WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZE. THAT TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME.
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE- PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL. BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL NOW
SIT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPATED.
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8152 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY ONE SEVEN.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITES PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
FOR US TO. HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AVOID ACOUSTIC. FEEDBACK YOU
TOO MUST MEET YOUR DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OF
THE PHONE IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR.
FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE FOLLOW UP MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING
WHICH IS CUSTOMARY AND AS IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO'S RESTRICTED
MAYBE. REMOVE THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR THEIR
CONNECT MUTED. PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL.
DISCUSSION ITEMS I'M HAPPY
PERSON FOR. A AND PART B. TO GO
TO PART. WITH CONTINUE PART B.
HAVE. A DISCUSSION. OUR MEMBERS
ON THE CALL. ON THINGS ANIMAL
OPEN UP FOR THE PUB HEARING
WELL IF YOU- HAS TO STREAMLINE
THE- PROCESS. AND A HEARING
CENTER CLOSE SAME MANNER CUSTOM.
THERE MAYBE LAG TIME RICHER WHO
ARE TESTING. TO USE OF ON TOOLS
TECHNOLOGY PLEASE RESPECT ONE
PACE. SELECTION PARTIES CAN BE.
I'LL IF ANY. IS FISK PRESENT
HERE PLEASE KEEP YOUR- MASCOT
COVER YOUR NOSE AND ALL AMOUNTS.
ICE ALSO THAT AS WAS- I DO IS
WE WILL HAVE A- FROM TWELVE. TO
ONE THIRTY SO WE WILL TAKE A
BREAK- IF PREVIOUSLY SCHEDULED
MEETING THAT WE HAVE TO TEN- SO
WILL ESTABLISH. A QUORUM- AT
THAT TIME- WHEN WE HAD OUR-
THIRD MEMBER HERE ACTUALLY.
MISS ROY IF YOU WOULD OF PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND THE STAFF A
CORE. Y. CASKEY HERE ALLEY.
HERE REQUIRE IT BUT I HEARD
HERE'S OKAY WE'RE PRISON AN
ACCOUNT. FOR- AS WE WILL BE TO
ALL VOTED END OF THE HEARING
AND AS PART OF THE HEARING IS
VOTE ONLY WE WILL SKIP PART. A
MOVE ON THE B. AND MEMBERS OF
THE IF YOU WANT COMMENT ON PART
AND IS WELLS OUR MEMBERS HERE-
WE WILL BE DISCUSSING ALL THESE
ITEMS IN THE SECTION OF THE
GENDER AT. THE ALLEY- IS HERE
MISS ECKLER- YOU MAY PROCEED
THIS IS PART B. MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THIS IS
PART B. OUR DISCUSSION. ONLY-
HI. OF WHICH- ON ISSUE NUMBER.
NINETY THE ISSUE NUMBER. UNDER
OUR PACKAGES RIGHT. OUR GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RACHEL EHLERS HERE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
YOUR STAFF HAS ASKED US TO GO
THROUGH AT A HIGH LEVEL THAT
THREE BIG PACKAGES THAT ARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND PROVIDE
SOME COMPARISON OF THE SENATE-
PAST MAJORITY PACKAGES-
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S NAME
REVISION PACKAGES SO I WILL
START ON PAGE NINETY NINE OF
YOUR AGENDA- WAIT FOR THE-
WATER AND DROUGHT PACKAGE SO
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE WATER DOP
PACKAGE THE WELFARE PACKAGE AND
THE CLIMATE PACKAGE AND FOR THE
FIRST TWO ALTHOUGH IT. HAD A
PRETTY HIGH LEVEL JUST LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE COMPARISONS-
SINCE THOSE PACKAGES HAVE BEEN
HEARD BY YOU ALREADY IN YOUR
COMMUNITY FOR THE THIRD THE
CLIMATE PACKAE BECAUSE THE NEW
SENATE PROPOSALS IS THE FIRST
TIME IT'S COMING BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE UNCLE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SLOWLY AND HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE COMPONENTS OF THAT
PACKAGE. SO HERE LOOKING AGAIN
ON PAGE NINETY NINE AT THE
WATER IN DROUGHT PACKAGE
COMPARISONS YOU CAN SEE THAT
THE SENATE PROPOSAL THAT YOUR
SUB COMMITTEE ADOPTED ON MAY
FOURTH COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S NAME REVISION
PROPOSAL- HAS DIFFERENT AMOUNTS
OF FUNDING THE GOVERNOR SCOTT
MORE FUNDING IT'S SPREAD ACROSS
TWO YEARS- A TOTAL OF FOUR
POINT FIVE HOWEVER PROPOSED FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. AND YOU'LL
SEE THERE ARE MANY SIMILAR
PRIORITIES ACROSS THESE TWO
PACKAGES BUT ALSO SOME
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES- SO YOU
CAN SEE THE FIRST LARGE NUMBER
THERE FOR ADDRESSING WATER DEBT
FOR THE THROUGH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD A
BILLION DOLLARS THE GOVERNOR
SPECIFIES THAT WOULD BE IN
FEDERAL- AND MERICAN RECOVERY
PLAN ACT FUNDS THE SENATE-
DOESN'T SPECIFY A FUN SOURCE
BUT BUT SIMILAR MOUNTAIN THAT'S
A THAT'S A BIG ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN IDENTIFIED- IN THE NEXT
CATEGORY SMALL COMMUNITY
DROUGHT ASSISTANCE YOU CAN SEE
SOME DIFFERENCES IN FUNDING
SOURCES THERE THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL IT WOULD INCLUDE ONE
POINT THREE BILLION IN FEDERAL
FUNDS TO ADDRESS THAT SAID SAME
AMOUNTS FOR SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THEN AS YOU
GO THROUGH YOU CAN SEE SOME
DIFFERENT PRIOR HE'S IN THE IN
THE- K. THE SENATE. AS A HIM TO
ON ARE. WHY STORM WATER MAN.
AND WATER FISH. BOTH IN THE
URBAN AND I'M- SETTINGS. AND
THE GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE
INCLUDES- SPECIFIC INITIATIVES-
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PRIORITIZED INCLUDING REPAIRS
TO CANALS FOR THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AND CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT. FUNDING FOR THE
SOLVENCY AND A LARGE NEW LAND
RE PURPOSING PROGRAM THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR DROUGHT
RESPONSE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL AS COMPARED TO THE
SENATE. SO THAT'S THE WATER
PACKAGE- NEXT WILL TURN TO PAGE
ONE HUNDRED AND THREE OF YOUR
AGENDA. AND THIS IS LOOKING AT
THE WILDFIRE PREVENTION
PACKAGE- THERE'S SEVERAL
COLUMNS IN THIS FIGURE ON PAGE
ONE HUNDRED AND THREE BUT I
THINK PROBABLY THE MOST
RELEVANT ARE THE MOST RIGHT
HANDS A LETTER TO COLUMNS WHICH
IS LOOKING AT THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION- AND THE SENATE
PACKAGE WHICH YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE
ADOPTED. AND HERE AGAIN YOU CAN
SEE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCES IS IN FUNDING
AMOUNTS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IS SEVEN OF ROUGHLY SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION WHERE IS THE
SENATE PACKAGES A BILLION
DOLLARS AND ALSO THE SENATE
PACKAGE THAT EXPRESSES INTENT
FOR THAT BILLION DOLLARS TO BE.
REPEATED FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS TO FIVE BILLION TOTAL- ME
HERE YOU CAN SEE MOST OF THE
CATEGORIES ARE REALLY THE SAME
IT'S JUST REALLY A RELATIVELY
MINOR DIFFERENCE IN AMOUNT-
BETWEEN THE TWO PACKAGES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS THE SAME
AS THAT AS WAS PROPOSED IN
JANUARY IT'S JUST REALLY WHAT
WASN'T INCLUDED IN THAT EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE. THE BIGGEST
PIECES FOR THE CLIMATE CATALYST
FUND THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE EARLY ACTION SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ROLLS THAT
INTO- HIS MAY REVISION BUT
REALLY OTHERWISE IT'S THE SAME
ISSUES THAT YOU HAVE TALKED
ABOUT- THROUGHOUT. THROUGHOUT
THE SPRING THROUGH THE PROCESS
THE SENATE PACKAGE JUST AS A
LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY FOR
SEVERAL OF THOSE CATEGORIES AND
THEN AGAIN ACROSS- FIVE YEARS
RATHER THAN ONE YEAR. AND THEN
FOR THE FINAL. YOU DISCUSSING
THIS MORE. TRY TO PAY ONE AND
TWO. OF YOUR AGENDA- SO THIS IS
NEW NUTRI IN FRONT OF YOU-
SENATE CLIMATE PACKAGE- THIS
PAGE ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE HAS
THAT HIGH LEVEL DESCRIPTIONS OF
ALL OF THE CATEGORIES IT TOTALS
THREE POINT SIX SEVEN FIVE
BILLION. IN GENERAL FUND BUT IF
YOU TURN TO THE NEXT PAGE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN OF YOUR
AGENDA THAT HAS THE COMPARISON
CHART ACROSS THE TWO PACKAGES
SENATE- MAJORITY PACKAGE HERE
BEFORE YOU AND THE GOVERNOR'S
ME REVISION GOVERNORS MAY
REVISION WOULD BE ACROSS THREE
YEARS WAS THE SENATE PACKAGES
JUST ONE YEAR- AND BUT YET
AGAIN HERE YOU CAN SEE A RETTY
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
FUNDING AT THEM THIS CASE IT'S-
MORE FUNDING FROM THE SENATE.
AS COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION. AS
COMPARED TO ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION. I AND IN THE KIND OF
WHILE THERE ARE SOME SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES I THINK IN THIS
PACKAGE YOU YOU REALLY WILL SEE
A DIFFERENT MIX OF PRIORITIES
ACROSS THE TWO PACKAGES AS
COMPARED. TO THE WILDFIRE WHERE
THEY'RE REALLY PRETTY SIMILAR.
SO JUST AGAIN WALKING THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT SINCE THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THI IS BEFORE YOU.
THE FIRST CATEGORIES REGIONAL
CLIMATE RESILIENCE THE SENATE
PACKAGE INCLUDES SIX HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION TOTAL.
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
FOR STATE CONSERVANCIES TO
UNDERTAKE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PROJECTS. AND TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOUR AREAS
THAT AREN'T COVERED BY THOSE
CONSERVANCY'S THOSE WOULD BE
GRANTS FROM THAT- CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PROJECTS
ACROSS THE STATE. YOU CAN SEE
THOSE THOSE FUNDING AMOUNTS IN
ACTIVITIES ARE NOT REFLECTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HOWEVER
THAT DOES HAVE. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DOES HAVE MORE FUNDING
FOR PLANNING AND CAPACITY
BUILDING AT. THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE. THE
NEXT CAT FOR CURBING EVERY- AT
SOME. FUNDING SOMEWHAT. HERE
FOR URBAN GREENING AND COOLING
AND RESILIENCE CENTERS- THESE
THE GOVERNOR'S AMOUNT INCLUDES
HERE AT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION THAT'S ACTUALLY AND
THAT- CDFA BUDGET. THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE FOR RE PURPOSING
SOME FAIRGROUNDS BUT- REFLECTED
HERE JUST BECAUSE IT IS A
SIMILAR ACTIVITIES TO WHAT IS
INCLUDED IN THE SENATE PACKAGE-
SIMILARLY BOTH PACKAGES INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND RESEARCH BUT MORE IN THE
SENATE PACKAGE THAT AMOUNT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S IS REALLY
PRIMARILY FOR. THE FOURTH
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT WHEREAS THE
SENATE PACKAGE DOESN'T SPECIFY
HOW THAT FUNDING WOULD BE
DIRECTED. AND THEN YOU CAN SEE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING HERE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S COLUMN FOR SOME
SPECIFIC INITIATIVES AND
PROGRAMS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE. NOT
INCLUDED IN THE SENATE PACKAGE.
THE NEXT CAT FOR WHAT SHOULD BE
YOU CAN PRETTY SO. DIFFERENCE
ACROSS THERE'S QUITE A BIT MORE
MONEY IN THE SENATE PACKAGE
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY
MILLION FOR MULTI BENEFIT FLOOD
PROTECTION AND DELTA LEVEES.
WHICH COMPARES TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THAT'S THAT'S ROUGHLY
SIMILAR IN THE GOVERNOR'S-
PACKAGE ACTUALLY IN THE WATER
PACKAGE BUT FOR SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION. AND MULTI BENEFIT-
PROJECTS. THAN THE SENATE
PACKAGE HAS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR PROTECTION OF LAKES
STREAMS AND RIVERS AND AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION. FOR URBAN
STREAMS AND RIVERS INCLUDING
THE LA RIVER AND PARKWAY- FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN THE SENATE
PACKAGE FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE
PROTECTION ACTIVITIES. WHICH IS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PACKAGE. THE SENATE PACKAGE
INCLUDES A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION FOR VARIOUS AGRICULTURE
AND FOOD SUPPLY RESILIENCE
ACTIVITIES NOW THIS IS GOING TO
DO THIS WOULD BE IN ADDITION TO
THE RESILIENT. AGRICULTURE
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE EXCUSE
ME PACKAGE THAT YOUR COMMITTEE
ALSO DISCUSSED AND ADOPTED AND
A SEPARATE AGRICULTURE PACKAGE
THAT THE GOVERNOR ALSO INCLUDED
IN THE MAY REVISION- BUT NONE
OF THE NONE OF THE ACTIVITIES
IN THOSE PACKAGES ARE ARE
SIMILAR TO THESE AND THE
GOVERNOR DID NOT HAVE THIS
AGRICULTURE SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES
IN HIS. CLIMATE PACKAGE. OUR
NEXT FOR CONSUMER AGAIN THIS IS
IN AREA WHERE YOU SEE A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE ACROSS
THE TWO PROPOSALS- IN FUNDING
AMOUNTS THE SENATE PACKAGE
INCLUDES NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION. SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY WOULD BE
THROUGH THAT STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY WITH A HUNDRED
MILLION RESERVED FOR PROJECTS
IN THAT SAME JUST KOBE. AND
THEN AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY RESTORATION AUTHORITY.
WETLAND RESTORATION PROJECTS.
ARE BOTH PACKAGES INCLUDE
AMOUNTS FOR THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL TO RUN
PROJECTS BUT BUT DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS THAT WOULD BE THE
PRIMARY VEHICLE- THAT THE GUY.
WOULD YOU USE FOR FUNDING FOR
SEA LEVEL RISE. ACTIVITIES
COASTAL PROTECTION ACTIVITIES-
AND THEN THE SAME YOU CAN SEE
IN SOME OTHER SPECIFIC
ALLOCATIONS FORTY MILLION FOR
THE CENTER- SANTA ANA RIVER
CONSERVANCY THIRTY MILLION FOR
THE COASTAL COMMISSION. FOR
LOCAL GRANTS FOR SEA LEVEL RISE
AND THEN TWENTY MILLION FOR THE
OTHER DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE FOR HELP RESTORATION
AND FISHERY PROTECTION. WHERE
IS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HAS
TWELVE MILLION SPECIFICALLY FOR
STATE PARKS TO UNDERTAKE
ACTIVITIES ON STATE PARK LANDS
RELATED TO SEA LEVEL RISE-
PREPARATION. AND THEN IN THE
FINAL CATEGORY YOU CAN SEE HIM
FALL FOR DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE PACKAGE THAT
ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE SENATE
PACKAGE. SO LITTLE BIT MORE OF
A DIFFERENCE HERE AND IN THIS
PACKAGE AS COMPARED TO FOR
EXAMPLE THE WILDFIRES WE
DISCUSSED. SO WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR- I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
HERE AS WELL IF YOU HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. I JUST WANT
TO NOTE. AS AS A REMINDER THAT
THESE ARE OUR SENATE MAJORITY
PAC JUSTIN NOT LA OKAY I CAN
JUST SAY WE'RE HAPPY TO. ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE BUT IF. IF THEIR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS ABOUT. PRIORITIES
ARE WHY THESE SPECIFIC
ACTIVITIES OR WHAT THIS
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES
WOULD BE THOSE OF HOW TO BE
BETTER DIRECTED THROUGH THE
CHAIR TO COMMITTEE STAFF AND
MLA- BUT WE'RE HERE TO. HELP AS
AS BEST WE CAN. RIGHT I THANK
YOU D. I NOTICE YOU STARTED
OFF. WITH THE IDEA WORK THE
CONCEPT AND THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY WILL GO BACKWARDS.
IS THAT THIS IS A ONE YEAR
PACKAGE. BY THE- SENATE FOR
THREE POINT SIX SEVEN FIVE.
BILLION DOLLARS FOR CITY
GOVERNORS. IS ONE POINT SEVEN-
IN ALTHOUGH THIS RECOMMENDATION
IS THAT. WE TAKE THEM RIGHT NOW
BUT WE SPEND IT OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT. YEAH I THINK I THINK-
THAT IS DEFINITELY AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION YOU ALL SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT IT YOU'RE
PUTTING THESE TOGETHER REALLY
JUST WHAT IS THE CAPACITY OF
DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL AGENCIES
TO BE ABLE TO ABSORB A HUGE
INFLUX OF FUNDING AT AT ONE
TIME SO. I THINK THINKING ABOUT
SPREADING IT IN A WAY THAT-
THAT THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
STATE GOVERNMENT FRANKLY CAN
ACCOMMODATE AS IT IS AN
APPROACH THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
AND THEN ALTHOUGH WE WERE NOT
HAVING A DISCUSSION ON THE TAX
PACKAGE COULD YOU COMMENT ON
THAT BECAUSE- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO- USE A
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR. FINE WE HAVE WE
HAVE OUR PACKAGE IF THE
GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE WE'RE-
WE'RE- MOVING THEM FOR BUT WERE
USING THE- THE DETERMINATION ON
THE FINAL AGREEMENT WILL BE THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY-
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT ARE. MIGHT BE
IN THE CLIMATE PACKAGE THAT
SOME FOLKS WILL LOOK TO THEM AS
THE IN THE ACT PACKAGE. HE I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR YOU WELL
IT'S REALLY COMPLICATED BUT TO
THINK ABOUT ALL OF THESE
PACKAGES TOGETHER BECAUSE NOT
INCLUDED HERE IS CAP AND TRADE
AS WELL WHICH HAS A LOT OF THE
SIMILAR. TYPE ACTIVITIES SO
EVEN THOUGH IT MAKES IT HARDER
THESE AREN'T STANDALONE
PACKAGES THAT JUST KIND OF GO
OFF AND GET IMPLEMENTED-
INDEPENDENTLY WITHOUT THAT
INTERACTION OUR PRIORITIES OF
OTHER PACKAGES OF CERTAINLY A
CAP AND TRADE- AGRICULTURE IN
ADDITION TO THESE THREE AS WELL
AS IT IS THAT DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE- BEING CONSIDERED THROUGH
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES REALLY THINKING.
HOLISTICALLY ABOUT WHAT ARE ALL
OF YOUR PRIORITIES WHAT ARE THE
ACTIVITIES YOU WANT TO- MAKE
SURE THAT THE STATE
ACCOMPLISHES WITH THIS- REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
pTHIS YEAR AND NOT GET WORRIED
ABOUT WHICH SILO THERE AND NOT
REALLY THINK ABOUT THEM
TOGETHER. BECAUSE I THINK THIS
AGAIN THE CAP AND TRADE WE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ON THAT BEFORE-
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HAS BEEN
PRETTY CLEAR ABOUT THEIR
DETERMINATION TO KEEP CAP AND
TRADE. CLIMATE POLICY RATHER
THAN POLLUTION POLICY AND WE'VE
WE'VE HAD SOME SUGGESTIONS THAT
ARE IN THERE DIRECTING- BUT
WHEN YOU'RE A- FROM GENERAL
FUND SO THAT WE CAN. LOOK AT
THIS HOLISTIC- INTERPLAY
BETWEEN THESE HUGE PACKAGES
THAT WE HAVE THAT ARE GOING ON-
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT. ALL
THESE PACKAGES TAKEN TOGETHER
FROM THE ALLEY OWES POSITION
THAT WE HAVE FAILED TO ADDRESS.
SEEMS AN ALMOST
INCOMPREHENSIBLE BUT IS THERE
IS THERE SOMETHING FROM THE LA
O'S OFFICE THAT WE HAVE SORT OF
MISSED EITHER IN THE CLIMATE
PACKAGE IN THE BACK PACKAGE IN
THE DROUGHT PACKAGE. IN THE
WILDFIRES PACKAGE. YEAH IT'S
CERTAINLY- AND YOU KNOW A
MATTER OF PRIORITIES AND IF YOU
LOOK KIND OF IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PACKAGES IN THE SENATE'S
PACKAGING EATING THERE'S A LOT
OF STUFF IN HERE. I THINK WHEN
THE AREA THAT WE HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED IN SOME OF OUR
REPORTS PREVIOUSLY IN
PARTICULAR AND THEN SOME OF THE
WORK WE'VE DONE ON SEA LEVEL
RISE IS THE IMPORTANT ROLE THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PLAY. AND
ESPECIALLY WHERE THAT'S WHERE
THE LAND USE DECISIONS ARE MADE
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THE LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SOUND AND SO
THINKING ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT YOU CAN GIVE. AND WHAT
THE APPROPRIATE ROLE FOR THE
STATE IS IN SUPPORTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR PLANNING- AND
FOR IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS AND
IN PARTICULAR FOR WORKING
ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL LINES AND
LOOKING AT A REGIONAL LEVEL FOR
SEA LEVEL RISE THAT'S GOING TO
BE HUGE AND SO- THAT THAT MAY
BE AN AREA YOU MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
IS HOW. WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE
STATE AND SUPPORTING AND
HELPING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
PLANNING AND BREAKING DOWN SOME
pLEVEL SO THEY. CAN BE WORKING
AT A REGIONAL LEVEL. IN DM I
KNOW THAT THE SENATE WHILE.
PACK AHEAD. EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OPR TO DO WHILE
FOR. CLAY AT. PLANNING ALTHOUGH.
SENATE PACKAGE ON CLIMATE
RESILIENCY. IS SILENT ON THE
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING
GRANTS AND THE- REGIONAL
CLIMATE COLLABORATIVE. PROGRAM
SO THERE'S LESS PLANNING
DOLLARS. A BOATLOAD OF MONEY
INTO PROJECTS. IF THE PROJECTS
ARE READY IF YOU'VE DONE YOUR
WORK THERE'S MONEY FOR THE
PROJECTS BUT THERE THERE'S NOT
IT APPEARS AS YOU AS YOU LOOK
AT THAT AT LEAST ON THIS FIRST
ROUND THAT THERE'S NOT WE'RE
NOT CALLING OUT THE PLANNING
DOLLARS THAT'S FAIR FAIR ENOUGH
CRITICISM FOR IDENTIFICATION.
LET'S GO TO MEMBERS WE HAVE THE
SRVER THE DISCUSSION ONLY EVEN
THOUGH I'VE TEETERING AROUND
WITH NON NON DISCUSSION ITEMS
WE'LL OPEN IT UP FOR DISCUSSION
ON THE DISCUSSION ITEMS OTHER
COMMENTS WE WANT TO MAKE ON ON.
PART A AND PART B. THAT ARE NOT
A DISCUSSION ITEM ON THESE
THREE PACKAGES- WE'LL TAKE UP
AFTER A BREAK THAT'S OKAY.
SECURITIZED IN SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS FOR AGENCY WHICH I
CAN HOLD WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
HOLD THOSE UNTIL AFTER THE
BREAK WOULD THAT BE. DO THEY
COME UNDER ANY OF THESE
PACKAGES. ABSENCE TO CIVIC
ITEMS IN REGARDS TO CAL FIRE
AND STAFFING. DECIDED TO KEEP.
AN EYE ON THE WILDFIRES YEAH ON
THE WIFI YEAH. PLUG IT IN RIGHT
OKAY I I'M NOT I'M NOT SURE IF
WE HAVE TO PORTER ON THE LINE
WE HAVE SUPPORT ONLINE. ALL
RIGHT. CHIEF THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TAKING THE TIME- I WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS CHIEF ON
THE ISSUE OF- ALL ISSUES- OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT THAT YOU
HAVE I THINK IT'S ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN ISSUE THIRTEEN-
WITHIN OUR PACKAGE. AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
AND DESTROY BECAUSE THIS IS
BEEN A BEAR TO TACKLE SO VERY
GRATEFUL MISTER CHAIR. MISTER I
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT'S GONE
INTO THIS. CHIEF LOOK I THINK A
OF ITEMS THAT ONE. I WOULD HAVE
HOPED THAT WE WOULD HAVE SEEN A
DISH OR TWO HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
FULL TIME FIREFIGHTERS AND I
THOUGHT WE ARE GONNA SEE THIS
YEAR COMING BACK. TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION I
UNDERSTAND YOU WERE NOT. IN
RETURN RECEIPT ABOUT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS
THAT WILL BE DEPLOYED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TWELVE
HUNDRED OF THOSE I BELIEVE ARE
ALREADY IN STATION WHICH IS BIG
NEWS AND WHEN I SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP SIR. BUT
TALK ABOUT. THE ISSUE OF THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE. POSITIONS
NUMBER ONE. HOW DOES THIS HELP.
THOSE FIREFIGHTERS THAT ARE ON
THE LINE- FREE THEM UP. TWO DO
YOU HAVE ANY ESTIMATE ON HOW
THIS IS GOING TO FREE UP FIRE
FIGHTING TIME- AND CANDIDLY WHY
THIS AND NOT LOOKING AT
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS CHIEF I
KNOW I JUST THREW THREE
QUESTIONS OUT OF JAIL IF THAT'S
OKAY- MISTER CHAIR. REPORTER
THANK YOU- THANK YOU SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE YOU NEED FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
SUBJECT AND THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE FOR YOUR QUESTION WELL
WHAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS OUR- ZERO- DIRECT MISSIONS
OF COURT- PROPOSAL. AND WHAT-
WHAT I WANT TO FOCUS ON IS
THERE EVEN A COUPLE OF THINGS
WHEN WE HAVE A LARGE INCIDENTS
AS EVERY SINGLE YEAR WE'RE
HAVING MORE AND MORE LARGE
INCIDENTS- ABOUT FIVE SIX YEARS
AGO. TEN TWENTY YEARS AGO WE
WOULD HAVE INCIDENT MANAGEMENT
TEAMS TO THE TUNE OF. ABOUT
FIVE ON AVERAGE- THAT WOULD BE
DEPLOYED IN A YEAR LAST YEAR WE
HAD TWENTY OF THOSE
DEPLOYMENTS. AND WHEN WE DO
THAT WE. WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT-
JUST SEEING A- LET ME OF FUNK
THAT FOLLOWS IN. YEAH BIAS
PROCURER STUFF THINGS WE NEED
TO- TO MANAGE THAT. INCIDENT
BASED UP SUPPORT- BULLDOZERS
AIRCRAFT WAR HAND CREWS
SOMETIMES FROM OUT OF STATE-
AND OR ENGINES ALL OF THAT
HAPPENING AS WELL AS
ACCOMMODATIONS AND FEEDING FOR
THE FOR THE CRUISER AT THESE
INCIDENTS. ALL OF THAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE BASE THROUGH
THE PROCESS THAT WE HAVE-
DEVELOP. IT'S A IT'S A EXTREME
WORKLOAD ON ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF WHAT WE HAVE TO DO-
ROUTINELY NOW IS OVER UNIFORMS
STAFF. FIREFIGHTERS THAT ARE
TRAINED TO BE ON FIRE ENGINES
IN COMMAND POSITIONS OUT ON THE
FIRE LINE. WE REDIRECT THEM
INTO BASE OR INTO HEADQUARTERS
TO- TO MEET THAT NEED. YEAH SO
WE'RE DOING THAT A REACH BASIS
WE'VE THAT THERE. A OF THOUSAND
OF THAT TIME OF WORK BEING BY
YOU STAFF THANK. BE DONE BY- BY
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF- YEAH
FRANKLY A LOWER COST THERE'S
ANOTHER PIECE TO THIS WHEN WE
PUT A FIREFIGHTER INTO THAT
POSITION WE STILL HAVE TO FIRE
HI HIGHER AND- WE STILL HAVE TO
KEEP THE FIRE ENGINE RUNNING SO
WE- WE HAVE TO HIRE BEHIND SO
WE'RE PAYING OVERTIME FOR THE
POSITION THAT'S DOING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK AND- OF.
THAT ADMINISTRATIVE POSITION
AND WE'RE ALSO HIRING A SECOND
BODY TO COVER THE FIRE ENGINE
AND. THAT'S THAT'S CONTRIBUTING.
OUR OF NOT GETTING OUR
FIREPLACE ENOUGH. AND TRYING
RELAX A TO RESEARCH AND BE FOR
THE NEXT INCIDENT. SO ALL OF
THAT IS PART OF THIS EQUATION.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE
COME UP WITH THIS PROPOSAL TO
SHIFT. THE FUND. SHARE THIS.
NET ZERO REQUEST. PROBLEM
DOLLARS THAT WE ALL HAVE BEEN
ALL. TO DO THIS ANNUALLY FOR
THAT PROCESS THAT I JUST
MENTIONED SO. THERE'S NO AND NO
pACTUALLY WE THINK THERE WILL BE
SOME SOME SAVINGS. THAT HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOURS EQUATES TO ABOUT
A THOUSAND WORKDAYS WHEN YOU
GET TO THE TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PEOPLE ON ON THE
GROUND DOING THE INCIDENT IN
BASE. THE OTHER THING ABOUT THE
IS THESE- INCIDENCES. THE
FINANCE PORTION AND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PORTION GOES ON
FOR WEEKS SOMETIMES MONTHS
AFTER AN INCIDENT CLOSES SO THE
FIREFIGHTERS ALTHOUGH HOME WE
STILL HAVE TO DO ALL THE
PROCESSING OF THOSE BILLS. AND
IN SOME CASES WE ARE SIX TO TEN
MONTHS BEHIND ON PAYING OUR
BILLS FOR- FOR. RENDERING.
SERVICES AND- NOT ONLY THAT BUT
THIS YEAR INTO WHAT WILL BE BIG
CHAT YOU WITH CONDITION WE ARE
HAVE ALL A THOUSAND BY MORE
THAN WE HAVE. BUDGETED TO THIS
DAY. AND GOT ABOUT FIVE TIMES
THE NUMBER OF ACRES- RIGHT NOW.
SO GOING INTO THIS SEASON WE
HAVE VENDORS THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE CALLING UPON TO RENDER
SERVICES AGAIN TO THE STATE. WE
HAVEN'T BEEN PAID FOR LAST
YEAR'S- AFTER AND SO- NOT ONLY
ARE THEY- SO IN SOME REAL TO
BACK BUT THEY'RE ALSO. ARE
CASES WHERE- WE- GOING TO BE
ASKING FOR THOSE- THAT THAT-
BUSINESS IS ABOUT GONE UNDER OF
AND WE'RE PAYING THE- THE LATE
FEE AND- PENALTIES TO THAT WE
HAVE TO ON MAKING. PAYMENTS
GOOD. SO IF THIS IS VERY TO ME-
IF VERY IMPORTANT ME FOR
KEEPING THE BUSINESS OF ARTICLE
GOING FORWARD. IT'S ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY
DOES PUT. SOME OF THOSE
FIREFIGHTERS THAT WHERE WE ARE
NOT IN OUR CURRENT REQUEST.
INTO THE BACK INTO THE SYSTEM
TO REDUCE THAT WORK LOAD ON THE
ENGINE STAFF THAT IS SO
OVERCAST AND I DO LOOK FORWARD
TO A TIME WHEN WE CAN COME BACK
AND TALK ABOUT. THE STAFF THAT
WE NEED. TO BUILD THE
DEPARTMENT TO THE FUNCTION THAT
IT NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO MEET
GOING INTO THE FUTURE BUT THIS
IS THE POINT IN TIME WHEN WE
REALLY NEED THE ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF. AND THE RELIEF OF THOSE
THOSE UNIFORMS STAFFED BY JUST
TO GET THROUGH THIS COMING YEAR
AND THE END OF YOUR STAY
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE AND WORSE
AS WE SPEAK. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
BUT THAT IS THE ADDRESS THANKS
TO ALL OF SENATOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
CHIEF I DIDN'T NEED TO GO TO-
FINANCE I FORGOT TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION BUT I DID LIKE YOUR
COMP WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER NINETY
ONE THAT. THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
ALLEY- AND WE'VE WE LOOK AT THE
CAL FIRE CATEGORIES AND COMPARE
THE GOVERNORS MAY REVISION. TO
THE- TO THE SENATE PROPOSAL IT
LOOKS LIKE HEALTHY FOREST GETS
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
MORE THE GOVERNOR HAS A HUNDRED
MILLION. IN THE SENATE HAS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
THE SAME WITH THE PROGRAM FOR
FORCE IMPROVEMENTS FOR SMALL
LAND OWNERS WE- 20% HIGHER. THE
SENATE HAS A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL VERSUS FORTY
WE'VE GOT THERE'S MORE MONEY IN
THE LEG AND FORCED LEGACY IN
THE REFORESTATION OF NURSERY. A
THREE MILLION DOLLARS MORE TWO
MILLION AND URBAN FORESTRY YOU
GO DOWN TO YOUR- YOUR ABOUT
PRESCRIBED BURNS IN HAND
CRUISES ANOTHER FIVE MILLION.
MILLION DOLLARS- WOULDN'T
AREN'T THOSE RESOURCES I MEAN
THIS IS IT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THE
SENATE VERSION. WOULD PROVIDE
CAL FIRE WITH MORE RESOURCES.
TO MEET THEIR THEIR CHARGE.
THAT'S A GREAT. IS SENATOR
HOUSE. AND WHERE WE- OUT. SO IN
THAT AREA AS WELL THOSE THOSE
ARE HE- GRASS. INCREASE THEY DO
NOT- THEY THEY ARE NOT THE
POSITIONS AND THEY ARE NOT
POSITIONS THAT WOULD BE
REDIRECTED IN THIS FASHION AS I
MENTIONED. WHAT WHAT WHAT THE
DIRECT MISSION SUPPORT PIECES
SPECIFICALLY FOR- OUR MEETING
OF THE EXPANDING NEEDS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT FOR OUR
FIREFIGHTING MISSIONS SO. THEY
ARE VERY SEPARATE AND IF WE
PULL THEM OFF OF THAT MISSION
LET'S JUST SAY- THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD THAT LEAVE US AT A
DEFICIT IN BEING ABLE TO MEET
THE MISSION. OF DELIVERING
THESE THESE RESILIENCY DOLLARS-
IN A WAY THAT WE COMMITTED TO
DO SO. I GUESS ONE FINAL
QUESTION BEFORE I GO TO FINANCE
SAID THE. SENATE VERSION. IS
FIVE YOUR- AND A PLAY FOR OF
VIEW WERE CAL. A DOZEN THE IF
YOU WERE A ONE YEARS FOR THIS
SO THE BE SURE WHAT THE MO. IS
BEFORE US BUT THAT THE ACTUAL
PACKAGE FOR A FIVE YEAR-
PROPOSAL DOESN'T THAT IS NOT
SUPERIOR TO THE ONE YEAR
PROGRAM THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE HIS COME UP BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO USE. YOUR YOU'VE GOT
LONG TERM PLANNING IN FIRE
RESEARCH FOR PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCE HEAP OF PROPOSALS
WOULDN'T THAT GIVE YOUR CREW.
BETTER PLANNING TOOLS TO MEET
TO CHARGES OF THE NEXT. THAT
DECADE. AGAIN WITH THE WITH
THE- WITH THE RESILIENCY
PACKAGE OR THAT THAT THAT PIECE
OF THIS- THE PLANNING AND THE
LONG TERM- EFFORTS THERE THOUGH
THIS IS ONE TIME FINDING IT AS
AN EXTENDED ENCUMBRANCE AND WE
THOSE THOSE POSITIONS ARE SHOWN
AS PERMANENT POSITIONS. SO WE
WILL WE WILL WORK FORWARD- WITH
THOSE POSITIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ACCOUNTING FOR THEM
GOING DOWNSTREAM- AND THAT'S A
LITTLE SEPARATE FROM WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THIS OTHER
PROPOSALS AND THAT ZERO- SHIFT
AND THE PERMANENT HIRING OF
THOSE POSITIONS. SO WE AREN'T
IN- ICE CYCLE OF TRYING TO HIRE
THESE OR QUARTER OF CORPORATE
UNIFORMS IN PLACES WHERE WE
WHERE WE CANNOT. FILL THOSE
NEEDS ON A ON AN INCIDENT FOR
INSTANCE OKAY- LET ME GET THIS
BACK ON SCHEDULE I WANT TO GO
TO MISTER AGUILAR AT FINANCE
BUT I HAVE FORGOTTEN TO MAKE AN
IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT ON PART
BE SO COLLEAGUES PLEASE FORGIVE.
ME- THE ACTION THAT WERE TO
HERE I'M BE IS TO SEND ATOP A
ZERO OF ACTIONS ADVANCE TO THE
TROUT. AGRA AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE CONSISTING WITH THE
AGENDA. OUR LINE ON THIS OF
THIS PLAN HOWEVER AS I
INTIMATED WE'RE NOT BACKING
AWAY FROM SEVEN SET IT'S PURPLE.
FOR RATHER THEM TO THE NEXT SET
TO THE FULL BUDGET. WHERE THE
PROCESS AND DISCUSSIONS WILL
CONTINUE BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR
BEFORE YOU REACH THE FINAL
BUDGET. MEETING CELLS HAVE
INTIMATED WE STILL HAVE A FIVE
YEAR WILDFIRE PACKAGE ALTHOUGH
WE'RE TAKING ACTION TO FUNDED
FOR ONE YEAR. IF FIVE MEMBERS
CAN TURN THEIR ATTENTION TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRD. THIRTY FOUR
ON THE PARK'S PROPOSAL WE'RE
GOING TO ADD. THAT ON TO THE
BUDGET TRAILER PAYROLL BY THE
TRAILER LANGUAGE IN THE B. C.
P. ADD A FISCAL STABILITY FOR
BOATING PROGRAMS IS GOING TO BE
PULLED FROM THE- THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR AND WE WILL NOT VOTE
ON ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR.
TODAY WE'LL GET BACK TO THAT
AND WE GET TO THE SENATE ALSO
THERE'S SEVERAL ITEMS- ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT. SEVENTY NINE AND
EIGHTY ONE- WE HAVE STAFF-
WRECKED. AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO ON AND TO THE CAN OF EACH OF
THOSE WE'RE GOING ADD- THE
FOLLOWING LANGUAGE IN THIS
WOULD BE LIKE FOR INSTANCE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHTH IS
HEALTHY RESILIENT AND-
EQUITABLE FOOD SERVICES. THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PROVE HIS PROPOSED TO REQUIRE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT SO IT'S
APPROVED BUT WE HAVE- YOU KNOW
ON THE VALUE IN THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAMS
FOR THE CALIPH. OF FARM TO
SCHOOL IN COMPUTER PROGRAM
PROGRAM THE URBAN AGRICULTURAL
GRANT PROGRAM AND THE HEALTHY
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAM.
AND WE WERE FED- THIRTY SECONDS
WILL CONFORM WITH THE FINAL
AGRICULTURAL PACKAGE SO IT'S
JUST AN ADDENDUM. ULTRA PACKAGE
WITH THAT CLARIFICATION I
APOLOGIZE MISTER AGUILAR WITH
FINANCE YOU HAVE SOME COMMENTS
ON THE- THE DISCUSSION ITEMS
IT'S THIS GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
IN THE SENATE RULES. A GOOD
MORNING SURE NUMBERS OR DRUG
THAT WAS OUR FINANCE ALL KEEP
OUR COMMENTS GREAT BREACH GIVEN
THAT WE JUST THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
DURING LAST WEEK'S HEARING AND-
YOU WANT TO BE AS MUCH TIME AS
POSSIBLE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS LET ME JUST TRY TO
REITERATE I THINK FROM FROM
LAST WEEK'S HEARING- YOU KNOW
OVERALL WHEN YOU COMBINE THE
WALL TO WALL. CLIMATE RELATED
PACKAGES ADMINISTRATION ROLE IS
OVER ELEVEN POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS AND A STRATEGIC AND
ONCE IN A LIFETIME INVESTMENTS
TO HELP ADVANCE SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CLIMATE
INITIATIVES. I THINK AS WAS
NOTED EARLIER HE NOTED THERE
DOES APPEAR TO BE A GREAT DEAL
OF OVERLAP AND IN MANY CASES
ALIGNMENTS AND SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THOSE PROPOSED AND AS PART
OF THE VARIOUS SENATE
PROPOSALS- AND YOU KNOW WE CAN
DO TO SUPPORT ADMINISTRATION
MAYOR VISIN PROPOSALS BACK
KNOWLEDGE THERE WILL BE.
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS ON THE
DETAILS OF THESE PACKAGES AS A
BUDGET IS BEING FINALIZED AND
WE HAVE A VERY IS FINE AND
STAFF AND DEPARTMENT STAFF
AVAILABLE TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS- ON. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PACKAGES. OKAY
THANK YOU WE WILL OBVIOUSLY
YOUR INPUT LET'S TURN TO SAY
SIR. ON OUR- THIS. ITEMS THANK
YOU MR CHAIR- ONE OF GET TO.
PROPER I'M NOT SURE WHICH
DEPARTMENT THEY SHOULD GO
THROUGH BUT I WANT TO GET THE
ROOT. SOME FEEDBACK FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON A FEW ITEMS-
STARTING WITH THE WATER AND
DROUGHT PACKAGE IN THE
COMPARISONS HERE- FOR ME LA-
ANALYSIS FROM STAFF ANALYSIS
WE'VE SEEN. IT SEEMS TO BE A
DISPARITY BETWEEN THE SENATE
PROPOSAL AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ON
RECYCLED WATER GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP AND STORMWATER
MANAGEMENT SO I WAS HOPING I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THOSE HOPING TO GET- SOME
COMMENTS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON- WHAT LOOKS
LIKE A- SIGNIFICANTLY SMALLER
AMOUNT ALLOCATED TO THOSE.
ELEMENTS OF RESPONSE WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT 60% OF THE STATE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- WITH
SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM WATER
NEEDS FOR THIS ONE TIME
INVESTMENT- WE JUST GOT SOME
LETTERS FROM OUR YOU KNOW FROM
SAN DIEGO AND LA WHO USUALLY
AREN'T ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
WATER- TALKING ABOUT THEIR
ABILITY TO EXPAND UP TO TWO
BILLION DOLLARS SHOVEL READY
RIGHT NOW SO I JUST WANTED TO
GET A SENSE FROM- THE LOGIC OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S. MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL ON THOSE
ELEMENTS. THIRD ROAD RUNNING
FINE AND I'LL JUST I'LL KICK IT
OFF AND THEN- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
COLLEAGUES HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THAT COULD SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT TO THE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS. I THINK ONE THING.
THEY'LL START OFF BY NOTING IS.
ACROSS SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS
VERY VERY S. ELIGIBLE USES AND
DIFFERENT ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES
AND SO EVEN THOUGH FOR EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T SEE.
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP CALLED OUT
SPECIFICALLY IN SOME OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THEY ARE LIKE AN
ELIGIBLE USE OF OTHER TYPES OF.
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE LIKE A LUMP
AND DOLLAR AMOUNTS AND SO
THAT'S KIND OF THE ONE OF THE-
ADS WERE BEING CROSSWALKS OF A
LOT OF THESE PACKAGES
SOMETIMES. WERE CALLING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY BUT BUT YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE A LOT OF SIMILAR
ELIGIBLE USES WITHIN THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TARGETING
ALSO WROTE BY NOTING THAT- THEN
THE OTHER YOU KNOW JUST ISSUE
ALTHOUGH IT IS- YOU KNOW AS WE
WERE LOOKING AT- THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDING AND WE-
ALLOCATED DOLLARS TOWARDS THAT-
THERE'S SPECIFIC TIMELINES
THAT- KIND OF IDENTIFIED AS-
WHEN. THE MONEY NEED TO BE
COVERED- IN LIQUIDATED A PART
OF COUNTRY TO THE WE HAD A SOME
OF THESE INVESTOR. I WAS
LOOKING. YOU KNOW WHERE THERE
ARE SOME SOME PROJECTS. COULD
MEET THOSE THOSE. RE SO JUST A
THINGS AND- BUT NOT SURE IF-
BUT THE WAY BORDER OR DEPART A
WATERY. AS ANY MORE DETAILS ASK
TO OF THEIR PER. AND HOW. IT
ADDRESSES RECYCLING AND GARBAGE
WATER THE. THIS WILL STORM
WATER COULD. YOUR HIGHNESS IS
MY LAW WITH CLOSE LOTTERY.
CONTROL BOARD AND WE ADMINISTER
BOTH THE WATER IS AND
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP FUNDING AND
THE AS FAR AS WATERY. THAT MOST
ARE ELEGY FOR OUR STATE
REVOLVING LOAN FUNDS AND SO
THAT IS TO PICK WHERE WE FUND
WATER RECYCLE PROJECT. WE OFTEN
DO HAVE A SMALL AMOUNT OF GRANT
FUNDS THAT THAT GO ALONG WITH
THOSE PHONES BUT THEY'RE
GENERALLY TOWARDS THE LARGER
MORE SOPHISTICATED AGENCIES
THAT ARE DOING THOSE TYPES OF
PROJECTS AND SO WHAT WE FOCUSED
ON WHAT'S THE WATER LIKE
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER.
FUNDING FROM THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN IS AS MISTER
AGYARKO INDICATED WE'RE
PROJECTS THAT COULD MEET THE
TIMING OF THE VERY SHORT TIME
FRAMES FOR CONSTRUCTING THOSE
PROJECTS AND ALSO FOCUSING ON
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY NEEDS
SO WE REALLY FOCUSED. THOSE
FUNDS ON ON THOSE PROJECTS AND
THE PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE
PRETTY MUCH IN HOUSE READY TO
GO. THAT COULD MEET THOSE
CONSTRUCTION TIME FRAMES. OKAY
I WOULD JUST NOTE FOR THEIR FOR
THE RECORD THAT YOUR YOUR
ANALYSIS- FROM THE WATER BOARD
INDICATES I THINK SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE. READY TO GO
SO. AS I KNOW THAT'LL BE AN
ONGOING ISSUE FOR DISCUSSION
AND APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE.
ON THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PACKAGE OPEN TO GET. HOPING TO
RAISE THE QUESTION ON THIS-
THIS DISPARITY BETWEEN THE
SENATE'S MAY TWENTY FIFTH
PROPOSAL AND THEN THE MAY
REVISE- ON A REGIONAL CLIMATE
RESILIENCE- SPECIFICALLY IN
THE- FIRST STATE CONSERVANCIES.
AS WELL AS THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PROJECTS I THINK THE
SENATE HAS SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION. DOLLARS THERE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS- ZERO IN
THOSE CATEGORIES- THAT'S A
CHALLENGE- THE LA RIVER ALSO IN
URBAN STREAMS HAS ZERO- SIR
TWENTY GET THEIR PERSPECTIVE I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S BEST.
CENTER D. O. F. OR C. N. R. A.
BUT HOPING TO- SHED SOME LIGHT
ON THOSE DISPARITIES AS WELL.
GO AHEAD. FINANCE IF YOU CAN S.
OR DIFFERENT FINANCING I'LL
KICK IT OFF AND THEN MAYBE A
TURNOVER TO LIE RESEARCH AGENCY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD ON THE ONE
THING ALTHOUGH IT IS YOU KNOW
FOR THE PROGRAMS THAT WE DO
HAVE THE CONSERVANCY'S AND THE
PROJECTS WITHIN THE
CONSERVANCIES ARE DEFINITELY
ELIGIBLE AND SO EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY CALLING
OUT YOU KNOW X. DOLLAR MATRYX
CONSERVANCIES THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THAT THE PROJECTS AND THE
PROGRAMS WITHIN THOSE I WOULD
NOT BE ELIGIBLE SO- YEAH I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF PERSPECTIVE
IS HAVING. A BROADER PROGRAM ON
ON THE SPECIFIC ISSUE AND THEN
WITHIN THAT PROGRAM- YOU KNOW
HAVING THE PROJECTS WITH THE
CONSERVANCY'S BE ABLE TO APPLY
TO ALSO MEET THOSE GOALS NOT
SURE THE RESERVATIONS. HERE
ANYTHING ELSE- ELABORATE ON
THAT. I WAS GONNA SAY THE SAME
THING THAT. I CAN. ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE OTHER PROGRAM THIS IS
CASH THE NATURAL RESOURCE THEY-
DO. AND AS TO THE RIVER AND THE
OTHER URBAN AND RIVER. THERE IS
FUNDING LIKE URBAN GREENING-
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO TWO
PROJECTS- GREENING PROJECTS
THAT COULD BE DONE ALONG THE LA
RIVER. IMPORTANT IF THE YEAH
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT SORT OF
THE OVERALL WATERSHED
PROTECTION ISSUE THOUGH WE'RE
WE'VE GOT I THINK THE SENATE'S
GOT EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION COMMITTED TO THAT AND
THERE'S ABOUT A SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR DISPARITY
BETWEEN OUR PROPOSAL AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THERE
WHERE- EVEN IF THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE'S-
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO MEET
THOSE SORT OF MULTI BENEFIT
NEEDS SO- JUST TO TRY TO GET.
SORT OF THE UNDERLYING POLICY.
BECTIVE ON WHY THAT'S NOT AS
MUCH OF A PRIORITY. THIS IS
BRIAN CASH AGAIN FROM NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY- WE DO FEEL
LIKE THOSE THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
PRIORITY AND- WHERE POSSIBLE
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING
IN OTHER PROGRAMS AND- YOU KNOW
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY. THROUGH THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE TO-
FURTHER REFINED THE PACKAGE
THAT NEEDED. WE ARE JUST NOTE
DEPUTY CASHIN FOR FINANCE ALSO
SAID THERE WAS THE GOVERNOR
EARLIER HAD A CLIMATE BOND THAT
THAT HE HAD FLOATED OUT THE
SENATE HAS A PUBLIC CLIMATE.
THE ASSEMBLY HAS A CLAIM UPON
AND ONE OF THE CATEGORIES THAT
THEY WERE LOOKING AT IS THE
WATERSHED PROTECTION THE SORT
OF STARTS OFF AT THE WATERSHED
YES THERE'S EXTREME HEAT
ELEMENTS THAT WITH THE URBAN
GREENING BUT THERE THERE IS
SEEM TO BE- I'VE- BEEN
INTERESTED IN WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT WE JUST HAVEN'T
SEEN IT IN THE BUDGET NUMBERS
AS AS AS AS THE ENTHUSIASM I
GUESS IS WHAT. MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR STERN IS SEARCHING FOR
INDEED WEALTH WELL SUMMARIZED
IN YOU KNOW WE PUT A LOT OF
TIME INTO SP FORTY FIVE AND
LOOKS LIKE A LOT OF THAT'S
GOING TO BE FOLDED INTO HIS
BUDGET SO REALLY HOPING THE
SENATE'S PRIORITIES CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN MAINTAIN SOME FOOTING
AND AS THE AS THE CONVERSATIONS
GO FORWARD- YOU KNOW LASTLY I
WOULD JUST RAISE. THE YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR ME PAYING THAT THE
SAME FROM THE SERMON CHOIR DID-
WHEN IT COMES TO- FUNDING ON ON
THE HAND CREW SIDE AND TRYING
TO GET. OUR CONTRACT COUNTY
SORTED BUT ALSO FROM HARDENING
AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE
PERSPECTIVE IT SEEMS LIKE- THAT
THERE CONTINUES TO BE A SORT OF
LESSER ROLE ON THAT THE
HARDENING FRONT AT LEAST IN THE
NEAR TERM AND MUCH MORE FOCUSED
ON- FORCED HEALTH- TYPE
PROJECTS OR OTHER SORT OF FUEL
TREATMENT PROJECTS- TELEPHONE A
FLAG THAT I DON'T KNOW IF THE-
CAL FIRE HAS ANY COMMENT THERE
BUT- REALLY TRYING TO. FIND A
PATH EITHER THROUGH PUBLIC
FINDING OR INCENTIVIZING MORE
PRIVATE ACTION TO GET SOME
METRICS INTO PLACE SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE SOME GOALS STAND
FOR JUST RECOMMENDED A CO EQUAL
FUNDING ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
INTO FOR FUEL TREATMENT THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS SHOULD BE
UNLOCKED SOMEHOW- ON THE
HARDENING FRONT FOR SEVEN CAL.
AND OTHER. THAT HAVE UNIQUE
NEEDS. JUST WANT TO FLAG FOR
THE G. ANY PURSE. THERE THOUGH-
TO LEND US I KNOW YOU GUYS BEEN
WORKING YOUR G. P. IN. TRYING
TO GET THAT MOVE. YES SIR AGAIN
THANK YOU SENATOR WHITEHOUSE
DEEPER AND OLDER YES WITH THE
WITH GRAPHS SENATOR STRANGE
QUESTION. I LOOK FORWARD TO.
CONTINUING THIS THIS
CONVERSATION- MORE SPECIFICALLY
IN THE FUTURE BUT FOR RIGHT
NOW- OUR OUR PROGRAMS. ARE VERY
EVENLY- COVERING THE STATE. NOW
WE ARE- WE ARE WORKING TO
INCREASE OUR APPLICANT POOL AND
THE QUALITY OF THOSE
APPLICANTS. AND APPLICATIONS
PROBLEM AREAS THAT HAVE- BAND
I'LL JUST STAY UNDER SERVED BY
OUR PROGRAMS- AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS. AND LOCAL
ELECTED- SO WE ARE VERY MUCH
WORKING WITH DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION IN THE REGIONAL
COLLABORATIVES THAT ARE ARE-
BEING STOOD UP THROUGH THIS
PROCESS- HOPEFULLY- THE BUDGET
WILL- WILL. PASS IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURETHAT E HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY TO LOOK AT REGIONAL
REGIONALLY PLANNING. ANTI THOSE
LOCAL GROUPS AND PUT OUR ARMS
AROUND THEM. AT THE REGIONAL
LEVEL. TO BETTER POSITION DOWN
TO RECEIVE FUNDING FROM ALL
SOURCES INCLUDING CAL FIRE SO.
CAL FIRE THE CONSERVANCY'S- THE
OTHER AGENCIES HAVING- GRANT
PROGRAMS WE'LL ALL BE
COLLABORATING WITH THOSE
REGIONAL COLLABORATIVES. TO
HAVE A KOBE- OUTCOME HE SAID
APPROACH TO THAT. THAT WILL
IMMENSELY HELP- RIDICULOUSLY
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA
THAT'S BEEN KIND OF- KIND OF
SPREAD OUT IN THERE- YEAH.
CASSIDY TO DO THIS- BUT- WE
WILL BRING THAT UNDER- THAT
GROUP AND THEN CAL FIRE WILL BE
A PART OF THAT AS WELL AS OUR
OUR- SISTER APARTMENT IN
AGENCIES. IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE GET MONEY TO WHERE THE NEED
IS FOR THE NEW THAT I DON'T.
THANK YOU THAT THE CHIEF PORTER
AND- FOR THE END THERE GOING
FOR THAT I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
BELOW MORE IN. OR RIP BUT IF WE
CAN FIND SOME WAY. TO HAVE OF
CODE. STATE WHY HARDENING.
THAT'S OF MATCH ALONG WITH SOME
THE ACRE GOALS AND GIVE OUR OF
THE SOME GOAL NOT TO THROUGH AN
ONLY PUBLIX. I THINK THAT COULD
HELP DIRECTOR STRATEGY HERE'S
BUT SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS IN THEIR
FLEXIBILITY AND THEY'RE WILLING
TO PAY IT WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
ON THESE TO REGIONAL. REGIONAL
APPROACHES TO THE FIRE ISSUE SO
THANKS. SENATOR DOLLY YOU'RE A
NICE DETERMINANT ALL THE START
OFF WITH THE- FOLLOW UP ON THE
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE TAXES FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION- IN THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FROM GEORGIA
WHICH IS ONE TIME FINDINGS-
WHICH I TAKE TO SOMETHING WE
NEED TO ADDRESS FOR. ITS SHOULD
BE ONGOING FUNDING IN MY
OPINION BUT WHAT I HAD A
QUESTION ON HOW MANY ACRES-
WITH THIS FUNDING TREAT. AT
RESEARCH AGENCY. WARM CAL FIRED
FIFTY WHO WOULD LIKE TO-
RESPOND. SENATOR DOLLY THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND- I CAN
GIVE YOU SOME SORT OF BROAD
PARAMETERS BUT I THINK IT
ACTUALLY GETS BACK TO KIND OF
THE EARLIER CONVERSATION WE'RE
HAVING I'M SO YOU KNOW THERE'S
YOU WORK BACK AND BACK OF THE
ENVELOPE ESTIMATE IS THAT IT'S
ABOUT JUDGE THOUSAND DOLLARS AN
ACRE- ON AVERAGE AND- AND SO
THIS COULD TREAT IN TOTAL NINE
ONE YEAR BUT IN TOTAL WITH
THESE DOLLARS AS THEY- GET
EXECUTED ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES- THAT BITE AGAIN
THAT IS A VERY ROUGH. BALLPARK
AND IT ACTUALLY GETS INTO SOME
OF THESE MORE DETAILS ABOUT
WHAT WHAT IS MEDITATION
TREATMENT PROGRAM- SAYS- VERSUS
HOW WOULD THESE DOLLARS BE
SPENT INTO REGIONAL STRATEGIES
FOR EXAMPLE ARE FORCED HEALTH
GRANT DOLLARS- ARE COMING INTO
COMMUNITIES- AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SOMETIMES
THEY'RE TREATING ACRE SOMETIMES
ARE MOVING BUDGET YEAH INVASIVE
SPECIES OUR FIRE PREVENTION
GRANT DOLLARS EACH YEAR-
SOMETIMES THOSE ARE TREATING
ACRES WITH STRATEGIC SHE'LL
BREAK SOMETIMES. THOSE ARE
GOING INTO EDUCATION OUTREACH-
AND HELPING COMMUNITIES ON THAT
MORE DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND HOME
GARDENING SO HE'S- GRANT
DOLLARS BY VIRTUE OF BEING
FAIRLY BROAD AREN'T NECESSARILY
A LITERAL ONE PER ONE
TRANSLATION OF BENCH MANAGEMENT
VERSES. FIRST NAME I'M
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND SOME OF
THESE OTHER INVESTMENTS-
ANOTHER POINT I WANTED TO MAKE
ON SENATOR STERN'S EARLIER
QUESTION IS REALLY HOW CRITICAL
THESE ARE EIGHT BEAST REGIONAL
STRATEGIES ARE TO JUST
UNDERSCORE WHAT SHE WAS SAYING
THAT THE GOAL IS FOR THE
REGIONAL STRATEGIES TO BAND
DIRECTOR R. GRANT DOLLARS AND
THESE BROAD GRAND BUCKETS. INTO
THE PRIORITIES THAT THE REGION
IS IDENTIFYING WHICH INCLUDES
HOME HARDENING AND- IN THE
FUTURE WE ABSOLUTELY DO YOU
WANT TO SCALE UP HOME HARDENING
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE DIRECT ASSISTANCE ON
HOME GARDENING. IS A NEW
PROGRAM THAT MISSTATES A
PROGRAM THAT I WE ARE LONG THIS
YEAR THIS THE FIRST TIME. IT IS
GETTING UNDER AND SO ARE PART A
HOW MILLION DOLLARS. TO BE ABLE
TO. THE MODEL AND THEN SCALE IT.
SO EVENTUALLY WE WANT TO SEE IF
I MANAGE AND- HARDENING. INTO.
SEEING SO. I'M CONCERNED THAT
WHAT THE HELL WE'RE GONNA TRACK
IT NOW WE'RE GOING TO SEE OUR
OUTCOMES IS GONNA BE CRITICAL
FOR THE FUTURE WITH IT WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK THAT WE NEED TO
DO SO WOULD IS THERE SOME- DATA
POINTS IN. THE PART IN THIS
POLICY THAT ALLOWS US TO FIGURE
OUT AND BE ABLE TO TRACK WORLD.
WE'RE ALL THESE BUCKETS OF.
RESOURCES ARE GOING AND THEN SO
LATER ON WE CAN LOOK BACK. AND
GO THIS MUCH WENT TO HOME
HARDENING THIS MUCH WENT TWO.
ACRES TREATED THIS TO THIS TOOK
CARE OF THIS COMMUNITY FOR WHAT
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS ARE SO I
JUST WANTED. MAKE A NOTE- THAT
I WOULD. WE BUY REMAKE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THAT IN THERE SO THAT WE CAN
COME BACK AND ANALYZE LATER
BECAUSE WE KNOW- THAT WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO IN WILDFIRE
AREAS AND EVEN IN THAT THE
DROUGHT STUFF TOO. BUT WE GOT A
WE NEED A MECHANISM TO COME
BACK IN AND BE ABLE TO TRACK
WHERE EVERYTHING WENT IN AND
WHERE WE GET THE BEST BANG FOR
BUCK AND WHERE DID IT RIGHT
BECAUSE I THINK. YOU KNOW
FUTURE- WE'RE GONNA HAVE A LOT
OF- A LOT MORE NEEDS. AND TO
FIND OUT WHICH PROGRAMS WORK
WELL SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR DOLLY AND-
AND WE ARE TRACKING IT- EVEN
THOUGH THE GRANT APPLICATIONS
ARE VERY BROAD AND COMMUNITIES
CAN ASK FOR WHAT THEY NEED- WE
ARE TRACKING WHERE THESE
DOLLARS ARE GOING IN WITH A
GREAT DEAL OF DEPTH AND ALSO.
USE SPEECH AND TRACKING WHERE
THEY ARE GOING ON THE LANDSCAPE
AND WHAT IS YOUR STREET AND
WHAT IS DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND
THEN ALSO IN THIS BUDGET IS
FIFTEEN MILLION PER SPECIAL ADD
DATA ACQUISITION SO THAT WE CAN
NOT ONLY TRACK RESPECTIVELY
WHAT WE'RE DOING. BUT BUT
MONITOR IT AS WELL YOU SHOULD.
GET THE MOST REFINED MODELS
IMPROVE OUR DATA LAYERS SO THAT
WE ARE SEEING THE IMPACT ON THE
LANDSCAPE ON THE WATERSHED-
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE
INVESTING IN YOUR ACTION FOR.
FOREST HEALTH UP IN HIGH SIERRA
FOR EXAMPLE THAT IS ALSO
IMPROVING OUR WATERSHED
RESILIENCE AND BIODIVERSITY AND
EXPANDING ALL THESE OF COURSE
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES AS WELL SO
WHEN WE'RE NOT ONLY GOING TO BE
TRACKING YOUR STREET AND WHERE
THEY ARE AND WHO'S DOING WHAT
WITH THESE. THESE DOLLARS- BUT
WE WILL ALSO BE- INVESTING IN
IMPROVING OUR MODELING SO THAT
WE CAN. TRACK BETTER MONITORING
SO THAT WE CAN BETTER
ARTICULATE WHEN WE ARE MAKING
AN INVESTMENT OF COURSE TELL
HOW IT'S ALSO INVESTING NOT
ONLY IN COMMUNITY SAFETY AND
WILDFIRES LATE BUT ALSO
IMPROVING WATERSHED HEALTH AND-
AND MITIGATING DROUGHT
CONSEQUENCES. THANK YOU. NOW
ONE OF TO GO TO A NINETY WHICH
IS WATER RESILIENT PACKAGE
WHICH IS FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION- WE HAVE ONE BILLION
DIRECTLY RELATED TO WATER
SUPPLIERS IN ITS WELCOME STEP
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THE DEBT
BACKLOG BUT IT WON'T SOLVE THE
REVENUE PROBLEM UNLESS THE
MORATORIUM IS LIFTED- IN HERE
WE KNOW THAT TO SENATOR DODD
HAS SP NINE NINE EIGHT WHICH
PROTECTS CUSTOMERS FROM SHUT
OFFS. FOR AT LEAST SIXTY DAYS
AND REQUIRES PAYMENTS THE
PAYMENT PLAN TO BE OFFERED THAT
REMOVING THE MORATORIUM WILL
NOT RE RESULT IN IMMEDIATE
TERMINATION OF SERICES SO FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN. IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN TO LIFT THE
MORATORIUM ON WATER SHUTOFFS. A
THIRD PARTY FINANCING FOR
SAVING WILL HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON ON THAT QUESTION. OKAY
WHAT ARE THE WHAT ARE THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR CRITERIA WILL
BE APPLIED FOR THE ALLOCATION
OF THE FUNDS. WE HAVE A-
CALLING FROM- WATER BORDER PULL
HUMANS WHO COULD TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE ONE BILLION
WATER REGIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU
SERGIO UNDERPLAYING SOME DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
DRINKING WATER. WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH- THE CRITERIA NOW AND
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT IS HOW TO. HELP
ADDRESS YOUR REGS THAT WATER
SYSTEMS I THINK FOR. ACTIVE
THERE'S TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
PLUS WATER SYSTEMS AND
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S A VERY LARGE
NUMBER OF THE BULK OF THOSE ARE
REALLY SMALL OVER HALF OF THOSE
ARE UNDER. A THOUSAND
CONNECTIONS- AND- AS WE GO THE
CRITERIA WERE. GOING TO OUR TO
FIGURE. OUT- WHAT THEY'RE LOSS.
MAY HAVE BEEN TRY TO UNDER. THE
ORIGINAL THEY DO SAY PRESENTLY.
ARE AND TRYING DECIDE THAT BOTH
ALLOWS THEM. QUICKLY I RECEIVED
SOME ASSISTANCE.WITH THE LOSS
OF REVENUE THAT DAVE US SEEN
THAT CAN IMPACT OF THE- CODE
THAT. AND MOVE FORWARD INTO. A
BETTER POSITION. FROM THAT NOW
WE BE ABLE TO ADDRESS EVERY
RIDGES EXACTLY AS YOU ARE
SYNCING IT PROBABLY NOT NOT IF
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A FAST
PROGRAM. AND I'LL BE ABLE TO
BRING THAT TO BEAR SUCH THAT.
WOULD GET THEM ON ON BETTER
FOOTING THAN THEY ARE NOW. AND
MOVE MOVE FORWARD IN THAT
FASHION. WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT. INFORMATION BUT FOR THOSE
OF US WHO REPRESENT A LOT OF
SMALL DISHES I'D FIRST LIKE THE
I DON'T THINK THERE'S GONNA BE
ENOUGH FUNDS TO. PICK UP THE
BACK DEBT AND AS YOU'RE
PROBABLY AWARE THAT. THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS IN
WATER PROVIDERS HAVE NO ABILITY
UNDER PROP TWO EIGHTEEN TO BE
ABLE TO RAISE REVENUE SO WE- DO
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR
TOOK A- STANCE TO ALLOW PEOPLE
NOT TO PAY THEIR BILL. AND NOW
WE'RE THANKFULLY WE HAVE SOME
SOME RESOURCES COMING IN FROM
THE- A. A. A. R. P. A. WHICH
ALLOWS US TO DO TO HELP IN THAT
IN THIS SITUATION BUT THE
PROBLEM STILL EXISTS. THAT IF
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
GO AROUND. AND PEOPLE ARE STILL
ALLOWED NOT TO PAY THEIR BILL
WITHOUT BEING SHUT OFF FROM THE
WATER AND EVEN THE DOT PLAN
ALLOW SIXTY DAYS- WE STILL HAVE
A PROBLEM SO I WOULD I'M
REQUESTING MORE DETAIL ON HOW
WE ROLL THIS PLAN OUT BECAUSE I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S GONNA BE
ENOUGH MONEY TO TAKE CARE OF
THAT. EVERYBODY THAT'S IN THE
REAR H. AND WE'RE STILL FACED
WITH THE PROBLEM AFTER WE PAY
THE BILL SO. IF SOMEBODY CAN
GET THAT BACK TO ME I DON'T
EXPECT YOU TO HAVE THAT MUCH
DETAIL TODAY BUT IT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL- BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY AND WE'RE
GONNA BE HERE IN THE FUTURE.
THE. AND LASTLY MR TERRIFIED
COULD ASK ONE LAST QUESTION OF
THE COMMITTEE. YEAH PRETTY
THOROUGH WE'RE GONNA BE VOTING
ON THE. PART A AND PART B. AND
THEN THERE'S. I GUESS THE ISSUE
NINETY THROUGH. NINETY THREE
TWO THREE THIS CAN BE HELD OPEN
AND IT'S GOING TO GO TO. A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. BETWEEN
THE SENATE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS THAT
CORRECT. YES SO WHERE DOES THE
PUBLIC GET A CHANCE TO WEIGH IN
THIS IS THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN BUT THEY HAVE NO
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE DETAILS
OF HOW WHAT COMES OUT OF THAT
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. WILL
THERE BE A PUBLIC HEARING AT
THE SENATE LEVEL SO THAT
DISCUSSIONS ARE GOING ON NOW
WITH ALL THE PARTIES ON
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS WERE. WE
HAVE UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A JUNE
FIFTEEN DEADLINES WERE SORT OF
WORKING BACKWARDS FROM FROM
THERE SO THEY'LL BE. L. B.
INPUT AT THE FULL BUDGET
HEARINGS AND THEN ON THE FLOOR
THEY'LL BE THEY'LL BE INFERRED.
BUT FOR THE PUBLIC TO ME
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL GET TO WEIGH
IN ON THOSE WITH AS THERE IS
THIS. AFTER THAT GOES TO THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AND THEN
AND THEN THE BUDGET COMES OUT
WHERE IS THE PUBLIC HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN. WELL
THESE THESE THESE THESE ITEMS
ARE ARE LEFT OPEN AND THEY'RE
GONNA GO TO THE CONFERENCE
ORDERS AGAIN NOT GOING TO BE A
DECISION TODAY. ON THESE ITEMS
CORRECT. THIS IS MY FIRST EVER
GOLD EXCEPT FOR THE YES THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT TO THE ACTUAL
CATEGORIES THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE AND WE ARE TAKING CARE OF
THE ACTIONS. THAT WE'RE TAKING.
YOU KNOW ON THE- PHONE FOR
INSTANCE ON THE CLIMATE IS THAT
WEIRD WE'RE GOING TO TAKE AN
ACTION TO. HAVE THE SENATE ANY
MYSTERY ADMINISTRATIONS
RESILIENCY PACKAGE APPROVED AT
THREE POINT SIX SEVEN FIVE
BILLION. BUT THE DETAILS AND
THE DISCREPANCIES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. I HAVE TO BE
FIGURED OUT AND THEN THERE'S
ALSO THE JUNIOR BUDGET AND THE
BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE SO WE
MAY NOT GET THE ACTUAL
CATEGORIES DOWN WE MAY BE
COMING BACK AFTER JUNE
FIFTEENTH IN THIS COMMITTEE. TO
WORK OUT SOME OF THE OTHER
PROPOSALS ON THE DETAILS SO WE
MAY HAVE A DOLLAR AMOUNT. THAT
WE THAT WE END ON BUT THE
PROGRAMMING IT'S A FLUID
SITUATION CENTER. I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE UNDER UNDERSTAND NOT
ONLY FOR ME BUT FOR THE PUBLIC
AS WELL. THAT IF WE'RE GONNA
ADOPT A BUDGET. BY JUNE
FIFTEENTH THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WE KNOW THAT. AND THEN
THERE'S GOING TO BE. THEN WE
pAND SPEND SOME OF THAT HAS
DOLLAR AMOUNTS AND THEN THOSE
CATEGORIES MAYBE MOVED AROUND
WITH THE PUBLIC DOESN'T HAVE A
POINT OF OPPORTUNITY THAT POINT
UNLESS THERE'S A TRAILER BILL
THAT COMES THROUGH- AND IT'S
BEEN IT'S NOT IF IT'S NOT HEARD
IN A COMMITTEE. THERE'S NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
COMMENT IF IT'S HURTING THE
COMMITTEE THEY HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY I MEAN AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HAVING THIS PUBLIC
HEARING AND WHAT WE TRY TO
PRESENT AT LEAST THE PACKAGES
WITH THE COLUMNS SO AT LEAST
HE'S TRYING TO MAKE IT EASIER
OTHERS WE GOT THE BUDGET JUST
LIKE. EVERYBODY GOT THE BUDGET
MORE TRYING TO POLICE IN THIS
COMMITTEE CREATE THE COLUMN SO
PEOPLE KNOW WHICH HAPPENS IN
JANUARY WHAT DID THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED WHAT DID THE SENATE
PROPOSAL LOOKS LIKE SO AT
LEAST. YOU SEE. IT WAS BE TRUE
YOUR CRAP WE WON'T KNOW EXACT
AHLERS FOR DELETION OF THE
DISCREPANCIES OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO RESOLVE. WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT I JUST I MEAN
FOR ME I DON'T KNOW MAYBE YOU
GUYS BEEN DOING THIS A LOT
LONGER BUT- IT'S BEEN
OVERWHELMING TO TRY TO KEEP
TRACK OF. THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT IS BEING. ALLOCATED AND
SPENT AND IF WE HAD THE EARLY
ACTION NOW WE'VE GOT THE NOW
WE'RE DOING THE REGULAR BUDGET
AND I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT'S
LIKE FOR THE PUBLIC TO FIGURE
OUT I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
WATER AGENCIES HAVE CALLED ME
AND ASKED ME YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S
GONNA LOOK LIKE THAT'S WHY I'M
TRYING TO GET SOME DETAIL TODAY
SO IF I CAN'T IF I'M HAVING
DIFFICULTY TRACKING IT TO
SOMEBODY THAT'S IN THE KNOW
AND- SO IT'S SOMEWHAT IN THE
KNOW HERE I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT
IT'S LIKE FOR. THE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO TRACK THE
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
BEING ALLOCATED ACROSS THE
BOARD WHETHER IT'S- NOT JUST
THE- THE- THINGS THAT WERE
CHARGD WITH BUT THE OTHER
COMMITTEES THAT ARE DOING FINE
IN. THE SUB ONES INTO THE OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEES. I MEAN THERE'S
JUST A LOT OF RESOURCES BEING
MOVED AROUND CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW AND I. HAVE NO DOUBT AND I
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
LOOK AT CENTER DR FORGOT TO SAY
THAT ONCE THE CONFERENCE.
COMMITTEE ACTION IS TAKEN. THAT
WILL COME BACK TO THE FULL
BUDGET WE WON'T NECESSARILY
HEAR IT HERE I DON'T THINK
THERE'S- THE PLAN IS IT WILL BE
AT THE- AT THE FULL BUDGET. AND
IT WILL BE. SEVEN ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SO WE'LL ALL BE IN
THERE WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT.
THE ELEMENTS THAT WE AGREE ON
AND THE ELEMENTS THAT WE MOVED
TO BUDGET YOU IN YOUR OR
SOMETHING SO THERE'S- THERE'S
THIS HEARING THERE'S A FULL
BUDGET HEARING AND THEN THERE'S
A CONFERENCE HERE SO THERE WILL
BE. IT IS FLUID AND IT'S A LOT
NO DOUBT. THANK YOU. ARE ARE
YOU. OKAY SO I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION I THINK MR YOUR BURL-
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES WE SEE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S TRIAL PACKAGE-
FORWARD DEPARTMENT WHERE
RESOURCES THE ORVILLE PUMPED
STORAGE PROJECT IN MY UNDERSIDE
VISITED TO PUMP STORAGE
FACILITIES BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT'S AN ENERGY- PUB
ELEMENT NOT A TROUT OR
RESILIENCY DOESN'T PRODUCE ANY
MORE WATER IN A PUMPED STORAGE
SPA FACILITY. FINE INVESTMENT
AND THIS MAY BE THE RIGHT PLACE
TO DO IT COULD YOU COMMENT ON.
THE THAT OBSERVATION OR
SOMEBODY HAD RESOURCES. SURE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION IT
ALL BECAUSE FOR A SECOND AND
SEE IF- WHEN MY RESOURCES
HOLLINGS HAS A COMMON FIRST AND
THEN ALL I CAN FOLLOW ON. SIX
IT IT'S SNOWED HERE GETS A CALL
AND ANYBODY ON THE LIST AND
YOU'RE LUCKY IN A LUCKY ONE-
TEMPE OUR PROPERTIES. I CAN SEE
WHETHER THAT THE CANAL REPAIRS
WILL STOP LEAKAGE AND STOP
WATER FROM SEEPING. LEAVE
LEAVING THE CHANNEL SO THAT.
CREATES MORE WATER PRINT- SO TO
SPEAK BUT THE PUMP STORAGE PER
SE I DON'T SEE HOW THAT HELPS
OUR DROUGHT. GO AHEAD. HELLO I
CAN I CAN TALK A BIT ABOUT THE
PROJECT THERE AND SO- YES THIS
PROJECT WOULD ALLOW FOR PUMPED
STORAGE OPERATIONS AT THE
ORACLE FACILITY. IN THE IN THE
REAL BENEFIT THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT. THAT WOULD ACCRUE
THERE HE IS REALLY SUPPORTING
ENERGY GRID- SUPPORTING THE-
WHICH IN TURN HELPS SUPPORT THE
CLAIM REJECTED IN THE STATE SO.
THERE IS A BIG ENERGY COMPONENT
THAT IS THE MAIN. BENEFICIARY
OF THOSE PUB ON STORAGE
OPERATIONS. OKAY THANK YOU I
HAVE A QUESTION ON. WHICH WE
TALKED ABOUT ON ON THE TRIAL
DEMONSTRATES THE DROP PACKAGE
WERE I'M GOING IN ON THE
AGRICULTURAL WATER EFFICIENCY.
THE SENATE PROPOSAL HAS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION VERSUS
THE GOVERNOR HAS SIXTY MILLION
AND I. TRYING TO WEIGH THE
DIFFERENT DISTINCTION BETWEEN
IMMEDIATE BENEFITS IT'S FOUR IN
THE IN THE AGRICULTURAL FIELD
INTO THE STATE WITH THESE WITH
SWEEP INVESTMENTS VERSUS LONG
TERM- INVESTMENTS AND I WAS
HOPING THAT. THAT SOMEBODY AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF. AGRICULTURE
COULD WERE WATER RESOURCES. IS
WE'RE LOOKING TO AS A DROUGHT
PACKAGE IT SEEMS THAT THERE'S A
VALUE IN THE AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR TO GET IMMEDIATE SAVINGS
ANY MEDIA. REALIZATION OF- MORE
WATER BY INVESTING IN WATER
EFFICIENCIES. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR- I'M RETURNING I'M NOT
GONNA SAY KERR FOUND THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE NECK YEAH. I
CAN TAKE YOUR QUESTION ON SWEEP
STREETS UNDER THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
INNOVATION- SO THESE ARE
PROJECTS TAKING A BATH FROM
TWELVE. TO SIXTEEN MONTHS TO
PUT ON. TWO MORE FROM MY FLAT
FRA REGAUGED TEN TWENTY. WELL
EFFICENT IRRIGATION SYSTEM ARE
USING MACROS BANKERS TRIP
AWESOME SUBDISTRICT
VERIFICATION. SO THAT IS UP
HERE WE HAD OUR IMPLEMENTATION
THAT TAKES PLACE BUT ONCE THOSE
SYSTEMS I'M PLACE IT'S SUCH A
<c.green>IG TRANSFORMATION THAT.</c>
USUALLY THE SYSTEM TIME PLACE
FOR YOU KNOW TEN YEARS OR
LONGER AND SO THERE IS
CONSIDERABLE WATER SAVINGS OVER
THAT TIME SENATOR. I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THAT IF IT DOES
TAKE SIXTY MONTHS THE SENATE'S
PROPOSING FOUR TIMES AS MUCH
INVESTMENT AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT THAT
THERE'S PLENTY OF. THERE'S
PLENTY OF A LEAK HERE AT-
INEFFICIENT FARMS THAT COULD
USE THIS MONEY TO YOU KNOW SAVE
SOME WATER STRETCH OUT THE
WATER THAT THEY HAVE SAVE SOME
OF THEIR CROPS IF WE HAVE AN
ACUTE. DROUGHT SITUATION WE'RE
NOT TECHNICALLY IN A TRUCK NOW
BUT WHO KNOWS WHAT NEXT YEAR
WILL BRING AND IT JUST SEEMS AS
THOUGH WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE
ALL THESE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
WANT TO PUT. MORE MONEY INTO
THIS CATEGORY IN AGRICULTURE AI
DON'T REPRESENT ANY CHARACTER
CULTURE I'M JUST SAYING BUT IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE A WISE
INVESTMENT. GIVEN WHERE WE ARE
TODAY AND I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS RHETORICAL IS WHY NOT MORE
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
DO. TO DEAL WITH THE SECURITY.
CONCERN. THIRD DRIVER FROM
PARKING BY ANTHOLOGIST- MAYBE
JUMP IN HERE AND JUST TO
CLARIFY SO UNDER MINISTRATION
PROPOSAL THERE IS ACTUALLY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SWEET THE DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT
YOU'RE SEEING THE SIXTY MILLION
THAT WAS IT THE ADDITIONAL MAY
REVISION INVESTMENT BUT THERE
WAS FORTY MILLION THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS- AND THEN AS A
FOOTNOTE IN US FOOTNOTE E.
PRINT TO SEE SMALL E. ON OUR ON
PAGE NINETY NINE THE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. THIS IS. EARNING
YOUR PAY TODAY. GOOD YEAH AND
THEN JUST ANOTHER QUICK NOTE TO
ADD SO AS PART OF THE DROUGHT
PACKAGE ONE THING YOU ALSO-
WE'LL SEE IN THE FINANCIAL AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. IS
SPECIFIC AGRICULTURAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS WELL THERE'S
ABOUT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THERE. TO HAVE- CDFA- HEROES
SUPPORT KIND OF IMMEDIATE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
POOR- WATER EFFICIENCY
CONSERVATION PLANS. TO ADDRESS
THE CURRENT DROUGHT NEEDS AND-
YOU SEE IF THEY COULD SPEAK A
LITTLE MORE TO THAT BUT YOU
KNOW SLEEP IS ONE COMPONENT OF
THE BROADER SUITE OF
INVESTMENTS THAT WE HAVE ACROSS
THE AGRICULTURE- PACKAGE AND IN
THE DROUGHT PACKAGE. THAT WILL
HELP US SUPPORT SO- DOCTOR IF
YOU WANT TO ADD A LOT TO LOOK
AT MORE OF THE DENSE DECIDE
YEAH I AM A PART OF THAT
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT PART OF OUR
DISCUSSION THIS IS. THE ACTION
THAT WE'RE TAKING IS AS WE WORK
OUT THE SENATE'S AGRICULTURAL-
ANY ADMINISTRATION SUSTAINABLE
WE'RE. TAKING THE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX. IN DOLLARS FOR
TWO THE HIGH NUMBER. WHICH WE
HOPE WE GET. COLLECTED FIVE
MILLION FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BUT GO AHEAD DR. ADD
THANK YOU SUGGEST AND THAT YES
THANK. OF COURSE YEP I'M I'M
NEEDED YET THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SENATOR SO- WE HAVE-
WE WOULD BE STARTING A NEW
PROGRAM I KNEEL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. FEATURING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
IRRIGATION SYSTEMS WE FIND THAT
THIS IS A MUCH NEEDED- A
RESOURCE BECAUSE ONCE FOLKS GET
THESE IRRIGATION SYSTEMS ARE
THERE ARE CERTAIN CHECKS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN TO MAKE THEM-
OPERATE IN AN EFFICIENT MANNER
FOR EXAMPLE. ARE THERE IS OUR-
CONCEPT CAR DISTRIBUTION
UNIFORMITY IN MAKING SURE THAT
THE WATER IS JUST RUDE EQUALLY
THROUGHOUT THE FIELD. AND YOU
CAN IMAGINE THAT IF THAT
DISTRIBUTION WAS AN EVEN. YOU'D
BE WASTING WATER IN ONE PLACE
THE FIELD WAS SINCE I
ENVISIONED THE IRRIGATION THE
WHOLE FIELD SO- THESE ARE TESTS
THAT THE TEST FOR DISTRIBUTION
UNIFORMITY. THAT IS NEEDED FOR.
BOMBS AND THEIR- TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE AT THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND AT
THE UNIVERSITY THAT I ABLE TO
DO THESE. ARMY ALSO HAVE WHAT
WE CALL MORE BY LOCATION LABS
OPERATING THROUGH SOME OF THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS. SOME OF THESE FANS
WILL CERTAINLY GO TO KEEP UP
THOSE MORE BY LABS THEN THEY
MOVE AROUND WITHIN THE STATE-
ARE THAT DISTRICT TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS SO. IT'S A MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES WITH THE DROUGHT-
THAT MORE BY LOCATION RABBITS
HAVEN'T BEEN FUNDED ON A- NOT
TIME BASE- AND THERE ARE
RESOURCE CONSENTS THAT I'M
KEEPING THEM GOING. MOST OF
THESE SERVICES ARE PRETTY
CHEAP- BUT- YOU KNOW THERE ARE
MANY CROWD WAS SO NECESSARY
KIND OF FULL OF THEM- BECAUSE
OF ALL THE OTHER COSTS THAT
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH. RIGHT
NOW I MEAN I'M IN AND THAT SORT
OF UNDERSCORES THE POINT I MEAN
IT'S GREAT TO SEND OUT THE
PROFESSOR TO HELP THE FARMER
WITH THE EFFICIENCY PROGRAM
BUT- THE STATE SENATE HAS FOUR
TIMES AS MUCH MORE MONEY INTO
THE ACTUAL. APPARATUS THAT THEY
HAVE TO BUY ME ONE SHE IS ONE
THING IS TEACHING THE FARMER
HOW TO RUN THE SYSTEM BUT IT'S
ANOTHER HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THAT WITH THESE WATER
EFFICIENCY USES SO. LIKE TO
HAVE FINANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT- WITH THESE
WHAT YOU KNOW YES WE NEED TO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON TOP OF
THE DEBTS. BUDGET DOESN'T FIVE
MILLION BUCKS COMPARED TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THE PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE TO RUN- THANK YOU
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION. JUMPING
AROUND WHICH WE DO BECAUSE WE
CAN ISSUE NUMBER NINETY THREE
IF WE HAVE DIRECTOR BOTTOMS.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE THE SENATE HAS IN
THEIR PROPOSAL WITH DID- FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO PROTECT FISH
AND WILDLIFE. FROM CHANGING
CONDITIONS. WHAT MIGHT WE- WITH
THAT TYPE OF INVESTMENT WITH
FISH AND WILDLIFE PROTECTION.
COUPLED WITH THE WATERSHED AND
THE OTHER- WETLAND INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'RE MAKING. OUR CLIMATE.
SENATOR JUST LET ME CONFIRM. AS
SOMEONE CHECK ON HIM ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. YOU'RE
ASKING ABOUT ISSUE NINETY THREE
SENATE CLIMATE PACKAGE ON PAGE
ONE TWELVE AND- AGENDA CORRECT
CORRECT THE SENATE WOULD
PROPOSE TO GIVE THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS IT'S THE BEST
VERSION IS NOT GIVING IN ORDER
TO HAVE THE W. C. B. PROTECT
FISH AND WILDLIFE IN RESPONSE
TO DROUGHT FIRE AND START
CHANGING CLIMATE AND WHAT TYPE
OF. WHAT MIGHT WE EXPECT WITH
THAT TYPE OF INVESTMENT IN THE
CLIMATE- RESILIENCY ARENA.
BRUNSKILL POSITIVE CHANGE FOR
THE BENEFIT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IN CALIFORNIA. TO GIVE
YOU SOME EXAMPLES. OF PROJECTS
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
PRESENTLY OPERATES. AND THE
BENEFIT OF INVESTING IN THE
BOARD IS IT HAS EXISTING
PERSONNEL AND PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE CAPABLE OF DISPERSING FUNDS.
RELATIVELY QUICKLY INTO THE
FIELD. SOME ARENAS INCLUDING
STREAMFLOW ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM
WHICH WAS CREATED FIRST UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE. IT INVESTS AND
WATER EFFICIENCIES RESERVOIR RE
OPERATIONS PURCHASE OR LONG
TERM LEASE CONJUNCTIVE USE
PROGRAMS ALL OF WHICH REQUIRE A
DEMONSTRABLE INCREASE IN STREAM
FLOW THE BENEFIT OF FISH MY
LIFE AS A CONDITION FOR SITTING
TO THE GRANT. AND THERE AND
CHARLIE VOLUNTARILY KIND OF
CREATED COLLABORATIVE PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE RURAL LANDSCAPE
URBAN LANDSCAPES WELL. TO GIVE
YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE AND ONE OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE GOVERNORS
MAY REVISION. IT IS A PROPOSED
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD FOR WILDLIFE
CROSSING. AND FISH PASSAGE
PROJECTS WE KNOW IN TIMES OF
WATER SCARCITY. WHAT ANIMALS
NEED IS THE FREEDOM TO ROAM WE
KNOW THAT INFRASTRUCTURE CAN
PROHIBIT THAT ROLE PLAYING BANK
CULVERTS IN COASTAL STREAMS
THAT PROHIBITS SALMON MIGRATION
UPSTREAM OR THANK. HIGHWAYS
THAT PROHIBIT ABOUT LIONS YOU
KNOW ACCESSING HABITAT
CORRIDORS. SO I THINK THAT'S A
MARQUEE ASPECT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT'S AN
EXISTING PROGRAM AND A LOT LESS
CONSERVATION BOARD. AND MORE
BROADLY LIKE THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL WHICH IS
ALWAYS UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL RECEIVED WEAPONS
RESTRICTED FUNDING. THE W. C.
B. ITSELF RUNS WETLAND
RESTORATION FUNDING PROGRAMS UP
AND DOWN THE COAST. OKAY I'VE
DUG DIRECTOR DONNELLY WITH THE
W. C. B. I THINK YOU'RE ON THE
LINE SOMEWHERE COULD YOU. WE
END ON THIS- IN IT WE HAVE
INFORMATION THAT SHOWS THAT WE
NEED TO DOA TWELVE TO FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
OUR STATE WILDLIFE WHAT OUR-
FISH AND WILDLIFE- AREAS IN
THIS IS A HALF A BILLION SO
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW IT'S A- A
TWENTY FIFTH OF WHAT THE
INVESTMENT NEEDS TO CALL BUT-
LET'S FOCUS ON THE FISH AND-
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD. DIRECTOR DONNELLY IF
YOU'RE THERE I AM HERE. TO CARE.
SO WHAT WHAT RESULTS WE GET IF
WE IF THIS IS IF THE- ASSEMBLY
AND THE S. AND THE GOVERNOR
AGREE FOR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR. INVESTMENT WHAT MIGHT
WE- ANTICIPATE THAT INITIALLY
WHAT TYPE OF IMPROVEMENTS WE E.
WE MAKE TO THE- ON THE GROUND.
LAST YEAR JUST IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE.
THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. PROTECTING
NEARLY FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES
STATEWIDE- SO WE'VE GOT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK
THROUGH- RESTORATION
ENHANCEMENT INDOOR CONSERVATION
EASEMENT ANOTHER AREA THAT
WE'RE WORKING AND WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO BE WORKING AND IS
WORKING ON NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS WE HAVE- WE WORK IT WE'VE
WORKED WITH SEVERAL- FARMERS
RANCHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
NOT ONLY TO ENHANCE AND IMPROVE
WATER RESOURCES AND WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE PROPERTY
TO SECURE ENHANCED WATER.
FLOWING ACROSS THE LAND.
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS TO
PROTECT NOT ONLY IN THE
WILDLIFE HABITAT THAT THOSE
FARMS AND RANCHES PROJECT. BUT
ALSO AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
ECONOMIC STABILITY OF THOSE
FARMS AND RANCHES CAN CONTINUE
INTO THE FUTURE- THE OTHER
THING ADD DIRECTOR BONHAM ALSO
MENTIONED OUR WORK IN THAT
WILDLIFE. CORRIDOR AND FISH
PASSAGE ARENA YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE WE'VE KERR ADDED JUST AT
OUR LAST BOARD MEETING LAST
WEEK WE FIND IT I BELIEVE THREE
PLANNINGPROJECTS. TO HELP
BRING CORRIDOR PROJECTS.
26521100% DESIGNED- STATUS AND
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK AND
POTENTIALLY INVEST THE FINAL
DOLLARS INTO MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE CROSSINGS AND ANSWERS
PASSAGE PROJECTS ARE
SUCCESSFUL- IN ADDITION WE HAVE
A WORKING WITH FARMS AND
RANCHES AGAIN. WE HAVE A
MONARCH BUTTERFLY AND
POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM THAT
IS SIGNIFICANT AND THAT IS A
CHANGING CLIMATE. YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF
A WARMING CLIMATE AND WHERE
THOSE ARE AND THEN INVEST IN
THOSE AREAS WHERE WE ANTICIPATE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
SINCE. UNIVERSITY SYSTEM AND
IDENTIFYING AREAS IN CALIFORNIA
OR WE SHOULD INVEST OUR DOLLARS
TO HELP THOSE POLLINATOR
HABITAT. FOR MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES NECK. OKLAHOMA
SENATOR THE ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION I'D BE HAPPY TO GO
MORE IN DEPTH IF YOU LOOK- I'M
SURE IF WE COME UP WITH FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION WE WILL MOVE
THE COIN. IN DEPTH QUITE A BIT
AND I WOULD BE REMISS WITHOUT
RECOGNIZING MY COLLEAGUES THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. FOR TWO OR THREE
YEARS I THINK WHEN WE REPORTED
OUT THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
HAS SOUGHT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN WORKING LANDS. ONLY
TO HAVE IT NOT IN THE FINAL
PACKAGE BUT IT HASN'T BEEN FROM
A LACK. OF ENTHUSIASM SINISTER
AND YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP ON
THIS AREA. WHEN I JUST LET MY
ENTHUSIASM IN AND APPRECIATE
THAT THE CHAIR- AND THE
COMMITTEE RAISING THE BAR ON
THIS. THIS FISH AND WILDLIFE
PROTECTION PEACE AND ESPECIALLY
UTILIZING THE W. C. B. WHICH I
THINK IS PROVING ITSELF AS IT.
EFFECTIVE ARM OF. OF US YOU
KNOW T. R. A. AND SEE IF W. IN
IN GETTING THIS WORK DONE IT
DIDN'T SOUND LIKE THERE'S THAT
MUCH OF A DISTANCE. THE SUM OF
ITS IN THE CATEGORIZATION SO
THE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. MAYBE IT MAYBE IS NOT
IN. IN ON EXACTLY CATEGORIZE
THE SAME WAY BUT- BUT I SENT.
I'M GETTING AN INTENT FROM FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT-
THERE'S A WILLINGNESS TO MOVE
THIS FUNDING. IF WE IF WE
APPROPRIATE THESE KIND OF
DOLLARS. THROUGH THE W. C. B.
AND MAKE THIS KIND OF
AUGMENTATION DO I HAVE THAT
THEY'RE RIGHT. SENATOR LIKE YOU
I'M- Q. CHAMPION FOR WILDLIFE
CROSSING AND FISH PASSAGE
PROJECTS I DO THINK THOSE
PROJECTS ARE BOTH CLIMATE
RESILIENCY AND DROUGHT WATER
RESILIENCY PROJECTS.
UNATTRACTIVE ASPECT OF
INVESTING IN THE W. C. T. B. AS
IT'S A KNOWN ENTITY. ACROSS THE
STATE WITH A LONG TRACK RECORD.
FOR WHICH- BOTH THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY HAVE STAFF IS IT BUYS
REMEMBERS. AND THE GRANT MAKING
AND- PROJECT INVESTMENT IS DONE
IN A PUBLIC PUBLIC FORUM. SO I
THINK IT'S GREAT THAT THE
SENATE PROPOSAL IDENTIFIES THE
W. C. B. AS AN ACTION AGENT AND
I THINK IT'S EQUALLY GRANT. THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE DOES AS
WELL. AND I THINK THAT BODES
WELL FOR THE FUTURE. THANKS FOR
THAT DIRECTOR BOTTOM END MR
DONNELLY. MISTER CHAIR ARE YOU
ARE YOU MOVING ON PAST NINETY
THREE WE WRAP IT UP HERE I WAS
GONNA HAVE I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION I WANT TO SEE IF
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SHOE SHOP
WITH THE STATE COASTAL
COMMISSION FOR POINT OF
CLARIFICATION- WE HAVE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. WHICH IS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS NOT PART OF
THE COASTAL COMMISSION- AT
LEAST FOR JURISDICTION AND WE
HAVE. A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN THE CAR- COASTAL PROTECTION
ACT WHICH IS NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE UNDER THE SENATE'S
CLIMATE PACKAGE. HIS LITTLE
CARVE OUT FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY WETLANDS I GUESS TWO
HUNDRED MILLION- IF. DIRECTOR
SHUSHA COULD TALK ABOUT THE-
THEN THE KNEES ON THE ON THE
COAST VERSUS THE NEED IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY OR IF I'M
CORRECT ABOUT THAT NOT BEING
INCLUDED IN THAT FUNDING
PACKAGE. OR ANYBODY FROM THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. WHAT I'M
SAYING COSA CONSERVANCY I'M
LOOKING AT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION SKEWS ME YEAH THIS
IS RACHEL IT WAS WITH THE LA A
WHILE THE COASTAL AGENCIES ARE
FIGURING OUT HOW TO RESPOND
JUST JUST A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY COVERS THE WHOLE
COAST INCLUDING THE SF BAY. BUT
THEN FROM A REGULATORY
PERSPECTIVE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IS JUST ALONG THE
COAST NOT THE BAY AND B. C. D.
C. FORM THAT COVERS THE
REGULATORY FUNCTION WITHIN THE
BAY SO THE CONSERVANCY IS ALL
CLOSED ALL DAY- BUT THEN THE
REGULATORY AGENCIES ARE A
LITTLE BIT SPLIT. VERY GOOD-
OKAY I THIS IS A FIRST FOR THE-
SUB TO. IT HAS MORE QUESTIONS
WILL GO BACK TO SENATOR SIR
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE A PAUSE.
THE CENTERS ARE DIRECT ADVICE.
ON THINGS EVEN THOUGH THEN
SORRY FOR RUINING YOUR GONNA IS
YOU'RE GONNA END EARLY I JUST I
DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND I KNOW THAT- THE C. C.
ON THE BUILD PROGRAMME
ESPECIALLY HAS BEEN.
CHAMPIONING DECARBONISATION IN
THE BUILDING SECTOR WANT TO SEE
IF THEY WERE AVAILABLE SINCE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING THAT ISSUE NINETY THREE
HERE- ON ON WHAT THE HUNDRED
MILLION OR MORE COULD DO. ON
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION IN
THAT SPACE. I DON'T KNOW C. C.
IS WITH US HERE. GOOD MORNING%
THIS IS NATALIE LEE I'M DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR RENEWABLE ENERGY
AND AT THE CDC AND THE PROGRAM
IS IMPLEMENTED IN MY DIVISION-
WE NEED TO SEE THE OPPORTUNITY
AND THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
WE DO SEE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO- BRING A COMPLEMENTARY GRANT
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO SUPPORT THE INSTALLATION OF
OLD SURFACES AND GREENING
SOLUTIONS- THE PROPOSED PROGRAM
HAS THE BENEFIT OF BEING
AVAILABLE AGAIN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WHERE THE BUILD PROGRAMME
DOES HAVE. SOME GEOGRAPHIC
RESTRICTIONS BASED ON THE
FUNDING. LIMITED TO HIGHER HERE
TORIES I THINK ONE OF THE BIG
ISSUES RIGHT. YES TODAY GAS
FUNDING UTILITIES REP
OKAY GREAT WHERE WE DID THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM- WE DO SEE A
PRIORITIZING AREAS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS. AND USING THE
CALIFORNIA HEAT ASSESSMENT TOOL
TO SUPPORT THEIR PARTICIPATION
AND WE DO WANT TO. OF COURSE OF
FOLLOW AND PRIORITIZATION FOR
DISADVANTAGED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. THANKS FOR
THAT THAT BE REMISS IF NOT
MENTIONING ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE CHANGE ASSESSMENT WHICH
WE ALL VOTED ON AND LET HIS
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR AND PLUG
IN THAT FOR THE FUTURE AS WELL
AND WITH THAT I WILL DEFER BACK
TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU. DULY
NOTED TO TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE FIFTH CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT THAT'S THERE- I
GUESS THE QUESTION- JUST
GENERALLY FOR THE ALLEY O. N. A
FINANCING ON. ON BOTH THE
GOVERNORS AND- THE SENATE
PROPOSAL IS THERE ENOUGH
PLANNING DOLLARS FOR THESE
REGIONAL AT ADAPTATION-
COLLABORATIVES WE SEE THAT THE
COOPERATIVES HAVE COME IN. AND
THURS THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS THAT
REALLY ENOUGH ON THE PLANNING.
A PORTION I GUESS CLA WHAT'S
YOUR PROPOSAL. BECAUSE I GET I
RECEIVED DID EVERYBODY RECEIVED
A LETTER ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE MILLION FOR PLANNING.
THIRD PARTY FINANCE I WILL HAVE
A COLLEAGUE AT NOON TARA FROM
FROM OPR BUT I THINK THAT THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS INTENDED
TO BE OVER TWO YEARS I BELIEVE.
AND I'VE BEEN ON TARET SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT MORE- TO ADD TO THE
PROGRAM. YES HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SNATOR AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE SO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL- DOES
DOES INCLUDE A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO
SUPPORT ADAPTATION AND
pWOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO LOCAL
REGIONAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. RECOGNIZING MANY
GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
ARE ALREADY TAKING PLANNING
ACTION AND STARTED TO IMPLEMENT
PROJECTS BUT SOME COMMUNITIES
JUST DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO DO THAT TYPE OF TRAINING
THAT IS NEEDED. THIS FINDING
THAT WE PROPOSED WHICH WOULD BE
A SURGEON MENTIONED- ALLOCATED
OVER TWO YEARS SO WE CAN ABLE
TO DO AROUND TWO ROUNDS OF
FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT THOSE
LOCAL REGIONAL TRAVEL AND
GOVERNMENT ADAPTATION PLANNING
NEEDS REALLY INTENDED TO BE
THAT FOUNDATIONS SO THAT WE'RE
INSURING THAT ALL COMMUNITIES
AND REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE
ARE ABLE TO DEVELOP- HEADLINERS
GOOD ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
PROJECTS THAT CAN THEN BE
FUNDED THROUGH. SOME OF THE
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INVESTMENT TYPES- ART
INVESTMENT ARMS PROJECTS POSTAL
CENTER. STRUCK I CAN'T. TAKE IT
IN SMALL QUESTIONS. A WORK I
WAS TO GET TO THE THEATER
OPENED I GUESS THE- PART OF IS
OUR OTHER YES YOU'D LIKE TO
HAVE THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
PLANNING. AN THE COLLAB SIX X.
SPREAD OUT AND STABBED ONE BIG
HAPPY WORLD BUT ARE THERE
ENOUGH PROJECTS IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE- AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
DOING THE PLANNING FOR THE- TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
THAT THE- THAT THE- SENATE HAS
PROPOSED YOU KNOW THERE'S TWO
THINGS GOING ON ONE. IS THIS
MONEY OUT THE DOOR WE'RE FOR
FIGHTING THE CLIMATE IT'S AN
URGENCY THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING. AND IT'S GREATLY AND
WE KNOW WE HAVE TO PLAN BUT IS
THERE ENOUGH. I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THE ACTUAL
PROJECTS EXCEED. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BUT
YOU TELL ME. WELL I'M I'M MAY
DIFFER TO SERGIO OR ADDING ON
THAT ON THIS SPECIFIC PROJECTS
THAT WERE HANGING. IN THAT
PROPOSAL TO GO UNDER RESOURCES
BUT I WILL SAY JUST ON THE
PLANNING SIDE WE CONTINUE TO
SEE OVER SUBSCRIPTION RATES
THAT FAR EXCEED THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR OBTAINING FUNDING
THAT WE DO HAVE ACROSS THE
STATE. JUST FOR EXAMPLE AS A
DATA POINT THIS IS ANECDOTAL
BUT- LAST YEAR WE RAN A
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY RECOVERY
GRANT PROGRAM AND SOME RETURNED
FUNDING FROM OUR PROPERTY FOR.
FUNDING WE HAD SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. WITH
OVER ONE MONTH KIND OF LEAD
TIME FOR APPLICATIONS BECAUSE
TIS IS ONE OF THE FUNDING. WE
RECEIVED APPLICATIONS. TOTALING
OVER THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS SO THAT WAS WHEN YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW TRYING TO DO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SUPPORT TO
GET WORD OUT. AND WE JUST SEE
SIGNIFICANT NEED FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR THIS FINDING
SUPPORT. I KNOW THAT DOESN'T
DIRECTLY ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
AROUND THE PROJECTS AND THAT
KIND OF THE POINT POINT SIGN.
BUT JUST A NOTE ON THAT TYPE OF
NEEDS THAT WE SEE FROM COMING
FROM COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE SIDE MISSILES WITH. THE
ELIO. RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MR
CHAIR- YET THERE. I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF NEED FOR PLAY.
AND THERE'S ARE OF IDENTIFY
PROJECTS BUT I THINK THING THAT
IMPORTANT ABOUT IS- WHO ARE THE
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE THE PLANS
AND PROJECTS READY TO GO AND
WHO ARE THOSE THAT MIGHT NOT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
CAPACITY AND MAYBE THAT'S AN
AREA. THAT THE STATE REALLY
WANTS TO FOCUS ON TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE LEFT BEHIND- AS INTERFERING
FOR CLAIM IT. I THINK THAT
REALLYGETS TO A POINT THAT-
THAT ALSO SPEAKS TO SENATOR
DOLLIES QUESTIONS EARLIER ON
THE WILDFIRE IS WHAT ARE WE
PAYING FOR THIS MONEY HOW WILL
THAT HOW EXACTLY WILL THE FUNDS
BE SPENT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE WATER REACHES. OR
THAT- WELFARE FOR THIS PLANNING
GRANT THERE REALLY ISN'T A
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK BEING
PROPOSED FOR A LOT OF THIS
FUNDING IN SOME WAYS YOU'RE
CONSIDERING. YOU KNOW WHEN TO
QUIT WENT TO SEVERAL DIFFERENT
BONDS AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT
WITH THE BOND HOW MUCH LANGUAGE
IS USUALLY BEHIND IT
PRIORITIZING IDENTIFYING WHO'S
ELIGIBLE DOES NOT. END
REQUIRING A LOT OF REPORTING ON
HOW THE FUNDS GET SPENT BECAUSE
OF HOW THIS IS BEING PROPOSED
YOU'RE NOT YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF. STATUTORY BACK
BACKBONE FOR FROM THE GUIDING
THE FINES AND GETTING
INFORMATION ON OUTCOMES AND
SPECIFYING THE OUTCOMES THAT
YOU WANT. SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THESE REALLY LARGE INVESTMENTS
THAT SPAN ANOTHER. REALLY
KIND OF GUIDANCE DO YOU WANT TO
HAVE TO AND TO PROVIDE OVER HOW
FUNDS ARE PRIORITIZED AND ALSO
WHAT KIND OF INFORMATION DO YOU
WANT TO GET BACK SO. YOU KNOW
WHETHER YOU HAVE TIME TO DO
THAT IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS THAT IT THAT IS ALSO
SOMETHING YOU CAN FOLLOW UP ON
THEM. THE SUMMER BOTH WITH
BUDGET BILL JUNIORS AND WOMEN
WITH TRAILER BILL THAT RELLY
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS TO
THINK ABOUT. SEND A CERTAIN
FINAL POINT IT JUST BILL THEM
AS EHLERS POINT AND HIS KEYS
POINT I THINK WE'VE GOT A REAL
OPPORTUNITY WITH THIS REGIONAL
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING TO.
TO AUGMENT SOME OF THE- THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER WHEN IT COMES TO
HARDENING. IN THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME TRIP TODAY SHOULD WE GET
THAT FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
AND- IN. TOO MUCH PUBLIC SO. IN
IS HEARTENING SPACE. BUT IF
WE'RE BUILDING CAPACITY AT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL. TO
MATCH THESE CLIMATE
VULNERABILITIES. AND TO
ACTUALLY WORK NOT JUST ON THE
PLANNING SIDE BUT ON THE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SIDE DOING
PRE HAZARD MITIGATION. AND
DEFINE THE AREAS THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE. TO WILDFIRE OR TO
FLOOD WHAT TO C. LEVEL RISE AND
ACTUALLY MICROTARGETING THAT.
INVESTMENT WE'RE GONNA MAKE
DOLLARS. PERFORM MUCH BETTER
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC GOING FOR IN
THE FUTURE SO I REALLY HOPE WE
CAN LAND SOMETHING HERE. USE
THE EXISTING ARCHITECTURE THAT
OPR STARTED TO BUILD AND THEN
MARRY THAT TO SOME OF THE
EXISTING EFFORTS GOING ON. AT
CAL FIRE AND C. N. R. A. WITH
THAT I WILL SHUT OFF MY MIKE.
CLOSE MY MOUTH AND WITH THAT.
THE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ON- THAT. ENERGY
ENVIRONMENT NATURAL RESOURCES.
IS IN RECESS UNTIL ONE THIRTY.
P. FIVE. BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW- SUBCOMMITTEE AT TWO- WE
ARE IN DISCUSSION ON ITEMS.
NINETY NINETY ONE NINETY TWO
NINETY THREE WHICH IS WHICH
INCLUDES THE GOVERNOR'S
RESILIENCY PACKAGE HE HAS-
LISTEN THE- HYDROGEN BIOFUELS
PILOT PROGRAM. I BELIEVE- THE
SENATOR. MACQUARIE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
IN AMATEUR R. I. I KNOW WE'LL
BE TALKING ABOUT S. P. FORTY
FIVE ALL THAT DID THE FUNNY
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ESPECIALLY IN THIS CHALLENGING
YEAR YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO BE
THE FIRST TALK ABOUT ALL ISSUES
OF HYDROGEN- LOOK AND I KNOW
THAT IT IS WITHOUT PREJUDICE
THAT. THE SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDED DEFERRING ACTION ON
SEVERAL THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS. INCLUDING THOSE
AFFECTING HYDROGEN REFUELLING
INVESTMENTS AND OTHER CARBON
REDUCTION MEASURES MEASURES AS
WELL AS SEVERAL CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSALS. AND I
AGREED WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN
THE CHAIR AND THE SENATE'S
APPROACH. CANDIDLY WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION ON THESE PROPOSALS
WE DON'T HAVE. ALL THE
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
BUDGET OR THE TREE THE
PROPOSALS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AT THIS TIME- AND
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ASSEMBLY IS ASKING FOR VERY.
SIMILAR DATA POINTS SO I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH THE CHAIRS
APPROACH AND I THINK IT'S A
SMART ONE. AND I EXPECT SOME OR
POTENTIALLY ALL OF THE
MINISTRATION PROPOSALS WILL
ULTIMATELY BE APPROVED IN THE
BUDGET. THAT SAID I WANNA CALL
PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO THE
HYDROGEN REFUELING ITEMS. AND
THAT THE LETTER RECEIVED FROM-
THE STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES AND I KNOW THAT SENATOR
ARCHULETA IS VERY INTERESTED IN
THIS ISSUE AS WELL. I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
COMPLEMENTED BY NEW
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN AMERICAN JOBS
PLAN. AND LOOK IT'S GOING TO
CREATE THOUSANDS OF HIGH WAGE
FAMILY SUSTAINING JOBS WITH.
JOBS THAT ARE CONNECTED TO
BENEFITS- AND ESPECIALLY WILL
BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THEY'RE ALSO CLEAN ENERGY AND
LOW CARBON POLLUTING
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE TARGETS. EVERYONE ASKS
DEFINE WHAT A GREEN JOB IS.
THIS BUDGET WOULD INVEST IN
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF GREEN JOBS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THIS IS WHAT
JOB CREATION IN THE NEW GREEN
ECONOMY IS ALL ABOUT AND AGAIN
AT MISTER CHAIR FULLY SUPPORT.
YOUR RECOMMENDATION HI AND
WOULD HOPE THAT ANY FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT COULD INCLUDE
INVESTMENT IN THAT HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AS I KNOW IT'S
SO CRITICAL ESPECIALLY TO THOSE
URBAN- UNDERSERVED. COMMUNITIES
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH ATTENTION.
CUTE EITHER OF MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT.
ON ANY OF THE- ITEMS IN PART A
OR PART B. THAT OUR VOTE ONLY
WE CAN'T ASK QUESTIONS OF THE-
OF THE AGENCIES WE CAN MAKE
STATEMENTS SO- CENTER STERNER
RECOGNIZE. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- SO MY THE ITEMS I
WANTED TO RAISE HERE LET ME
JUST PULL. THIS OKAY SO- ON.
THE ISSUE OF A LET'S START
LET'S START PARTE- UNDER THE
CC- ON THE C. C.'S ENERGY
PROGRAM INVESTMENT AS WELL AS
THE- CALIFORNIA RESOURCE BOARD
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PROPOSALS- HOPING WE CAN. WHERE
IN SOME KIND OF COMPROMISE
THERE THAT RECOGNIZES THE QUITE
VISIONARY AND SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT THE NINE HUNDRED
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
ACCELERATING PROGRESS I KNOW
WE'RE DEFERRING THAT ITEM AND-
IT'S AN ACQUIRED JUST TALKED
ABOUT THE GREEN HYDRANT PROJECT
PRODUCTION PIECE OF IT BUT
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OTHER
PIECES ON PRE COMMERCIAL LONG
DURATION STORAGE- ON CRITICAL
RESOURCE IN TRANSMISSION
PLANNING WE JUST SAW SOME
REALLY BIG NEWS TODAY. ON
OFFSHORE WIND- SO VERY EXCITED
ABOUT ALL THAT SO I'M HOPING WE
KEEP GATHERING STEAM THE
BUILDING ON PROGRESS THERE AS
WELL AS IN THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM- I THINK
WHICH IS UNDER BOTH ITEMS FIVE
AND THIRTEEN- I HOPE WE CAN
KEEP MAKING PROGRESS WE KNOW IN
OUR D. C.'S NUMBER SAY FIVE TO
SIX BILLION IS REQUIRED
ANNUALLY TO METERS HAVE GOALS.
SO WE HVE TO KEEP AIMING HIGH
THERE AS WELL- SO HOPEFULLY WE
KEEP MAKING SOME PROGRESS- ON
ITEM ELEVEN- UNDER PART B. WHEN
IT COMES TO CAL JAM- OVERSIGHT-
WE'VE BEEN STAFF HAS BEEN ON
THE NURSERY SERVICES AND WATER
COMMITTEE'S BEEN REVIEWING THE
P. C. P. THERE- AS WELL AS THE-
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL IN THE MAY REVISE FOR
OIL WELL REMEDIATION- WE'VE GOT
TO MAKE PROGRESS THIS YEAR.
WHEN IT COMES TO- BOTH ABANDON
AN ORPHAN WELLS AS WELL AS IDA
WELLS THAT REALLY ARE RIGHT BE-
IT CATEGORIZES DESERTED AND
TAKEN OUT OF PRODUCTION- I
THINK THE INDUSTRY UNDERSTANDS
THIS POINT AND THERE'S BEEN
SOME FRUSTRATION EVEN THERE
FROM THE INDUSTRY SIDE AND FROM
THE FOLKS IN LABOR WHO WORK IN
OIL AND GAS THAT WE'RE NOT
GETTING ENOUGH. THROUGHPUT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PLUGGING
PROCESS I THINK THERE'S SOME
REALLY EXCITING OPPORTUNITIES
TO DO THIS WORK I DON'T THINK
IT SHOULD ALL BE ON THE PUBLIC
DIME THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL I THINK IS
EXCITING BUT WE'D REALLY LIKE
TO SEE GOING FORWARD HOW WE CAN
FIND A PARTNERSHIP HERE. SOME
INDUSTRY MATCH OR SOME
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO- TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUR PARTNERS IN
LABOR TO DO MORE URBAN
ORIENTED. WELL CLOSURE WORK AND
IF WE COULD TAKE SAY YOU KNOW
RIGHT NOW THE TARGET IS I THINK
THIRTY EIGHT WELLS TO BE CLOSER
TO THE ORPHAN WELL PROGRAM OVER
THE NEXT EIGHT TO TEN YEARS OUT
OF THE B. C. P. THAT'S NOT
GONNA INSPIRE A LOT OF TRUCKS
FROM OUR FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
THE FOLKS OUT THERE WHO ARE
HURTING. WHO ARE WANTING TO SEE
MORE SETBACKS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE WORRIED
ABOUT NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING
WE'VE GOT TO START
DEMONTRATING PROGRESS THIS
YEAR AND IN THE YEARS AHEAD I
TRULY THINK WE CAN HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP HERE WHERE IT'S NOT
ONLY GOING TO CURRENT AND
TELLING THEM WHAT TO DO
NECESSARILY OR VICE VERSA BUT
EMPOWERING LOCAL ACTION ON THIS
FRONT WE'VE SEEN ELLIE CITY
COUNCIL START TO ACT GET THEIR%
OWN INSPECTORS IN PLACE SO.
VERY A VERY PASS ABOUT ISSUE
AND I HOPE THROUGH THIS BUDGET
WE CAN LAND SOME BIGGER
COMPROMISED. TO START JUST. NOT
FIGHTING ON THE BUMPER STICKER
POLITICS BUT ACTUALLY CLOSING
THE MOST DANGEROUS WELLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I KNOW WE
TOUCHED IN ITEM FOURTEEN A
LITTLE EARLIER- AND CENTER
REQUIRE AND I ARE BOTH
CHAMPIONING THIS. CONTRACT
CITIES REQUESTS. FOR FOURTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION ON THE SIX
FUELS CREWS- WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP PUSHING HARD AND WANT TO
SEE- OUR LOCAL FIRE DISTRICTS.
GET THEIR FAIR SHARE AND DO
THAT DO THE WORK- I WOULD ALSO
I WOULD ALSO NOTE. THERE'S AN
ITEM. THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY
MENTION HERE BT- WHEN IT MAY
BE UNDER THIS COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION WE'VE WE FUNDED
WE'VE HAD FUNDING IN THE PAST
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE- FOR
OUR- THROUGH WORK FOR MUSEUMS
ED FOR A CULTURAL HISTORICAL
RESOURCES- I THINK THERE'S SOME
SOME INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WORK
TO BE DONE THERE. AND YOU KNOW
I WOULD JUST RAISE THAT THIS IS
BEING DISCUSSED IN STEP FOUR
AND IT WAS ALSO TO DISCUSS IN
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE BUT THESE
CULTURAL HISTORIC AND
INSTITUTIONS WERE SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC- AND
THERE'S BEEN TWO OR FIFTY
MILLION PROPOSE FOR C. C. H. E.
AT THE RESOURCES AGENCY SO I
JUST WANT TO RAISE THAT HERE
HISTORIC UNDER INVESTMENT BUT
THE NEED IS GREAT AND WE HAVE
TO HELP THESE ARTS CULTURE AND
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES SURVIVE
AFTER HAVING A VERY VERY TOUGH
YEAR. LASTLY WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE I WOULD JUST RAISE-
GOING FORWARD I STILL BELIEVE
IN THE CLIMATE CATALYST- I
THINK THAT WHETHER IT'S
CIRCULAR ECONOMY SMART
AGRICULTURE- LEVERAGED FUNDING
IS GOING TO BE VALUABLE GOING
FORWARD SO I'M HOPING WE CAN
GIVE DUE CONSIDERATION- TO
SEEING THE CLIMATE CATALYST-
REALLY BECOME AN ENGINE FOR
FINANCING PROJECTS THAT ARE
JUST TOO BIG AND TOO MY
TEACHERS FOR GRANTS ALONE- AND
WITH THAT. I WILL KICK IT BACK
TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
INDULGENCE FORGET CENTER-
ACQUIRE YOU RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR I JUST ONE
LAST ITEM I'D LIKE TO GET A
MENTION AND THAT'S THE PART OF
THE PROJECT FOR OFFSHORE WIND
OFF OF THE COUNTY OF HUMBOLDT.
BUT THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING
AND VERY GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS SHOWING LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE WORKING WITH
ABOUT A MINISTRATION NUMBER ONE
AN INVESTMENT FOR THE PORT OF
HUMBLE TO BE ABLE TO START
LOOKING AT DEVELOPMENT OF ON
SHORE OR ON SHORE WORK RELATED
TO OFFSHORE WIND FOCUS SEEN ON
DOLLARS FOR BOTH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AS. WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
FOR EXPERT I BARMAN REVIEW. BUT
THERE'S ABOUT SEVEN TEN DOLLARS.
IN THIS PROPOSAL FOCUSING. ON
OUTREACH TO TRIBES LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS- OTHER
PARTNERS I THINK THERE'S ONE
THING MISSING IN WE HAD A BILLS%
CONTINUE TO HAVE A BILL ON THIS
AND IT'S VERY CRITICALIS
WORKING WITH THE NORTH COAST
FISHING COMMUNITY- WHAT WE KNOW
IS ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT. OF THE
NORTH COAST THOSE GOT COASTAL
WATERS ARE ALREADY OFF LIMITS.
DUE TO THE MARINE PROTECTION
ACT. FOR COMMERCIAL FISHING
WHICH I FULLY SUPPORT BY THE
WAY. AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT
WHAT POTENTIAL IMPACTS. A
COMMERCIAL FISHERMAN WILL-
THERE WILL BE FOR COASTAL
COMMISSION. COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN WITH OFFSHORE WIND I
FULLY SUPPORTED OUR BILL WOULD.
EXPEDITE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW ASSOCIATED WITH-
OFFSHORE WIND THERE'S A HUNDRED
MEGAWATT. PROJECT OFFER THE
HUMBLE COAST END WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE COMMERCIAL
FISHING FLEETS HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE SO THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO.
ADVANCE AS THE NEGOTIATIONS
CONTINUE ON THIS CRITICAL IN
LANDMARK. OFFSHORE WIND
PROPOSAL THAT IS BEING ADVANCED
BY THE DEAD BY DEMONSTRATION AS
WELL AS THE NEW SOME
MINISTRATION. BUT WE CAN'T
LEAVE COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN.
WITHOUT A SEAT AT THE TABLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER
CHAIR. AT THIS TIME WE WOULD
LIKE TO OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD- I'LL REMIND.
EVERYONE TO TODAY'S AT
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY ONE SEVEN- AND DUE TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS I MAY
INSTITUTES AND SOME TIME LIMITS
DEPENDING ON HOW MANY. PEOPLE
ARE ON THE LINE TODAY-
HOPEFULLY AS PEOPLE THEY CAN
CONFINE THEMSELVES TO ONE TO
ONE MINUTE I'M SO LET'S OPEN IT
UP I SEE NO. WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM. I ARE HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE I'LL TURN TO ROOM
FOR- TWENTY FORTY AND SEE IF
THERE'S PEOPLE LISTED ENTER
COMMENT I SEE NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SO. LET'S NOW MOVE
TO WITNESS IS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VA VINOD
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OVERS
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO
FIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU HAVE
NOT ALREADY DONE SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE LINE NUMBER AND YOU WILL BE
CALLED ON IN ORDER. TO MAKE
COMMANDOS ONES FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. OUR FIRST LINE IN QUEUES
LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL EXACTLY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TREADWELL AGENTS IN HER STATE.
SPEAKING TODAY ON ISSUES FIVE
AND THIRTEEN I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE MEN IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
FORWARD AS YOU MAY KNOW
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT AGENCY ARE
CURRENTLY ON A PATH TO
TRANSITION 21100% SURE MACHINE
TECHNOLOGIES BY TWENTY FORTY.
WITH MANY AGENTS- THE TEMPTING
TO MOVE MORE AGGRESSIVELY I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE OUR INDUSTRY
HAS VISION WE BELIEVE THE PLANT
AND I MEAN THAT QUITE LITERALLY
FOR TRANSITIONING TO TECHNOLOGY
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO BRING THE
TRANSITION ONLINE. I WE DO
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL BECAUSE OF WHICH HE
THE TRANSITION LEVERAGE
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT NEW
FEDERAL FUNDS AND IT RESPONDS
DIRECTLY TO OUR REQUESTS TO
CREATE THAT INSIDE THE PORT OF
THE TRANSIT INDUSTRY IN
PARTICULAR THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU NEXT.
LINE SIX SIX ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR MY CUSTOMER THE
COMMITTEE PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST- ON ISSUES
NINETY TO NINETY THREE AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO APPLAUD THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PROPOSAL
AROUND THE THROAT FIRE AND-
CLIMATE INTEGRATED PROPOSALS IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE ROLE OF THE NATIONAL
FUNDING FOR CONSERVATION
INCURRING. EXPLAINS THE INCLUDE
IN THE PROPOSAL. ALL OF THE
WERE TALKING ABOUT HI OR WATER
TAKING BIODIVERSITY AND CLIMATE
MITIGATION. THE SAME ACTIVITIES
OUT IN THE LANDSCAPE AND MANY
OF THEM GOING TO TAKE A LONGER
TIME TO ACHIEVE AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE TOOLS TO DO
LONG TERM CONSERVATION AND
PROOF MANAGEMENT COULD BE
CRITICAL TO GETTING YOUR LONG
TERM GOALS WE WERE MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR- FOCUS ON YOU
KNOW THINKING LONG TERM.
FOCUSING ON RESTORING WATERSHED
OVER THE LONG TERM AND WE
BOUGHT YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THE
SENATE THANK YOU. NEXT. NINE
FIFTEEN ONE FIVE. THE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MARKER PRIOR ON BEHALF OF THREE
CLIENTS PART ISSUE THIRTEEN IN
PART A- ON BEHALF OF CHARGE
POINTS AS DESCRIBED IN DETAIL
IN THEIR MAY TWENTY FIVE LETTER
CHARGE POINT SUPPORTS THE
PROPOSED SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. SEEKING CLARIFICATION
ON THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
SPECIFICALLY CHARGE POINT
COURAGE IS THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
ALLOCATE THE MAJORITY OF THE
SEVEN FOOT STRUCTURE FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THAT LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES ARE
RAPIDLY INCREASING AND
MANUFACTURERS ARE REGULARLY
INTRODUCING NEW MODELS. CHARGE
POINT ALSO SUGGESTED ON THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT- THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LOOK TO WAYS IN
WHICH THE CDC CAN IMPROVE
INCENTIVES TO REDUCE THE COST
OF INSTALLING THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND VIOLATION
CHARGE POINT SUPPORTS THE YOU
HAVE IMPORTANT INFRASTRUCTURE
MAN MANUFACTURING FUNDING
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED ARE THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL HELP SECURE
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP FOR
DECADES TO COME. ON PART BE-
ISSUE THIRTY FOUR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN CLEMENTE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE SENATE
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO SUSPEND FUNDING FOR
THE PUBLIC BEACH RESTORATION
GRANT PROGRAM AND RESTORE THAT
FUNDING IN THE ADOPTED TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO STATE BUDGET.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF CRITICAL
PUBLIC SAFETY SAN CLEMENTE'S
MARINE SAFETY HEADQUARTERS ARE
AT RISK AND FURTHER SOME BEACH
ACCESS POINTS HAVE HAD TO BE
CLOSED TO THE EROSION CREATED
CREATING UNSAFE- ACCESS TO
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE BEACH
FINALLY ISSUE. SIXTY NINE ON
CAL RECYCLE AND THESE- CON PACK.
OR BEHALF OF- REPUBLICS. WE
WISH TO ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE MAY TWENTY FOUR LETTER
SIGNED BY MORE THAN FORTY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE SOLID
WASTE ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL A FIFTY FIVE MILLION.
TO POWER CYCLE FORGET GIMMICK
WASTE RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. IN
ADDITION WE REQUEST THE STATE
INCREASE THIS AMOUNT TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE'S
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL TO ALLOCATE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU NECKS.
SEVENTY NINE SEVEN NINE. GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER FIFTY NEED
NEED A PICK ME UP MY FAMILY
FARMERS AND CAP STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE NEARLY ONE BILLION
IN NEW FUNDING FOR TRANSITION
THAT ANIMAL AGRICULTURE WHICH
INCLUDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PARTNERSHIP FARMERS FARM TO
SCHOOL CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS URBAN
AGRICULTURE PROGRAM BEGINNING
FARMER AND FARMWORKER TRAINING
AND A STATEWIDE PESTICIDE
NOTIFICATION NETWORK- WE HAD
CAPPED URGE THAT BUT THE FINAL
DR BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES. TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TOOL
SHARING LIBRARY FOR SMALL SCALE
FARMERS AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FOOD HUBS AND
APPEARED PETRIFIED MILK CHEAPER
MORE ROBUSTLY FUND TO MORE
ABOUT THE FUND INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT RESOURCES AND
COMMUNITY PROTECTION FINALLY
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING THE
INCLUDING BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO ENSURE THAT THE ENHANCED
PETRIFIED CARE MONITORING
NETWORK WILL BE LINKED. TO
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTION THANK YOU. YOU'RE
WELCOME OUR NEXT. NINE SEVEN
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT. WHAT
HAPPENED MR MEMBERS RECALL
MAASTRICHT WITH THE TRUST THE
PUBLIC LAND- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT APPRECIATE THE SENATE-
PROPOSAL FOR THE STATE
CONSERVANCY THE WILDFIRE
PACKAGE OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
PROTECTION WHICH WE AGREE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT AND CALLED THE
PROTECTION WERE ALSO VERY HAPPY
WITH THE SENATE RECOGNIZED THE
EXTREME DANGER- BY INCLUDING
THREE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION FOR URBAN GREENING
COOLING CENTERS AND BACK UP
POWER. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE URBAN GREENING
PROGRAM SO IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
THAT THREE NINETY FIVE IS GOING
TO BE IVIDED UP BUT I HOPE IT
INCLUDES THE TWO. THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM INTACT OTHER
PROJECTS READY TO GO OUR
PROGRAM IS NOT FUNDED LAST YEAR
AND AS WE ALL KNOW- YOU KNOW
DEADLY HEAT IS HERE AND IT'S
GOING TO GET WORSE- SO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THE
CROSSHAIRS OF THAT REALLY NEED
THE URBAN GREENING- PROGRAM AND
IT'S GONNA PENCHANT TO COOL
NEIGHBORHOODS AND- THE AMBIEN
AFTER CAPITAL- TEMPERATURES BUT
ARE GOING TO BE AROUND FOR
AWHILE. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR. LEADERSHIP- THANK YOU.
TEXT NINE EIGHT NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER
ALEXANDER ON BEHALF HOW I'M
COMMENTING ON ISSUES FIVE AND
THIRTEEN. AFTER STRONG
CORPORATE GOVERNANCE AND
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR YOUR
MISSION CRITICAL I THINK ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
ADVANCE THE TECHNOLOGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE'RE HERE
TO ASK YOU NOT TO DETERMINE THE
ACTION ON THE ITEMS BECAUSE
CRITICAL INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
LIKE EACH THAT HAD BEEN WITHOUT
FUNDING FOR OVER EIGHTEEN
MONTHS THE TIME IS REALLY
ATHLETIC. AND ANY DELAY IN
FUNDING PROGRAMS JEOPARDIZES
OUR TRANSITION TO HAVE. SENT
THE WRONG SIGNAL TO
MANUFACTURERS AND THAT NOTHING
I MEAN MORE POLLUTION AND OUR
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN THE MEANTIME. ALSO WHAT WE
REALLY NEED NOW IS FINDING
CERTAIN THINGS WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE ALSO. I'M ASKING YOU TO
REJECT THAT RECOMMENDATION ON
THE EVENING REACTIVATION AND
PACKED THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER
BELOW THAT POINT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE LONG TERM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MAX. FOR A
LINE. UNTIL THEN WE HAVE THE
FROM A POLLUTION OFFICERS
ASSIST WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE ADOPTED A
BEACON PROGRAM FUNDING TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WHICH INCLUDES A
KARMA PROGRAM MAYBE NINE TWENTY
THREE LOCAL INCENTIVES PROGRAM
APPROVING THE EXTENSION. FOR
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE. HAPPEN
FOR THE PRESENTATION TIME
DEVELOPMENT AND BUSINESS MARKET
CERTAINTY WE APPRECIATE COMPOSE
FUNDING FOR A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN
FROM THE PROGRAMMING CHANNELS
AND IN LIGHT OF THE BUDGET
SURPLUS. SHOWS RIGHTEOUSLY
TRIMMED GOVERNOR TO FURTHER
PRIORITIZING PROGRAMS FOR
FUNDING AND WE MUST EXPRESS IT
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR A DISTRICT IT'LL BE
SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION IT
DOES NOT COVER THE CURRENT
CULTURE ACCOUNT FOR NEW
COMMUNITIES. ADDED TO THE STATE
MANDATED PROGRAMS AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE SENATE FUNDING FOR
THE RESIDENTIAL WOOD SMOKE
REDUCTION PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
NEXT LINE NINE SEVEN. SCHNITZER
KAREN THIS IS JENNIFER FOR THE
MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
WARDENS SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE SO
HARDENED DEFEAT THE ROBOT IN
LANSING INVESTMENT PROPOSAL
APARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE IN
A WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
URGED THE SENATE TO SUPPORT THE
DROUGHT PACKAGES INCLUSION OF
IMPORTANT FUNDING FOR ECOSYSTEM
MONITORING OF TERRESTRIAL
SPECIES OVER TIME A AGREEMENT
FOR WILDLIFE OFFICERS AND
FORENSIC EXPERTS AND MOST
NOTABLY TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS
FOR WTTW STRUCK REPAIR AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC WORK OF ART.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN ALSO
FOR FLAG IN THE REQUEST OF MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
MAYORS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
OUR CHAMPIONS RUBY ON ALAN
BRAZILIAN ISLAND THAT'S MANY
pARTS CULTURE AND CREATIVE
FACTOR ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION WITH HIM I TOO WANT
TO LIFT UP TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ATHLETE IN THAT
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD GO TO THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL INDICTMENT AT THE
RESOURCES AGENCY AND URGE ITS
INCLUSION IN THE SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. NINETY NINE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MA ON BEHALF OF THE FOR SAFETY
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY
THANK THE SENATE FOR ITS
SUPPORT OF THE TRANSITION TO
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR UNDERSERVED
FARMERS FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM A
STATEWIDE PESTICIDE
NOTIFICATION PROGRAM AND
INVESTMENTS AND HOT POLLINATOR
HABITAT. IN THE BUDGET LANGUAGE
TO ENSURE ENHANCED PESTICIDE
AIR MONITORING WILL BE LINKED
TO OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS. AFS OPPOSES ANY
FUNDING FOR DERRY DIGEST YOURS
WHICH POLLUTE WHILE DOING
NOTHING TO REDUCE AIR AND WATER
POLLUTION AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY ARE
OFTEN LOCATED FINALLY WE HOPE
THE FINAL BUDGET. LANGUAGE
INCLUDE SECURED PESTICIDE BILL
C. TO FIND MORE INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT RESOURCES AND
COMMUNITY PROTECTION THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT. NINE
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN'T MEMBERS OF MANY
MY NAME IS RANDALL PROBABLY
GOVERNMENT SPECIALIST FOR SAN
FRAN I WAN TO THANK YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT BUS IS CAPTURED IN
ISSUE THIRTEEN IN PART A
DEDICATED FUND FOR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES IS
CRITICAL ESPECIALLY FOR THE
BUILD OUT OF INFRASTRUCTURE OR
VEHICLE CHARGING- THAT WILL
HELP THE STATE REQUIRES BOTH.
ENTRANCES LOOKING TALKING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR FULL VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE LOCAL DOLLARS
ARE USED TO PROVIDE SERVICE FOR
LOW INCOME RIDERS MORE STATE
FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION BUS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ROLLING
STOCK THE MORE WE CAN INVEST IN
OUR LOCAL SERVICE THANK YOU AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE AS WE DELIVER ON
THESE CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION
PRIORITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MAX. ONE OH FIVE ONE HUNDRED
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBER STANDARD BOTTOM IT
HAPPENS HERE CLUB CALIFORNIA
WHICH AMENDED DETAIL BETTER TO
YOUR COMMITTEE YESTERDAY ON THE
ENTIRE BUDGET SO JUST FOCUS ON
THAT- FIRST REPAIRS THE CORNER
OF THE PROPOSAL. PROPOSALS IN
THE SENATE CLIMATE RESILIENT
PACKAGE THAT WOULD IMPROVE
HABITAT CONSERVATION AND
PROTECT ECOSYSTEMS AND
COMMUNITIES FROM THE WORSENING
IMPACTS OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS
ALLOCATING SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
TO THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD IN THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY. SECOND WE SHARE
SENATOR STERN CONCERNS AROUND
THE LACK OF PROPOSED FUNDING
FOR HOME GARDENING. STATION
CONTEMPLATING WHAT STATE AT THE
SAME RATE AS IT SOUNDS WILD MAN
MANAGEMENT. FINALLY WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION THAT YOUR
COMMITTEE REJECTS THE APPROVAL
OF THE A. B. EIGHT REACTORS
NATION. FORGET ABOUT. THE STATE
SHOULD NOT WAIT TO SECURE THIS
CRITICAL TRAINING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING. ZERO
POINT EIGHTY EIGHT REACTORS
NATION BEST YEAR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THESE ITEMS AS WELL AS THE ONE
WE OUTLINED IN IRAQ THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT.
NINETY TWO NINE TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KEPT IN ROWS ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE IN ONE
OF ITS PROGRAMS RISSA CHANGE
SPEAKING ON PART BE ISSUED
SEVENTY EIGHT SPECIFICALLY WE
APPRECIATE THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION TO FUND THE
HEALTHY STORAGE REFRIGERATION
GRANT PROGRAMS. AT TWENTY
MILLION. URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. FUNDING
FOR THIS POOR CORNER STORE
OWNERS EMERGENCY FOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS INTO DESERT STATE
RIGHT BEYOND THE FORTY OF THE
FIFTY COUNTY. BENEFITED IN THE
RECENTLY COMPLETED ROUND ONE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS PROGRAM BUT ALSO BEING
CHAMPIONED BY SOME DIFFERENT
BETWEEN. NEXT. LIN. ONE OH
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND UNITS I'LL BE OUT
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES JUST WANNA SPEAK
BRIEFLY ON THE ISSUE EIGHTY
EIGHT- PERSONAL I THINK THE PRO
TEM'S OFFICE AS WELL THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP IN RESPONDING TO
CALIFORNIA'S DROUGHT- BIG PROPS
TO HEAD TO THE STAFF TO AND
REALLY PUTTING TOGETHER THE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN PAGE PACKET-
WE FULLY SUPPORT THE SENATE
PROPOSAL- AS MOST PERSONS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL
COULD ROUTE- SUCH AS MONEY
QUICKLY BANNED BANNED THE
PROPOSED TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR COOKING NINETEEN REGIONS-
JUST A FEW ADDITIONAL
CATEGORIES TO CONSIDER THIS
PROPOSAL COMES TOGETHER.
FUNDING FOR DAM SAFETY AT
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH HAZARD DAMS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
PEDIATRIC MEDIATION FUNDING FOR
REGIONAL COMMAND AND THEN THE
PROP SIXTY HABITAT RESTORATION.
FUNDING THAT IS REFERENCED IN
TO- SO AGAIN YOU FOR YOUR IN
TOP LOOKS FORWARD TO WORK BUT I
JUST AT THE CONVERSE MOVED
FORWARD NOW. NINETY FIVE. THANK
pKEEP A CREDIT BUT THEN AFTER
REPORTS OF COUNCIL I'M GOING TO
AGENDA FOR AT LEAST THAT I'M
TRY YOU TO MY COMMENT I'M
LOOKING THAT YOU SHOULD BUDGET
I WOULD ACTUALLY ALLOCATION
YEAH INCREASED FUNDING THE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECT
TWO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR BALANCE
THAT 50% OF THE CONTRACT CRAP
INVESTS. ARE LOCATED THEN BACK
LOW INCOME DISADVANTAGED
WELCOME BACK OUR PARTNERS AND
ASK THAT YOU DO NOT TAKE
IMMEDIATE REAUTHORIZATION
OPTICAL BECAUSE YOUR CRITICAL
THAT WE SEND THE NECESSARY
MARKET SIGNALS AND MAINTAIN
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCES THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT
GOING FORWARD. OTHER THING
ABOUT PAST MANAGEMENT AND
AGRICULTURE BUDGET PROBABLY
SUPPORT THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE APPROVED
THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION PROCEEDING ON WITH
THE PROGRAM WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT UPDATING IT HEARING THE
PESTICIDE NORTH BEACH
DISINFECTED BY USE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS PESTICIDES BUT IN THE
MEANTIME THE FOR THE PROPOSED
PLAN TO PROVIDE INTERIM FUNDING
FOR TRANSITION. MANAGEMENT
INCLUDES SEVERAL IMPORTANT
ITEMS THAT WE SUPPORT FOR
EXAMPLE YOUR RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE TEN MILLION DOLLARS I
NOTIFICATION NETWORK IT KEEPS
YOUR- AND YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION AT BUDGET THE
LANGUAGE THE LINK CLASSIFIED.
MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT. AND
WHAT IS FROM THE PLAN FUNDING
FOR ME PROTECT. WHICH FINALLY-
URGED THE SENATE TO INCLUDE
MILLION COMMUNITY SUPPORT FUND
THAT WORKS PROVIDE RESOURCES
THE PEOPLE ON TOP. AT GREATEST
RISK OF HARM PESTICIDE USE.
ANDRE WE CAN TO SUPPORT THE
SENATE. PROPOSED THE BEST. AND
ASK ABOUT CHURCH RECRUIT
JUBILEE DOLLARS IN THE MAIL
FIVE THE WATER AND POWER. DOT I
PACKAGE. UP ON ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS IN THE REST OF THE
EDGE THAT WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR DOCTOR HEARING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. LINE ONE OR
THREE. SURE THERE WE CAN INTO
HERE- ON BEHALF OF A COUPLE OF
QUIET- FIRST OF ALL SANDALS
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI ON ISSUE
NINETY ALSO DISCUSSED THE ISSUE
EIGHTY EIGHT- WE SUPPORT AT
LEAST ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR WATER
RECYCLING AND STORMWATER
CAPTURE PROJECTS WOULD LIKELY
INCREASE FUNDING FOR MY MOTHER
READ MEDIATION OF TOXIC SITES
AS WELL- AND A LITTLE BUDGET
ITEM BUT- I WANTED TO JUST DRAW
ATTENTION TO THAT AND WHILE.
WE'RE ON THE GRIDLOCK AND RIVER
ALSO- ISSUE THIRTEEN A MAY
OCCUR STUDY CORRESPONDING- OVER
ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
BEFORE- NAMELY AN ADDITIONAL
TWO POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
FOR ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ENTERED
THE FRAY ACCOMPANYING COST
BARRIERS AND FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY- WE
SUPPORT- THE PROPOSED
EXPENDITURES IN ISSUE THIRTEEN
A- AND- THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
THE REMAINDER OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS. ABOUT THE ROBUST
PACKAGE ONLY NATURAL- I'VE
MANAGED TO ADOPT- OR A CHANGE
OVER THEIR SLEEP YOUR. MISSION
CAN YOU. AND YOUR PERFORMANCE
BY WRISTS FOR THE TWENTY APRIL
TWENTY. AND THANKS LOOKING
AROUND THE LOCAL. AND IT WAS
GREAT MANDATE WE WANT TO GO TO
A FUND CARGO WE WILL UP ON CARD-
AND BECAME IS TRUE FOR THE-
LINE FOR BUT LEADS. THE LARGEST
REAL. OPERATE LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE G. THANK
YOU NEXT. NINE NINETY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF SISTANI KILGORE ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
THE ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT AND RANCHO CALIFORNIA
WATER DISTRICT- WE VERY MUCH-
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SENATE
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE'S DROUGHT
RELIEF AND RATE AND REVIEW THE
PROPOSAL AT THE EARLIER IN THE
MONTH- VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
HARD WORK THAT THE IMMEDIATE
BAN ON THIS AS WELL AS
LEADERSHIP AND STAFF. WE ARE
PARTICULARLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
RATE OF RELIGIOUS BELIEF OR
ACTION OF THE PROPOSAL AS WE
HAVE YOU KNOW SO MANY GREAT
PLAYERS. THE DIRECT RESULT OF
COVERT NINETEEN AND FINALLY WE
DO CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
IN THIS AREA AND THINK THAT-
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROVISIONS IN
HIS PROPOSAL THAT WOULDFIT
NICELY IN YOURS AGAIN JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE EFFORT.
THANK YOU NEXT. NINE EIGHTY
TWO. YES HI THIS IS MIKE
ROBESON FROM EVERY SINGLE
DIRECTION SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE LITTLE BIG BURGER JOINT
POWERS AGENCY- SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE ISSUE FORTY ON
PAGE THIRTY EIGHT- TO. GLIDE
FUNDING FOR THE FIRST PHASE OF
THE YEAR WILL BYPASS PHASE ONE.
IN SUPPORT OF THAT AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE REGULAR. HOUSE
AGENCY- SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNMENT'S CLIMATE AND WATER
RETENTION PACKAGES-
SPECIFICALLY. IN DOLLARS FOR
DWI PER CAPITA IN THE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO D. W.
R. FOR FLOOD PROTECTION I'M
STRONGLY URGE US SUPPORT OF
THOSE ITEMS AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. NINE ONE ONE.
YES GO AHEAD. I WOULD HAVE TO
NAME MY NAME IS BATTLING WITH
POLLUTION AT. SEVENTEEN THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK
AT THE AFTERNOON AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PLANET ONE
FROM PERMITTED. QUITE UNCERTAIN
ABOUT. THE CORPORATE. AFTER I
THAT'S- SOME OF PROVIDES
SERVICE REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
RUBBLE OF THE PARK AFTER MIDDLE
BUT ARE. ABOUT A LEAST. I A
SHIPMENT OF IMPEACHING WITHOUT
FROM A BOOK FROM THE PROJECT
AFTER THAT BYTHE WHETHER
COMMUNITY. BILLION IN FUNDING
FOR THE STATE RUN BOARD BROADER
ANYBODY BETTER INTEREST FROM.
AFTER WAS ABOUT. FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION CONTINUED
FROM FROM THE PURPOSE OF THE
FROM I'M DEFINITELY LOOKING
BENEFIT PROJECT THAT BENEFITS.
THE COMPANY AFTER ACTIVE
BENEFITS BUT A LOT OF SHOCK THE
KITCHEN A LOT OF BUT YOU WERE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED PLUS. WITH
TAX. LINE EIGHTY. ATTENTION
INJURE MEMBERS PERFORM CORRECT
ACCOUNT BEHALF OF THE CLIENT
FIRST WE HAVE TO PUT ON A
COUNTY LEVEL THING I SUPPORT
PETITION FORTY PART BELIEVE THE
AGENDA OF THE SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION FOR THE CONTRARY
GRANDSTAND THE ON GOING ON A
BIKE PATH IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE A PROPERTY
COMPANY PRODUCT WHICH ACCOUNT
BANK NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL
AND PUBLIC PROBATION OF NORTH
AMERICA AND WESTERN FASTER WITH
MANAGEMENT THIRTY ON A SHIP
NINE OTHER CONNIE PACKAGE WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR
NEEDS OF. THE PUBLIC A FIFTY
FIVE MILLION TO POWER CYCLE
ORGANICALLY PROPHETICALLY
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT AT THIRTEEN THREE
BY REQUEST FOR LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THIS AMOUNT. TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. WHAT
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
AT TEN PROPOSAL TO ENTER
MILLION. THE VELOP AND
IMPLEMENT THE THIRTEEN THREE
OKAY PROCESS A PRO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. FIND ONE ALL
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
DID BE UNHAPPY CALIFORNIA SEVEN
I TRIED TO TALK TO TODAY PARTY
OF THE ENGINE THAT FIRST ONE IS
THIS YOUR NUMBER 90% CLIMATE
PACKAGE I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK ON THAT
AND OTHER INCLUSION OBTAINED A
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
URBAN GREENING COOLING
RESILIENCY CENTERS AND BACK UP
POWER AS WELL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR C. LEVEL RISE LOCAL
GRANTS TO HELP ADDRESS. THE
LEVEL LIKE THIS YOU CAN COASTAL
COMMUNITY- ADDITIONALLY THE
SECOND ITEM I LIKE TO SPEAK TO
THE ISSUE NUMBER SIXTY NINE THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY PACKAGE ON A
RAID ARRAY FROM THE COMMENTARY
MADE BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF THE DOLLARS BUT
WON'T REGRET OUR SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE- ALREADY PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
TO HELP ANYTHING COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF THIRTEEN THREE
ORGANIC WHICH REGULATION AND
AFTER THAT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
BEING BUMPED UP TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU RAJ
WILL WORK ON IT. I APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU NEXT. WHEN WE OLD
FOR. IT BY BEING. IT IS YOUR
LAN IS OPEN HI THERE THANK GET
AFTER MR VIA BLANCO WITH MY
BUSINESS MAJORITY WERE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUES SEVENTY EIGHT
THE HEALTHY FOREST
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAM A
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY IS A
FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER ADVOCATE THE
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION. PRIMARILY WORK IN
ACCESS- IN PROMOTING ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL SERVICES GRANT
PROGRAM INCLUDING THE HEALTHY
START THE FEDERATION THAT
PROGRAM FIND SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
STRENGTHENING SCRIPTING PROGRAM
WELL BEFORE THE RESTORATION
GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES
INCENTIVES ARE LOCALLY OWNED
STORES AND OTHER SMALL SCALE
STORAGE MARKET ENERGY EFFICIENT
REFRIGERATION WITHOUT HEALTHY
FOOD ACROSS THE STATE WE HAVE A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER THAT IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROGRAM
PARTICIPATED IN IT LAST YEAR
THE HONOR OF WITH LOVE MARKET
CAFE. THAT WE PARTICIPATED IN
THE PROGRAM LAST YEAR AND
RECEIVED YOUR BEAUTIFUL THERE
ARE PREPARED AND PLASTIC
PROGRAMMING EXPERIENCE ONE THAT
I HIGHLY RECOMMEND ALL SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS IN THE AREA
THANK. YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
THE NEXT. LYING FIVE. CAN YOU
MY NAME SYED MANY LEADERSHIP
CAN PERFECT WE KIND OF BELIEVE
IN FOR THE TO COME AS WE
CONTINUE TO ON THE OTHER FOR
DIED AS THEY ARE WITH UNDER MY
EFFORTS ACHIEVE CLEAN ENERGY
ADDITIONALLY THEY'LL BE I'VE
BEEN PLAYING WITH THE CORPORATE
VENTURE THE QUANTIFIABLE
EMISSION REDUCTION TO ENHANCE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS. AND
DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTION. BUT
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM IT BUT-
NOTIFICATION PRODUCT PROGRAM
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S MILKY AND
THAT WE THAT. WHEN OF THE
PROPOSED LOOKING CLICK ON I
THINK DIRECTOR COMMUNITY
PROTECTION A PUBLIC TO PROTECT
BUT AT THE BACK THANKS
APPLICATION. AND PROTECTIVE
GEAR FOR WORKERS AFTER A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
THE FACT THAT LAST WEEK AFTER
ALLEGEDLY IN DOLLAR INVESTMENT
FOR INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES FROM
THE PERFORMANCE CLASS AND
RESTRICT THE LEAF THAT LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
CAN'T HAVE HIGH QUALITY JOBS
CAREER OPPORTUNITY CLEAN WATER
AND CLEAN AIR THANK. YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. I AM A SEVEN. THAT
AFTERNOON AFTER AMONG OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS CAN THEY
CAN'T BEGINS STRONG OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
WITHIN ISSUES AREA. ONE FIVE
AND THIRTEEN. ABOUT THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION SECTORS
INCLUDING LIGHT DUTY HEAVY DUTY
AND OFF ROAD. BECAUSE THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL BE REQUIRED IF
THE PAY IS EMITTED THE GRAPH OF
DECARBONIZATION GOALS AND WHEN
THE NATION OF COMBATING CLIMATE
CHANGE. THE PROBLEMS BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF SCALING THE
PRODUCTION OF RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN IN CALIFORNIA TO BRING
DOWN THE CARBONIZATION COP
ACROSS THE TRANSPORTATION AND
ENERGY SECTORS. PROVIDE ACCESS
TO FIREARMS DISPATCHABLE
RENEWABLE POWER AND ENHANCED
GREAT RIGHT RELIABILITY AND
GRID RESILIENCY. UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENTS IN MAJOR
DECARBONISATION PROJECTS LIKE
THE THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR LONG DURATION
STORAGE ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION PROPOSED FOR GREEN
OCULAR HYDROGEN PRODUCTION.
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THEIR
MISSION VEHICLE THE REFUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE NECESSARY
AND TIMELY ME CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS. FINALLY RECEIVED
THE DATA PART THE GOVERNOR OF
INCLUSION OF FUNDS FOR THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE INCENTIVES AND CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM. EVENTS
HAVE PROVEN TO HELP STIMULATE
THEIR MISSION VEHICLE SALES.
INCLUDING FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE SALES WHICH I CAN
ATTEST TO PERSONALLY
CONGRATULATE THE FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE MYSELF. I
THINK THAT IS WHAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE STATE THE
COMBINATION OF BOTH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND.
CONSIDERATION NEXT. I AM FOUR.
I'M GOOD AT CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
WINSTON BUMPER CENTER OF RECORD
BOAT CAN CARRY. AND- I WANTED
TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW TODAY AND
SPEAKING ON CONDITION THIRTY
FOUR- FISCAL STABILITY. FOR
BUILDING PROGRAMS AND- I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION. OF NO
INCREASE IN REGISTRATION FEES
NOW UNTIL A STAPLES PROCESSES
PUT IN PLACE TO DEVELOP A PLAN
FOR THE LONG TERM ONGOING
STABILITY ON THE HARBORS AND
WATERCRAFT REVOLVING FUND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT.
NINE EIGHTY SIX IT'S- PRETTY
MUCH YOU CARE NUMBERS
UNDERCOUNT FISH CONSERVATION
PROGRAM MANAGER WITH OCEAN
CONSERVANCY WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF
GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSED CLIMB INVESTMENTS IN
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
OPC TO PLAY A COORDINATING ROLE
IN PROTECTING RESTORING AND
CREATING AN ADDITIONAL TEN
THOUSAND ACRES OF COASTAL
WETLANDS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
INCLUSION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. OVER TWO YEARS
PROVIDES CRITICAL FUNDING TO
ADVANCE COASTAL WETLAND
RESTORATION CRITICAL FOR
PROTECTING CONSUMER RIGHTS
ALONG WITH MYRIAD. URGING KERR
BENEFITS LIKE LIABILITY
PROTECTION CARBON SEQUESTRATION
OF PUBLIC ACCESS. WE BELIEVE
WILL BE SEEN AS THE RED STATE
ENTITY TO STORE WAS PROJECT. SO
THE HIGHEST CONCERNS ARE
IMPORTANT RESTORATION PROJECTS
ARE PRIORITIZED WASHINGTON
WOULD YOU ALSO RECEIVE SUPPORT
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
STATE. PARKS RIGHT ARRIVES
ABOUT ADAPTATION STRATEGY AND
FINALLY WE THANK THE SENATE FOR
PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION SHE RANTS
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
X. YEAH LINES. SEVENTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE BUDGET THIS IS
HIGHLY RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
BORROWER YES WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR THIRTY MILLION
REQUESTS FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WE SUPPORT A
TRANSITION THE PAPER THING
ABOUT PEST MANAGEMENT. WITH THE
PART HOTEL TO UPDATE AND SHARE
THE PART THE SIDE MILKY AND WE
SUPPORT INVESTMENT AND WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS AND POLLINATOR
HABITAT LAST YEAR 98% OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN A PLACE IN
PLACE SAYS BACK ON AFTER GRADE
FOR AIR QUALITY WE ARE YOU HE
WILL PROVE POPULAR SUPPOSE
OFFER FUNDING FOR TRUCKS BUSES
AND ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES. WE
URGE YOU TO RECONSIDER-
RENEWING EIGHTY EIGHT VEHICLE
REGISTRATION FEES WE HAVE BEEN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND ARGUE TO
MAKE CLEAN AIR INVESTMENT BY
ALLOCATING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET IF THE
COURT CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROGRAMS LIKE CLEAN
CARTS FOR ALL ENSURE THAT HALF
OF THE INVESTMENTS ARE MADE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY'RE NEEDED ABOUT. FIVE
PLEASE READ PLEASE APPROVE
CLEAN ENERGY INVESTMENT WE CAN
ACCELERATE TRANSITION TO HYBRID
THAT RENEWABLE ENERGY. THANK
YOU. NEXT. NINE ONE OH TWO.
THANK YOU TO ENSURE IN THE- MY
NAME IS TROY COOK I'M REPRESENT.
ME BOX ANGELA CLEANTECH
INCUBATOR OUR COMMENTING ON
ISSUE THIRTEEN TODAY. ARE YOU
FURTHER REFINE THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU
TO PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BEYOND WHAT
IS IN THE PRESENT PROPOSAL FOR
THE PORT OF HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE TRUCKS. YOUR
MISSION TRUCK AND AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS
ENSURING THE EQUITABLE
EQUITABLE DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE WOULD ALSO. THANK
YOU TO- LONGER TERM CERTAINTY
FOR FUNDING AT THE EIGHTY EIGHT
OFFERED THE THREE OPPOSITION
WHAT THANK YOU THANK YOU MAX.
NINE ONE HUNDRED. HELLO GERMAN
LOOK BY CALCIUM ONE OF YOUR
BOAT WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
ESTUARY INSTITUTE I'M SPEAKING
ON THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PACKAGE ISSUED NINETY THREE ON
THE CHART ON PAGE ONE THIRTEEN
I JUST WANT TO REINFORCE THE
POINTS MADE BY THE CHAIR AND I
MISS ALICE FROM THE LA ALSO
OFFERS REGARDING THE ENORMOUS
NEED AND SUBSTANTIAL AVOIDED
COST BENEFIT. FUNDING LOCAL AND
REGIONAL CLIMATE ADAPTATION THE
REALITY IS ABOUT 90% OF CLIMATE
ADAPTATION THIS LAND USE
PLANNING AND ABOUT 90% OF LAND
USE PLANNING STORE CLOSURES AT
THE CITY AND COUNTY LEVEL
CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO CITIES FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES AND A HUNDRED
NINE TRIBAL AREAS THIS IS WHERE
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING.
KERR AND THIS IS WHERE YOUR
SENATE POPOSAL TO FUND THE
STATE CONSERVANCY AND THE
COASTAL COMMISSION WILL BE
ESSENTIAL AND HAVE A MAJOR
IMPACT YOU HAVE A LETTER FROM
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
REPRESENTING FIFTY SIX CO
SIGNED BY FIFTY SIX CLIMATE
ADAPTATION LEADERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS AND THE NGO SECTOR WE
ENFORCING THIS VERY POINT.
FINALLY I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
PROPOSAL DOES NO APPEAR TO
RECOGNIZE THE CRITICAL THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH CAN AND SHOULD
PLAY IN COORDINATING AND
PROVIDING GUIDELINES TO SUPPORT
THE SEPARATE BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR WHAT YOU HAVE PUT DOWN
THE NEST YOU HAVE PROVIDED A
VERY BOLD DIRECTION ON CLIMATE
ADAPTATION FOR CALIFORNIA THANK.
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
NEXT. NINE ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR SHARING CENTER MY NAME IS
DANGEROUS ON HUNDRED CREWS ARE
ARE SPECIFICALLY A IS THIRTEEN
OF THE JET. THAT PROPOSAL CRUZ
IS A FULLY ELECTRIC AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE COMPANY I WILL BE
OFFERING RIDE SHARING AND
DELIVERY SERVICE. WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNORS HAVE BECAUSE OF
INCREASING THE REGISTRY I JUST
READ YOUR COMMITMENT. IS THAT
FUTURE. AS THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
WE REQUEST THE INNOVATIVE
BUSINESS MODELS ARE CRUISE.
OVER TO COMPETE FOR FUNDS TO
BUILD OUT THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. SPECIFICALLY WE
ASKED THAT ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS THREE CHARGING
STATIONS INCLUDE COMPANIES THAT
INCREASED ZERO EMISSION MILES
TRAVELED BY MEMBERS OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC THANK YOU. NEXT
MAKES TWELVE LINE. ONE ELEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
BALLOT APPS WITH THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
ON ISSUE EIGHTY SIX WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT FOR A.
B. SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES IN THE
AMOUNT OF TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BUT
REQUEST THE SENATE CONSIDER
INCREASING EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING WHICH
HAS BEEN POSTED FOR FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS DESPITE ANNUAL
INCREASES IN NUMBERS. THE
COMMUNITY AN ERROR TO. STRICT
WORKED WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE SENATE SUPPORT THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT
REAUTHORIZES KARL MOYER PROGRAM
IN EIGHTY EIGHT. INDEED THE
ONLY TWENTY FOUR EXPIRATION THE
CONVOY- PROGRAM PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
BENEFITS ACROSS THE STATE
ESPECIALLY TO THE AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR AND WE REQUEST YOU
SUPPORT THIS HIGHLY COST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
NEXT. LINE. ONE FIFTEEN. THAT
MENTION FOR THE SANTA ANA
WATERSHED PROJECT AUTHORITY IN
REGARDS TO THE GERMAN WATER
FUNDING STOP I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM I. R. W. M.
ARE PROVEN REGIONAL PROGRAMS
THAT CAN IMPACT THE REGIONAL
SOLUTION TO DRIVE IMPACT.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK YOU.
X. X. ONE ONE TWELVE. SHARE
THANK YOU KATHLEEN BYE THERE'S
GONNA BE HAPPY TO CLIENTS
TODAY- FIRST ON BEHALF OF BUT
ON OUR PART A NUMBER. THIRTEEN
WHY SHOULD I. WORK FOR THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME THAT
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALSO
URGE YOU TO. REJECT IT BACK OUR
RECOMMENDATION AND THE PORK B.
EIGHTY EIGHT RE AUTHORIZATION-
BUT WE BELIEVE NOW IS THE RIGHT
TIME TO SECURE THESE FUNDS FOR
LONG TERM INVESTMENT AND THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT CAN ONLY
HAPPEN BUT- WHAT YOU'RE REALLY
JUST BANK THE FINANCE. STAFF
AND NUMBERS FOR OTHER WORK IN
SUPPORTING UTILITIES WHERE
UTILITY CUSTOMERS WITH
SIGNIFICANT RESEARCH HAS. BEEN
A LOT OF FACTORS THAT GOT BAY
AND- THE ELECTRIC SIDE- THE
RELIGIOUS THANK YOU FOR THAT-
SECONDLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ALSO SUPPORT THE ASSOCIATED
REAUTHORIZATION MAYBE EIGHTEEN
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING THAT S
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR IF YOU
ARE P. I. N. OTHER- CLEAN
VEHICLE PROGRAM. I BELIEVE THE
NUMBER IS. NUMBER AND ALSO
PERCEIVE YOUR PEAK MAKING IT
LOW INCOME ONLY. MAKE IT THE
PATIENT TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE WILL TRULY TRANSFORM THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION MARKET- WE
WOULD ALSO URGE DECISION ON
THESE- AND NOT NOT TO BE
DEFERRED- INCLUDING CRP WHICH
CURRENTLY HAS THOUSANDS OF
PRESIDENT ON- WEIGHTLESS. THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH- NECKS. ONE
THIRD. GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE
HELPED MEMBERS THAT THEY CAN I
CAN TELL YOU KNOW TO PART B.
THE OBJECT THE COMPANY PLANTS
AND OF THE COURT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
FUNDING ISSUED NINETEEN TWO
THREE TWENTY THREE BUT WE WOULD
ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT- THE DEPARTMENT
DEPARTMENT WIRKLICH IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL LONG TERM FUNDING
SOLUTION AND REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY Q. REGARDING ISSUE
NINETY DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
SUPPORT THE SENATE DROP PACKAGE
INVESTMENT AND VISION ROBERT
AND I WOULD APPLY MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE MADE BY JENNIFER
FEARING. I'D ALSO ADD THAT
UNDER THE WILDLIFE REQUEST THAT
THERE IS FUNDING MADE AVAILABLE
ON THE FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT
FOR THE FALCONS TEAM- TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE OF WHICH
WHAT WAS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR IT'S NOT EVEN GOING TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THE IMPERIAL AND
COACHELLA VALLEY AN IMPORTANT
FOR THE WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT WOULD ALSO
EXPRESSED CONCERN OVER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR LAND REPURPOSED THINGS
WITHOUT ANY DIRECTION OR
STANDARDS TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC MONEY WILL PROVIDE
PUBLIC BENEFIT FOR ISSUE- NINE
NINETY ONE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY OF DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE SUPPORT BENNETT'S
RECOMMENDATION I WOULD JUST
REFER BACK TO THE MAIN ELEVEN
LETTERS BYE BYE BYE MORE THAN
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS TO ENSURE
THAT MONEY SPENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- THAT WILL NOT
HAPPEN- A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
THE ENVIRONMENT OR EXACERBATE
BUYER. AND FINALLY PUT YOU
NINETY THREE DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY AT THE NEVERLAND
TRUST AMP YOU SUPPORT THE US
SENATE CLIMATE PACKAGE
ESPECIALLY THE PROPOSED FUNDING
FOR THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD AND THE CONCERN TEAM
INCLUDING THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY WOULD FURTHER URGE
THAT- FINAL FUNDINGFOR THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY WOULD
INCLUDE MONEY FOR THE REMOVAL
OF THE DAM AT SUCH AS THE
MATTEL HOT POTTER VALLEY
PROJECT IN BATTLE CREEK I
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT CONSERVATION
REPORT WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS MONEY DIRECTED TO
WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY AND- IT.
HAPPENED. AND THAT MONEY IS
MADE AVAILABLE TO OTHER PARDON
THE STATE NOT CURRENTLY SERVED
BY CONSERVANCY PROBE. SUCH AS
THAT. DESERT THANK YOU MUCH.
YOU KNOW. ONE TWENTY. GOOD
AFTER MEMBERS OF THE EIGHT IN
WITH THE WRONG BUT THAT
CALIFORNIA WANTING TO PUT GREAT
KERR ON ISSUES ONE THE WHILE AT
EXPENDITURE PLAN ARE HERE SEE
IF THE PART OF A VENDING FOR
OBVIOUSLY FOR A WHILE BY
RESILIENCE AND FOREST RELATED
ACTIVITIES WE SUPPORT A LOT OF
WHAT WAS THEN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HOWEVER WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SENATE
PROPOSAL FOR A FIVE YEAR PLAN
LOOKING OUT AHEAD WE'VE LONG
SUPPORTED MULTI YEAR FUNDING
FOR. WILDFIRE RESILIENCE FOR
HOME HARDING FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE FOR THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS AND WE WOULD SUPPORT THE
FENCE PROPOSAL THERE WE WOULD
ALSO ASK FOR CONSIDERATION FOR
A COUNTY BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM-
WE PUT THAT IN OUR LETTER THAT
WE FILED YESTERDAY- A LOT OF
COUNTY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO APPLY FOR
A COMPETITIVE GRANT AND A BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO GET MONEY OUT ON THE
GROUND LOCALLY AND- WE WOULD
ADD SUPPORT A PROPOSAL LIKE
THAT THANK. YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT. ONE HI THIS IS MARK
BY WHICH OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP SPEAKING
WITH REGARD TO HIS TWENTY SIX
ON THE CAP AND TRADE SPENDING
PLAN AND WE'RE JUST- VERY
THANKFUL FOR THE PROPOSED
APPROPRIATION BILLS FOR THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM-
SENECA BY ERICA REQUESTED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND BUT WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THAT AMOUNT WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT'S
BEEN PROPOSED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE HOPE THAT
CONSTRAINTS IN THE FINAL BUDGET.
NEXT. ONE TWENTY ONE. HI THIS
IS PATRICK WELCH FOR THE COP
TWENTY MINUTES EARLY
DISPOSITION REPRESENTING PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES PUBLICLY OWNED
ELECTRIC UTILITIES RAP THANK.
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SENATE
STRAP. AND PARTICULAR
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE BUT
PROVIDE THE PROJECTED PATH%
TOWARD MITIGATING THE IMPACT
THAT THIS YOURSELVES AND HELP
CUSTOMERS ACHIEVE UNITY WATER
SYSTEMS IN PUBLIC- ELECTRIC
UTILITIES. UNPAID BOTTOM RIGHT
DOWN. THAT MEANS ONE DOING AND
I'M ROB BILLS THREE MILLION I'M
LOOKING ON THE BACK OF THE
BUILD UP IN NINETEEN. THE
SUPPORT PROVIDING GREAT CARE
WITH THE CITY DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT AND A FAST AND
EFFICIENT MANNER THAT EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO CUSTOMERS ALL SIDES.
OUR SYSTEM. OF PUBLICLY OWNED
ELECTRIC. CLOSING DATE. HAS
ALSO BUT THE BEST TO DROP
RELIEF AND THIS. WHICH WERE
OUTLINED WITH VOCAL JENNA I
THINK SOME OF THOSE PHOTOS TO
COMPLEMENT. OF INSURANCE PLAN
INCLUDES LEGISLATURE
MINISTRATIONS WORKED ON A FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT THAT WILL
DRESS STOP IMPACTS BUT BUT IT
WILL COVER SEVEN NINETY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT. ONE TWENTY
TWO. A GOOD AFTERNOON I CAN
REMEMBER THE VILLAGE AT THE
HIGH WITH THE POIGNANT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE PROVIDING
ADEQUATE SERVICES SUCH AS
HEALTH CARE FIRE PROTECTION
PARKS RECREATION AND UTILITY
THAN MANY OTHERS I ASK YOU A HI
COMING AT WE ARE IN THE CORNER
AS AND IF YOU SEVENTY THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
PROPOSED BETWEEN RESILIENT
BETTER BUT WOULD URGE THAT IN
THE DETAILS DOT BUT BUT
DISTRICTS ARE INCLUDED IN THE
DISCUSSION AND EXPLICITLY OUGHT
TO PROFILE WHATEVER INVESTMENT
BOTH MIGHT GO TOWARDS. I'M
RIGHT BY IT WITH THE CLIMATE
RESILIENT OXYGEN WE'VE BEEN
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE BOND
PROPOSALS AND APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT ACCOUNT I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
DETAIL GETS FLESHED OUT I'M NOT
THAT PROPOSED FUNDING BE
ALLOCATED FOR ADVANCE PAYMENT
OF GRANTS FOR THOSE DISTRICTS
YOU WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
OTHERWISE THE PRICE AND THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING
OUGHT TO BE AVAILABLE AND AGAIN
ABOUT THE ELIGIBILITY BE
EXPANDED SO THAT WHENEVER A
LOCAL AGENT P. AS IN PAUL CAME
UP BY BUT THAT WITHOUT THEM IN
A SPECIAL DISTRICTS WITH
OTHERWISE. YOU MAY NOT WANT HE
DID BETTER LIKE CAN I OF IF
THERE ANYTHING THAT WE LEFT OUT
ALL OF THESE. ARE YOU WITH. OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S
WHAT DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN UNIQUE
IT. FROM ALLSTATE AND FEDERAL
BROKE RELIEF FUND OUR LOCAL
FUNDING FOR COMPANY. AND TO
THAT AND WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE- PACKAGES THAT WOULD.
GIVE A BILLION. OR GIVEN OF YOU
TELLING NONPAYMENT OF DEBT AND
WE ARE HAVE A PREFERENCE TO THE
SENATE PROPOSAL BUT-
INTRODUCTION ABOUT FUNDING. AND
WITH THE WILDFIRE PACKAGES
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
FIVE YEAR PLAN BUT WOULD RGE
YOU TO INCLUDE A GRANT PROGRAM
AND NOT THAT WOULD BE. DIRECTED
TOWARDS- INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. HAVE EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT WILL COVER
NINETEEN RESPONSE BUT THEY MAY
BE ABLE TO HAVE CONTINUED
ROBUST BY RESPONSE IN THIS.
WILDFIRE SEASON AND I'M IN THE
FUTURE I MIGHT BUY IT WITH A
PARKING BACK MEANT THE
GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. OPPOSES FUNDING UNDER
ISSUE TWENTY SPECTACLE NOT
EXPAND AT THE MOST FAVORABLE
OUT BACK WITH THE PART BUT- THE
STATE PROPERTY AT RECREATION
AND OPEN SPACE DISTRICT HAVE
RECEIVED. NO BOX OFFER ANY OF
BEAR WATCHES OVER THIS LAST
YEAR DESPITE BEING VERY PRESENT
IN PROVIDING. SERVICES
ESSENTIAL TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND EDUCATION AND
CHILD CARE SERVICES AND WHAT
APPS FOR YOU TO. CONSIDER
EXPANDING NOT FUNDING FOR THOSE
PURPOSES THANK. YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WANT FOUR. YEAH IN TURN
MEMBERS THIS IS I AM NOT BURKE
ON BEHALF OF THE CAL STATE
BEEKEEPERS WITH. IN SUPPORT OF-
THE HE HAD MADE P. P. I'M ITEM
SEVEN ONE- OF THE PART YET
GENDER TO SUPPORT THE D. EIGHT
PROGRAMS WITH TO HOW OF
BEEKEEPING AND PROTECTING
POLLINATORS THAT I HELP THE
AGRICULTURE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY AND ITEM EIGHTY FOUR
ON THE SAME AGENDA I WOULD
SUPPORT THAT DIGITAL FUNDING
FOR POLLINATOR HEALTH FORAGE.
AND HABITAT THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT. ONE TWENTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE
ACT ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION IN NATURE
GIRL WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION FOR
CONSERVATIVES IN THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY PACKAGE AND THE
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION FOR EACH
CONCERT AT THE AT THE WILDFIRE
PACKAGE. YOU'RE GRATEFUL THE IS
THE DENTURE RESOURCES PROPOSED
TO SUPPORT OUR CRITICAL AND
EFFECTIVE AND SEVENTY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ONE AREA
WE DO THINK IT'S LACKING IN
YOUR PROPOSAL HOWEVER IF
FUNDING TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
BASED WORK FORCE TRAINING AND
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAMS AND
EFFORTS BY COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROGRAMS THAT COULD BE
ACCOMPLISHED- ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS NOT. IN
OUR AID. IF UNITY ACT THE GRANT
PROGRAM. THERE. ONE OH SEVEN.
HI CATHERINE DOT- I THANKS-
KAREN WHITE HOW CAN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE STAFF
I'M- REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT ALL OF THE
ISSUES BEFORE YOU WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
ENTERTAINMENT INNOVATIVE
FUNDING PROPOSALS. I YOUR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY EFFORTS WILL
HOPEFULLY REDUCE THE NEED FOR
THE DROUGHT AND OTHER.
REMEDIATION EFFORTS IN THE
FUTURE. IT'S DIFFICULT. ON I
TWENTY TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
ENGINES. SIXTY NINE AND NINETY
ONE EIGHT. IN TERMS OF
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE.
CALIFORNIA DOES VERY LITTLE TO
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES FROM PESTICIDES WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PESTICIDE
BELCHING TO MAKE THE MOST
HARMFUL PESTICIDES MORE
EXPENSIVE I MOVED TOWARDS A
CALL TURNING UP. WE SUPPORT THE
FUNDING PROTECTED BY
NOTIFICATION NETWORK
SURVEILLANCE CAN PROTECT THEIR
FAMILIES FROM PESTICIDES
APPLICATIONS ARE OCCURRING WE
ALSO SUPPORT EXPANDED AIR
MONITORING WHICH MUST INCLUDE
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT. THE
DEPARTMENT PARKS. AND
REGULATION MUST BE REQUIRED THE
TICK PROTECTION PROTECTIVE
ACTIONS FOR THE SCREEN. THEY
ARE VULNERABLE AND THEY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. THEY BEAR BOTH THE
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM HEALTH
EFFECTS OF PESTICIDE EXPOSURE.
CRITICALLY MISSING FROM THE
FUNDING AS SPECIFIC SUPPORT
FUND- FOR COMMUNITY SO THAT
THEY CAN. BUY PERSONAL
PROTECTION EQUIPMENT. AND AIR
FILTERS FOR THEIR FAMILIES WE
ALSO SUPPORT FUNDING FOR SAFE
STORAGE WE URGE ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE PREFERENCE
FOR ORGANIC FOOD AND THE BOMBS
GO PROGRAM. OUR KIDS ARE
EXPOSED TO SOME OF THE
CHEMICALS LET'S KEEP. THE
PESTICIDES OUT OF THEIR
STUDENTS. WELL TRY PREVENT YOU
BOTH IN THE SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM AS- YOUR- WITH USING GO
AND SHE- BUT- AND MENTAL HEALTH
CHECKS MODELS. AND WHY SMOKE
WELL BEYOND THE FIRE AND IT HAS
LASTING EFFECTS. THREE SUPPORT
THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND
INCREASED FUNDING FOR CITIZEN
CAL CAL NEEDS TO IMPLEMENT-
RECYCLING EFFORTS AND PARK OUT
COMPOSTING. WELCOME SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR EXTREME HEAT
PROTECTIONS WE SEE THE PATIENTS
WHO SUFFER STROKES AND HEART
ATTACKS AND OTHER RELATED
ILLNESSES WHICH AFFECT NOT ONLY
THEMSELVES BUT THEIR FAMILIES.
WE SUPPORT PEOPLE THROUGH
MEDIATION EVER CHEMICAL
ASSOCIATED WITH CANCER AND MANY
OTHER ELEMENTS WHICH UNLOCKS WE
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION FROM
YOUR OLD MACHINE VEHICLES
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO MUST
BEGIN. AGAIN OUT IN BAKERY SAID
DEMAND FOR OIL AND CLEAN UP OUR
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY. CALL I THINK THANK
YOU NEXT DOOR. FINE ONE
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU STEPHEN
AMELL OPEN LIMITS- PROJECT
BUDGET FOCUS ON EQUITABLE SHIFT
TO HELP MORE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS TO
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AMONG HOW-
WE WERE SUCH A CALL THEY SHOULD
ACT QUICKLY AND THEY APPROVE IT
AT. ME THE CLEANER SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION YOU GET THE KERR
YOU NEED TO BEAR TO HELP
IMPACTED WATER QUALITY I'M PART
EIGHT ISSUE FIVE METERS A
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING
OPPOSITION PROGRAMS BUT THE
BUDGET PROCESS TO ENSURE
FUNDING FOR CAR MOTOR AND OTHER
CRITICAL POLLUTION CONTROL
PROGRAM KERRIGAN ARE QUITTING
THE SIGNS ARE INVESTED IN THE
DRAFTING CLIMATE CHANGE DRIVEN
TO HELP WITH. THAT WILL BE THE
END. OBSERVATIONS REGARDING IT
BECOMES HARMFUL AIR POLLUTANTS
AND IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH I'M
PART OF A ISSUE THIRTEEN YOU
SHALL WE SUPPORT THE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
POINT OF LIGHT MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES THIS YEAR THE
BEST OF THE LAND OF OUR MISSION
TO PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
SUBJECT OF TRADITIONAL
INTERMISSION CALIFORNIA'S MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION EQUITY BASED REMISSION
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MUCH OF
A BAND AND SUPPORT OF
NETWORKING SYSTEM INTERMISSION
RECORD. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU NEXT. BUT THE FUNDING
IS CRITICAL FOR NEEDING HELP
THEY GET. BETTER QUALITY
STANDARDS JOB SUMMARY CRITICAL
NEAR TERM EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING
FEDERAL DEADLINE TO REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION AND IF NOT LET. ME
INTO DARKNESS SANCTIONS
RESTRICTIONS ON BUSINESS. AND A
FEDERAL TAKEOVER COULD OCCUR.
WE DISAGREE WITH RECOMMEND TO
REJECT APPROVAL OF THE EIGHTY
EIGHT ROCK MUSICIANS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. NOW IS THE TIME
TO SECURE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PRESENT
AND FUTURE ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO THE COMMON PROGRAM.
EXTENSION NOW PROVIDES PROGRAM
STABILITY AT SOME POINT STATE
IMITATION PLANNED DEVELOPMENT
AND PROVIDE A CLEAR SIGNAL TO
THE MARKET THAT WILL HELP
ENSURE PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN
CLEAN TECHNOLOGY. BURNING
DISTRICTS EIGHTY SIX INCENTIVES
HOWEVER ASKED THAT YOU INCREASE
THE SPENDING TO PRIORITIZE NEAR
TERM EMISSION REDUCTIONS. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE MUSIC
SEVENTEEN INTERPRETATION
FUNDING FOR EVERY DISTRICT BUT
AFTER YOUR CHRISTMAS SPENDING
TO COVER ACTUAL PROGRAM COSTS
THANK YOU. THANKS. ONE THIRTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BILL MCCALLUM WITH
COAST CLEAN ON ITEMS FIVE
THIRTEEN. THE SENATE TO FUND
CLEAN TRUCKS AND BUSES AT THE
LEVEL THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED FOR HIRE BUT BOTH THE
VEHICLES AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BECAUSE PLEASE CLEAN TRUCKS AND
SCHOOL BUSES AND TRANSIT BUSES.
WILL REDUCE. THAT IS BOTH
CHANGING THE CLIENTS AND MAKING
THEIR UNHEALTHY FOR PEOPLE WITH
PRE. WE ALSO URGE FUNDING OF AT
LEAST FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECTS CLEAN CARS
BROUGHT IN THE OTHER EQUITY
PROJECTS THAT PROVIDE CLEAN%
MOBILITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND WE KNOW THAT THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE NOT RECEIVED FUNDING IN
TWO YEARS NOW AND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN FINDING IT
NOW AND WAITING A FEW MONTHS
COULD BE THAT SOME LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
ACCESS TO SAFE. AND CLEAN
RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION. I FINE
WE YOU TO RE AUTHORIZE THE
CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS IN
EIGHTY EIGHT ALONG WITH
GUARANTEES THAT AT LEAST 50% OF
THOSE INVESTMENTS. REACH
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND THE PEOPLE IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
NEXT. ONE THIRTY SEVEN SHOW
LIKE HEALTHY SENATORS AND MS
ROY GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANKS
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THIS IS
ROBERT GOING FROM THE QUALCOMM
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD CONTROL
AGENCY SEKA THE NATION'S MOST
AT RISK SUCH AREA PLEASE NOTE
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR D. W. R.
ISSUES SIX SEVEN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FORTY THE SYSTEM
WIDE FLOOD RISK REDUCTION.
BUBBLE TYPE BENEFIT YOUR BYPASS
PROJECT AND LASTLY THE
RESILIENCE PACKAGES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR FLOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE AS JOHN
STEINBECK IN THE PATERNAL
DECISION REMIND US AFTER THE
DROUGHT COME THE FLOODS THANKS
AGAIN. SIX NINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRIS
WROTE ON BEHALF OF CALCULUS THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
BUT THE PRECIPITATION OF
FUNDING IN THE SENATE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND COURTS REGARDING
THE PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE THAT
THE ONE BILLION DOLLAR FIGURE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
CORPORATE STARTING POINT FOR
NEGOTIATION WITH THE COMPANY
AND LOOK AT THE STATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SENATE ON THE DETAILS OF THE
FINAL PACKAGE AND TO REQUEST
THAT THE FINAL AGREEMENT
INCLUDED THE FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION GRANT. FOR TIM
BURTON WHAT REMOVAL AS PROPOSED
IN THE SENATE THANK YOU. SO
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT. ONE FORTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS THAT WERE
A PROJECT WITH THE CLIMATE
CENTER AROUND THECLIENTS ARE
LARGELY SUPPORTED MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
THE SCALE OF INVESTMENT THE
BEST INCREASE IN ORDER TO
PROPERLY ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
THREAT ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS
OF ENERGY NATURAL WORKING ONE
JOB TRANSITION WHICH THERE'S A
LOT OF YES YOU BET BYE WHAT DO
YOU TELL THAT HIGH LEVEL
PERSPECTIVE. ON INVESTMENTS IN
MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS ENERGY
RESILIENCE I THINK OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS WITH TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION TOWARDS PROJECT
ASIAN A BILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE UP FIFTY
MILLION. TWO SO IT'S NOT A
PRETTY GOOD YEAR. TWO POINT
FIVE FOR. MAJOR BASIC
RESTAURATION. WHAT ANOTHER TWO
POINT NINE. WE ALSO SUGGEST THE
CREATION OF A TWO BILLION
DOLLAR. HI ROAD BONNIE TRUCK
WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT-
EARNING POTENTIAL BENEFITS FOR
WORKERS IN THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY. DURING THE TRANSITION
TO CLEAN ENERGY SEARCH AND
FINALLY WE URGE YOU TO MOVE
QUICKLY TO ADOPTED THAT PACKAGE
INCLUDING REAUTHORIZATION OF
EIGHTY EIGHT PRESIDENT FRANKLIN
ACTUALLY. ON IT NOW THANK YOU
NEXT. NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS
RECOMMEND CONFRONTING AMERICAN
FIVE ONE TRACK THE CALIFORNIA
I'M IN AGRICULTURE NOT WORKING
ON IT ALL COMMENTS ARE
BEGINNING TO BE REGARDING
ISSUES EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
THE GOVERNMENT AGRICULTURAL.
AGRICULTURAL PACKAGES BEFORE
QUICKLY WALKING FOCUS OF A
HUNDRED MILLION A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ALTERNATIVE
MINIMUM MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
REGARDING ISSUE EIGHT POINT
GOVERNOR'S TO CONDUCT WATER
ENHANCEMENT AT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS HE ALSO THE COURT BUT
THE GUY AND SENATOR ABOUT AND A
GRANT HOWEVER WE WANT TO AND
THAT HE GETS PAID HOW SPENDING.
TO GREAT FOR TECH ASSISTANCE
HELLAND ARE SIGNIFICANT QUITE
REGARDING ISSUE NINE YOU CAN'T
WILL BE ASKED TO CONSIDER
CORPORATE BENEFITS AND
COLLISION AT NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE DEPARTMENT. OF
CONSERVATION FOR THAT PART OF
MY- AND WE ASK YOU TO. THE TO A
HIGHER MILLION. ACCORDING ISSUE.
PACIFIC LEE THE SENIOR P. YES
THEY THANK YOU. THE EQUITABLE
SYSTEM OKAY ON THE OF THE WITH
THE NOVEL THE CRIME. AND
INNOVATE HEALTH SOLUTIONS WELL
WE THE PROPOSAL I HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR THE SENIOR
FARMERS MARKET NUTRITION
PROGRAM WE DON'T THINK IT IS
ENOUGH TO MEET THE NEEDS OF LOW
INCOME SENIORS THAT YOU CREATE
THE THING ABOUT REGIONAL MARKET
ABOUT FARMERS. WE ASK THAT YOU
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
THE SCENE HOURS ARE MARKED FOR
SENIORS AND ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO AFFECT THEM AND HE
AND ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION FOR
THE OFFICE TO FIND. OUT WHAT
YOUR PROGRAM. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. ONE FORTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON G. MINOR BEHALF OF
TURLOCK YOUR DISTRICT EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
WE'RE CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE SENATE DROP OPPOSE ALL
THAT WE HAVE SPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR
WATER UTILITIES THAT REALLY
AGRICULTURAL WATER EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS AND FUNDING FOR
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP PROJECT
TYPICALLY SEPTIC TO SEWER
CONVERSION. SEPARATELY ON
BEHALF OF MP WHICH DIVERTED AT
ELECTRICITY CUSTOMERS IN CNTRA
COSTA MARIN NAPA AND SOLANO
COUNTIES WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
LONG DURATION STORAGE IN GREEN
HYDROGEN PROPOSAL CONTAINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE WE
BELIEVE BOTH ARE ESSENTIAL
TECHNOLOGIES FOR ENSURING WE
CAN GET A 100% COVERAGE FOR
INTELLECTUAL THE SECTOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU NECKS.
WHY THIRTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHURCH MEMBERS TELLING JACK ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE NEED TO ACT NOW
ON THE E. B. EIGHT RE
AUTHORIZATION COURTED
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL TO RE
AUTHORIZE EXPAND THE PROGRAM
SUNSET. ACTUALLY DISAGREE WITH
THE STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION TO
REJECT APPROVAL OF THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. BECAUSE WE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM IS THE
FLAGSHIP INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL TO HELPING
YOUR MISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE MARKET DEVELOP.
AND DEPLOY NEW TECHNOLOGIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE STATE'S CRIME
MAKE YOUR MISSION VEHICLE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT
GOALS. THE INDUSTRY IN THE
STABLE LONG TERM MARKET SIGNAL
FROM THE STATE TO CONTINUE
INVESTING IN AND DEPLOYING THE
TECHNOLOGY. CAN BE AUTHORIZED
THE FUNDING AT THE LAST MINUTE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON MARKET GROWTH AND
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE WHICH
WILL ONLY UNDERMINE OUR STATED
MISSION CHRONICLES. NOW IS THE
RIGHT TIME TO SECURE FUNDING
THAT SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE AND WE
URGE YOU TO APPROVE THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL AND NOT TO DEFER
ACTION ON THAT PACKAGE. THANK
YOU. THANKS ONE. THREE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MY CAT IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
REVIEWED THOMPSON BUT THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
ALSO SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS
SHOULD BOTH METROPOLITAN AND
CONTRACTORS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE PROPOSED FUNDING FOR WATER
IN DROUGHT AND COPING NINETEEN
FINANCIAL HELP RETURN WATER
AGENCIES CLEAR CUSTOMER DATA.
SUPPORT ELEMENTS IN THE SENATE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S DROP
PACKAGES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF METROPOLITAN URGES
SENATE TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR
RECYCLED WATER PROJECT RECYCLED
WATER IF THEY DROP BY AND BY
OUR CALCULATION THERE ARE OVER
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN PROJECTS
THAT ARE SHOVEL READY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ALSO
THINK MORE FUNDING IS NEEDED
FOR MONITORING AND TREATMENT OF
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINANTS LIKE.
SH METROPOLITAN INTERSTATE
WATER CONTRACTORS WILL BE
SHARING COPIES OF OUR LETTERS
THAT OUTLINED OUR PRIORITIES
WITH YOUR COMPANY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT ONE FOUR.
THANK YOU SHARE AND MEMBERS I
AM DOCTO STUART WHITE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF MANY OF US WORKING
HARD TO SAVE THE MONARCH
BUTTERFLY MIGRATION AND ALL
POLLINATORS ON ITEM NINETY.
EIGHTY FOUR. ASTROCYTES ARE
DEVASTATING POLLINATORS AND
INSECTS SO WE SUPPORT THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM IN
THE MAIN REVISED BUDGET.
HOWEVER MORE IS NEEDED
MIGRATORY WESTERN MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES IN BROOKLINE MORE
THAN 99% AND A BELOVED
MIGRATION WILL DISAPPEAR UNLESS
WE TAKE ACTION TO RESCUE THEM
JUST AS WE DID CONDORS BUT
SHOOTER. ALSO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR HABITAT NEEDS WE
NEED TO FINALLY ADDRESS
PROBLEMS WITH AVAILABILITY THE
LOCAL NEIGHBORS. SO WE ASK YOU
TO INCLUDE FUNDING FROM MONARCH
RESCUE AND STATEWIDE LOCAL SEED
BANK THAT'S PART OF THE
POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT. ONE
THIRTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHURCH MEMBERS THIS IS DUE TO
CLEANING THE CONSERVATION
STRATEGY GROUP CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE CLIMATE
RESILIENT PACKAGE ISSUE NINETY
THREE- ON BEHALF OF THE WILD
BIRD CONSERVANCY AND CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL THANK
YOU. NEXT. TWENTY EIGHT. TWO
EIGHT IS YOUR LINE ON MUTE YEAH
IRAN GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE THE
LINE ONE NINETEEN. MR TRAN
MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY SHOP WHICH I
YOUR INTERNATIONAL TRAVELLING
ON BEHALF OF YOUR CLIENT BUT
SOMETHING HAPPENS I'M TALKING
ABOUT YOUR POLLUTION CONTROL
BUT- NOW HE FACING ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES AND NEEDING HELP
BUILD A QUALITY ATTAINMENT
MANAGERS IN ORDER TO MEET OUR
OBLIGATIONS AS OUTLINED IN OUR
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PROGRAM.
FINALLY URGED THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE REACTIVATION. OF
THE- PROGRAM. FINDING READ BY
FOR THE FARMER. WHICH FOR A
QUALITY AS WELL AS HE COULD NOT
BENEFITS TO THE BATTLE AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT THAT
FOR THE FUNDING INCLUDING
INCLUDED IN THAT PLAN FOR
ALTERNATIVE ACTING ABOUT
HOWEVER WE HOPE TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT FOR THAT
ITEM AND THEY- HAD DETERMINED
THAT THE NEED FOR THE PROGRAM
MUCH GREATER LASTLY THE
DISTRICT SUPPORT INCREASED
SPENDING FOR NEAR TERM
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS WILL
BECOME BANDAGED BELIEVABLE. ON
BEHALF OF ANOTHER CLIENT
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY YEAH
THE SENATE TO CONSIDER
APPROVING THE PROPOSAL. TO BE
AUTHORIZED. I AM NOT PHYSICIAN
WILL PROVIDE CERTAIN FOR. NEEDS
NOW AND THE NEAR I THINK THE
PART. THANK NEXT. NINE ONE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MATT
CALKINS COMMITTEE MEMBER FROM
REGARD ISSUE SIXTY NINE THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY MY NAME IS
NICOLE HI AND ON BEHALF OF THE
YOUTH ALLIANCE AND FIFTY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS COMPANIES CITIES
AND COUNTIES REPRESENT A LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON MAY TWENTY
SECOND. I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND EXPRESS
OUR COURT THE GOVERNOR'S
REVISED BUDGET FUNDING OUT OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE DOLLARS
FOR THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY ARE
THAT ARE SUBJECT THE CARD OUT
OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING SPECIFICALLY. FOR
REVIEW WHICH- I OUTLINED IN THE
WAIT TIME. AND EIGHTY THIRTY
NINE RANKS AS A HIGHER PRIORITY
BEFORE COMPOSTING AND RECYCLING
WHEN YOU HAVE A SMALL MENTION
IN THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE LONG
SECTION. HOWEVER THESE
COMPANIES ARE TYPICALLY SMALL
LOCAL CALIFORNIA BASED
BUSINESSES NONPROFITS OR CITY
PROJECT. AND MOMS ARE DIFFICULT
TO ACCESS OUR QUALIFIED
QUALIFIED FOR RIGHT NOW WITH
CERTAIN TYPES OF BUSINESSES.
CALVER THANK ALL REVIEWS GRANT
PROGRAM HAS ALREADY APPROVED
SIX SHOVEL READY PROJECTS TWO
FAMILIES INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS
THE STATE- FOR FUNDING IF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES BECOME
AVAILABLE THIS YEAR. EVERY
INDUSTRY AS WEB RECYCLING WHAT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO BUT WHAT
POINT TO SCALE UP THE INDUSTRY
LEADING AND LEADING INTO A
TRANSITION- TOWARDS THE
PAINTBALL AND RESILIENT
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. NOT RELIANT
ON FOREIGN RECYCLING MARKET
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION NEXT. ONE SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER THE STAFF ALL UP THERE
ON BEHALF OF WATER REUSE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
STATE'S WATER RECYCLING OUT
WERE EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED
WITH THE GOVERNOR STREPTOCOCCAL
SECRETARY CROWFOOT CORDON LA
TIMES YESTERDAY AND THAT ONE OF
THE MAIN REASONS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ISN'T IN A LARGE
TROUT IS BECAUSE OF WATER
RECYCLING. HOW CAN A DROP
PACKAGE NOT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN NEW SOURCES OF
WATER RECYCLED WATER IT'S
CRITICAL TO CREATING LOCAL AND
REGIONAL WATER GOING IN AND WE
SUPPORT AT LEAST SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION AND RECYCLE
WATER IN THE FINAL DRAFT
PACKAGE AND WE WANT TO A
SPECIFICALLY THANK FOUNDER
STERN FOR HIS COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS ON THE MATTER EARLIER
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU. NEXT
ONE FOUR SEVEN. THANK YOU TERRY
NUMBERS STEPHEN MEYERS SPEAKING
ON ISSUE NINETY THREE ON BEHALF
OF THE COP TWENTY HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
INVESTMENT TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD IN THE
SENATE CLIMATE RESILIENCE PLAN.
HOPE TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE BUDGET COMMITTEES TO ENSURE
TARGETED FUNDING FOR NATIONAL
COMMUNITY CONSERVATION PLANS
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANS
WHICH PROTECT CRITICAL HABITAT
FOR ENDANGERED SPECIES IN
EXCHANGE FOR STREAMLINED
PERMITTING FOR DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. THE WIN WIN FOR
PROTECTING US ON WORKING LANDS
WHILE ALSO ENCOURAGING SMART
DEVELOPMENT AND STIMULATING THE
ECONOMY THANK YOU. NEXT. ONE
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
MARK FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
THE CINEMA COUNTY WATER AGENCY
WILL LARGELY SUPPORT SENATE
STRAP ALSO ELEMENTS OF THE
GOVERNORS AND THE DIVISION
PARTICULARLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
QUESTION FOR FUNDING FOR DATA
COLLECTION AND BOTH PROPOSALS
ARE CRITICAL TO CINNAMON WATER
IS IDENTIFIED FUNDING FOR AN
INSTANT REVERSE RESEARCH AND
WORK ON FORECAST INFORMED
RESERVOIR OPERATIONS WORK HELLO
WHICH CHANNELS WATER AGENCIES
PRESERVE MORE WATER IN DRY
TIMES LIKE THE TRAP WE ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING. WE ALSO
WANT TO PARTICULARLY CALL OUT
THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT THE COMPANY URBAN
SETTING AND IN AGRICULTURE AND
ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
REDUCING. THE NEED FOR MORE
FUNDING FOR WATER RECYCLING. I
WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO. LEND
THEIR SUPPORT TO PRESENT THE
CURRENT CRIME RESILIENT PACKAGE.
OF THE FUNDING FOR THAT NEW TO
BE IN THE- IN PARTICULAR ABOUT
CRITICAL PARTNERS FOR AGENCY
AND REGION TO RESTORE HABITAT.
FOR ENDANGERED AND THREATENED
SALMON AND LOOK AT. AFTER THAT
THEY CONSERVATION. WE ARE
PLEASED WITH THE CENTRAL
PACKAGE IS DETAILED IN OUR-
LETTER PREVIOUSLY SUBMITTED. ON
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
DEPARTMENT FISHING ROD RIGHT
HAVING BRING TAKE ISSUE TWENTY
WE'RE SUPPORTERS. I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE ANY KIND OF FUNDING FOR.
ROBERT PROTECTION UTILIZE THE
CHRISTIAN PERMITTING PROCESS
NEEDS TO MAXIMIZE DOLLARS FOR
PROJECTS YOUR PROJECT
IMPLEMENTED QUICKLY. AND LASTLY
ON BEHALF OF OUR CHAPTERSON
PART A ISSUE THIRTEEN WOULD ACT
ON THE REQUEST FROM THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND MACY FOR
INCREASED INVESTMENT EUROVISION
VEHICLES PARTICULARLY HEAVY
DUTY. AND ALSO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL THAT ABBOTT PROPOSED
SPENDING PER DAILY DIGEST YOURS
BE REJECTED THANK YOU TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF. FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK. NEXT ONE FIFTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK FOR THE R.
TO WRITE IF YOU COMMENTS TODAY
MY NAME IS JOHN KENNEDY I'M
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
THANK GOD RIGHT IF YOU CREATE
COMMON CONDITIONS SIXTY NINE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY IT EXPECTS CAP
AND TRADE FUNDING UNCERTAINTY.
THREE PROGRAM AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE UNDERS. FOR I'D LIKE
TO ALIGN MY COM BECAUSE YOU
COULD FROM SERVICE IS NOT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND OUR
PARTICIPATION IN THE LARGE
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING
COALITION LETTER MISTER CRAIG
REFERENCED. ARE HERE HE'S
TRYING TO SUPPORT THE KIND OF
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN
PROPOSED DEDICATION AT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR BOTH
ORGANIC WASTE GRANTS. OUR BIKE
RULES REGULATIONS ADOPTED LAST
YEAR ESTABLISHED FAR REACHING
REQUIREMENTS TO DIVERT 75% OF
ORGANIC WASTE FROM LANDFILLS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WORKING HARD
TO DEVELOP THE LOCAL PROGRAMS
ORDINANCES COLLECTION SYSTEMS
AND UPDATE RATE. WHICH HE
BELIEVES GOALS THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN LOCAL SYSTEMS
OUTLINED IN THE SENATE PLAN
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO HELPING
US. BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION AND
ABOUT THE STRONG EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS TO MAKE THIS WORK. BUT
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING TO
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE APPLE FOOD
RECOVERY PROGRAMS. AND
COMMUNITY COMPOSTING OPERATIONS
BUT WE STRONGLY SUGGEST
INCREASING THE AMOUNT DEDICATED
TO THOSE PURPOSES TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AND
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY ALLOCATED
TODAY. PLEASE ENTER WERE EVEN
THE EIGHTY. AND FINALLY ARE
HERE SUPPORT ITEMS THAT THREE
ABOUT AND THAT MILLION. TO
UPGRADE PROGRAM WHICH MEANT A
RESULTING FACTORS. WE THINK
THESE ARE. ARE LOW OVERDUE AND
CAN HELP FAIRGROUNDS BETTER.
THE ROLES OF THE WORKING. AND
EVACUATE CENTERS AND SORT OF
THE CATALYST FOR THE DEPLOYMENT
OF BROADBAND INTO UNSERVED. AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. NEXT ON. ONE
THIRTY TWO. SEVEN MEMBERS JERRY
DESMOND UP HALF OF RECREATIONAL
BOATERS OF CALIFORNIA ON ISSUE
THIRTY FOUR OF COOKED UP THE
HEARING AGENDA TODAY THE FISCAL
STABILITY PROMOTING PROGRAMS.
BUT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
THAT WOULD PROVIDE ME AN
ADDITIONAL COMMITMENT OF
GENERAL FUND MONIES TO SUPPORT
THE HARVEST AMERICA BADLY
THOUGHT AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN BOTH
REGISTRATIONS BEADS. AND SECOND
THE BUDGET TRAINER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD REQUIRE
STATE PARKS TO CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS TO REVIEW THE
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE OF THE
REVOLVING FUND TO PREPARE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS THE
LONG TERM VIABILITY FUN SOURCES
OF REVENUE AND EXPENDITURES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE FEES
AND TAXES PAID BY THE VOTING
PUBLIC PROVIDE THE MAXIMUM
ACHIEVABLE BENEFITS. FOR THE
FUTURE OF ON THE WATER
RECREATION. IMPROVERS OF THIS
ADDITION WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO ENSURE THAT THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS REQUIRES THE
APPOINTMENT OF REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE KEY STAKEHOLDER
ORGANIZATIONS. TO REQUIRE THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP PROCESS TO BE
CONDUCTED IN AN OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS SUBJECT TO
THE BROWN ACT PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES
ACT. AND TO SUPPORT CLEAR AND
COMPREHENSIVE OBJECTIVES FOR
THE PROCESS. THANK YOU X. ONE
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING RESISTANCE TO
ANTETOKOUNMPO ON BICYCLES IN
FACTORIES IN VENTURA MY
COMMENTS REGARDING SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURAL PEST MANAGEMENT MY
COMPANY BUILDS AND SELLS
BENEFICIAL INSECTS COULD HELP.
FARMERS TRANSITION TO ORGANIC-
BACK AND I'M HOPING. CALLED THE
BOOK NEED AND THAT ASIDE
HEARING- PESTICIDE. WILL RIGHT
OVER THERE COMMON SENSE WOULD
HAVE A LITTLE FOR TAKING
BECAUSE MY HIGHER THAN THE
PROPOSED KNOW BUT BUT
COLLECTION POST FEB. YOUR
LOCATION WILL HELP. YOU MIGHT.
FOR YOUR POTENTIAL STOPPAGE.
I'M TO TALK ABOUT THE FACT WHEN
APPLICATORS MUST NOTIFY THEIR
NEIGHBOURS ALONG WITH OUR
MONITORING AND THE POSTAL CODE
REGULATORY ACTIVITY
NOTIFICATION. WILL HELP PROTECT
FARMWORKERS. AND ALSO WITH
REGARD ACTUAL HABITAT BIBLE
PROGRAM PEST MANAGEMENT NOT TO
DRIVE THE PROTECTION OF
POLLINATORS OF MONARCHS. I'M
SORRY THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT
SHOWS ACTIVE SUPPORT COMPLEX.
BUT CONTRIBUTES TO THE NATURAL.
WHAT ALSO BECAUSE BOTH FROM
BACK. SIZE NOT HAVE BEEN FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS. GREAT PUBLIC
BENEFIT AND SUPPORT THAT WILL
IMPROVE SCHOOL REQUIRED TO BUY
A OF THE BUDGET FOR LOCAL
FARMERS. AND WHY DON'T. HOPING
HELLO WITHOUT POPULAR COULD ADD
1% WE WILL TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND BARRELS OF WATER
PER ACRE OF PESTICIDE
PRODUCTION. A LOCAL SUPPORT OF
AGRICULTURE WATER I WELL AS
WHAT THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. ONE FORTY NINE- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OUT OF MY POCKET HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE DETAILS EVEN AS YOU FIRE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS AND THAT- HE
GOES TO COURT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET TRAILER BILL
BURNS THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PARTICULAR IF HE'D BE
AUTHORIZATION OF EIGHTY EIGHT
ABOVE THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATIONS REPORT THIS
EVENING. TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
NOW IS THE TIME TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON BOTH VEHICLES AND CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE AND TRANSPORTATION
CALLING ABOVE BECOME APPEAR
APPROACH YOU'RE SURE MARKET
CERTAINTY ABOUT CONSUMERS AND
INDUSTRY- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. TRAILER BILL
DONE. SO WE RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH DR. FOR APP UNDER
THIS. AND YOUR- OF THE ABOUT
THE CONTINUED ON PART OF BUDGET.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT.
NINETY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBER BENEFITS THAT
EACH SPECTATOR FOUNDATION OKAY
THINKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COASTAL PROTECTION
NETWORK HUMBLE A KEEPER AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER
DECLINING ISSUE NINETY THREE
TODAY STRONGLY SUPPORTS AN
EXCLUSION OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION ALL RIGHTS
LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM L. A.
L. HAS IDENTIFIED HUMAN RIGHTS
ONE OF THE GREATEST THREAT TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY BECAUSE
THE COMMISSION FACILITY
INTENSIFY PROACTIVE LOCAL
ADAPTATION PLANNING. KITA
LITERALLY THINKING R. P. TENT
SHORELINE HABITAT RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND A COOKBOOK
AND A CONNIE AS WELL LET ME
QUICK TOWARD OF JOYFUL EACH
PROVIDE ALL RESIDENTS THAT
MEANS THAT THE CALIFORNIA THAT
THEY'RE CHEAPER TO EXPERIENCE.
NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE THANK
YOU. Q. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO RE
IT UP FIVE SO. MOM PLEASE CALL.
THE NEXT- CALLER IN MEMBERS
RETURN TODAY. ONE FIFTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON INTERLOCKING
WITH THE BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT THAT WILL REDUCE
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANT
PHILIP DAMAGING KIND OF
COULDN'T CUT OFF PHILLIPS TRACK
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY THESE
ARE THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
INDEFINITELY STATED MAKINGTO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE- AND
THEY'RE ALSO THE MOST OVERALL
EFFECTIVE EFFECTIVE THE ONLY
INVESTMENT. THAT CAN PROVIDE
CARBON NEGATIVE EMISSION- THE
COURT THE PROPOSAL BY THE SOUTH
COAST AND WHAT VALLEY OTHER.
TECH BUT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS TO REPLACE DIESEL
TRUCK THIS WILL PROVIDE.
BENEFIT FOR THE CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY. WELCOME TO SUPPORT THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TOWARD
AGAIN INCREASED DIVERSION
ALTHOUGH WE URGE THE SENATE TO
ALLOCATE FUNDING TO CALIPHATE
O. AS WELL AS LOCAL GOVERNMENT-
BOTH NEED TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS. FUNNY BECAUSE I DON'T
UTILIZATION. FOR TWENTY THIRD
AT THE PATIENT'S REMOVED FROM
WILDFIRE MITIGATION. AS WELL AS
LONG TERM LOOKED THE OTHER
CULTURAL OPEN BURNING OF
AGRICULTURAL WASTE. AND FINALLY
WE DO SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR
TERRY DIED AFTER. AGRICULTURE
BOARD RELEASED A REPORT A FEW
WEEKS AGO OUTLINING ALL OF THE
KIND OF INVESTMENT FOR THE PAST
YEAR. AN INVESTMENT IN DERRY
DIED DOCTORS WERE BY FAR THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AT ANY OF THE
STATE INVESTMENT. KIND OF
POLLUTION REDUCTION THREE TIMES
GREATER REDUCTION AND THE NEXT
HIGHEST CATEGORY ACTUALLY NEED
TO CONTINUE. TO INVESTMENT
BANKING. THANK YOU FOR NEXT.
ONE FIFTH EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND OF HIS ROCKER
DICKINSON FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION. SPEAKING
ON ITEM NINETY THREE OF PART B.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF A ROBUST
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PACKAGE AND-
JEW TO CONSIDER INCORPORATING
THE ELEMENTS INCLUDED IN OUR
MAY TWENTY FIRST LETTER
SUPPORTED BY OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS TO THE EXTENT
THAT IT'S NOT ALREADY PART. OF
THE PACKAGE THAT IS BEFORE YOU
YEAH IN PARTICULAR I WOULD
UNDERSCORE THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ADAPTATION PLANS
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
REGIONAL GOVERNMENT LEADERSHIP
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE GROUPS.
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NECKS. ONE FIFTY NINE. OCT THEM
THANK YOU HAVE MADE IT END UP
UNDER THE WIRE FOR YOU TO COOK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION TESTIFYING
IN REGARDS TO ITEM FIVE-
DISTRACT OUR GRATITUDE AND
APPRECIATION FOR THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE FUNDING
BARELY FIRST IMPORTANT OUT IN
UL EIGHTY EIGHT REPORT THAT 90%
OF HEALING THAT WERE CAUGHT
WILL BE PROVIDED BY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. IN ORDER FOR US TO
LEVERAGE THE DOLLARS IN
FURTHERANCE OF MEETING
CALIFORNIA GOLD WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT THEY BUILD ON THAT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EACH DEBATE YOU INSURE THAT
HYDROGEN FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
IS AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT OUR
RESIDENTS LIVING IN MULTI
FAMILY DWELLING OR THOSE WHO
PARK ON THE STREET THOSE WHO
ARE SINGLE VEHICLE HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR COMMUTERS- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WE
YOU AND BE ADDED TO ENSURE THAT
WERE ADEQUATELY SUPPORTING BOTH
YOUR MACHINE VEHICLE TOP. PLATE
ALL. RIGHT THANK YOU. NEXT ONCE.
ONE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS IF I IMPALA WITH ANY
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU YEAH TO
MAKE A QUICK COMMENT TODAY IN
CHARLIE PRECOURT THE SENATE
COMPREHENSIVE CLIMATE RESILIENT
BUDGET PACKAGE THAT INCLUDES
INCREASED CONSERVATION FUNDING
HELLO FROM YOUR COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING THE THREAT POSED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE LOSS OF
BIODIVERSITY WE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE YOU INCLUDING THE
FOLLOWING ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
FOR THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY- FIRST
VEHICLE SO THEY CAN SEVENTEEN
IN GENERAL AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION.
AND THE FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WE MUST NOT OVERLOOK THE
CRITICAL ROLE THAT ARE
PROTECTED LAND PLANE CAPTURING
AND STORING FRESH WATER STORING
CARBON PROTECTING US FROM
GLOBAL RISE IN PROTECTING
BIODIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN UNPRECEDENTED FINANCIAL
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE AND BIODIVERSITY CRISES
IN THE FY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET AND THE
NEIGHBORING ACTION AT THAT
SCALE ATTENTIONAL PROVIDE
CHRISTIE FOR PRESIDENT AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE THIRTEEN
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CURRENT CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PROPOSAL AND INCREASE
INVESTMENTS IN LAND
CONSERVATION AND APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTAINER IT
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP. AND AT
THE ASPEN OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS ON THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES
I WANTED TO GIVE US A QUICK
THANK YOU JOANNE THAT BROUGHT
YOUR STAFF AND NOTE THAT THEY
SHOULD BE PLEASED THAT THE
COURT LETTER YET B. AND A
COALITION OF OUR PARTNERS THAT
L. A LOT OF GREAT FUN BUT THE
POINT THAT WE BLOCK THE PORT IN
REGARDS TO THAT AND IT QUITE
RESILIENT BACKAGE THANK YOU. SO
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT. ONE SO.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND MEMBERS GOOD
ON OF HOP CALIPER BAR JUSTICE
ALLIANCE. HOW BEEN MEETING WITH
OPPOSITE UNDER BUDGET BUT WE
WILL LIKE TO MAKE A FEW BUDGET
PRIORITIES. FIRST THEY HAVE A
NEW ONE BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND ALLOCATION FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS ARE WHICH
ARE COMMUNITY LED AND COMMUNITY
CENTERS PROJECT. ALSO REQUEST
THAT THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM FUNDING
BE INCREASED TO SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION THE FUND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND WEATHER STATION
UPGRADES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. YOU HAVE TO PORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE TRANSFORMER
FROM THE COMMUNITIES GRANT THE
FUND COMMUNITY LED. RESILIENCE
PLANS. AND LASTLY SECOND
REQUEST THAT ALL FUNDING FOR
DAIRY DIGESTERS TO CONTAMINATE
GROUNDWATER AND INCREASE AIR
POLLUTION BE ELIMINATED. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY ONE CAR. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS THAT
THE TASHA NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF PLAN
TRACK REPRESENTING OVER EIGHTY
BRANCHES ACROSS THE STATE AND
THE DEMOCRATIC BALLOT OPEN
DEBATE THE PARTY WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SENATE THE
PROBES ON THE CLIENT PACKAGE
AND- WE JUST HAVE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS. MADE BY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU. NEXT.
ONE SIXTY TWO. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL BOCA GOVERNOR
ON BEHALF OF THE ENERGY
CONSUMERS I JUST WANTED TO PUT
A FINE POINT ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF CONTINUED STANDING AT THE-
FIGURE SKATER DIGESTIVE
PROGRAM. AS MISS LEVIN
MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE INVESTMENTS
REPORT JUST CAME OUT. SHOWS
THAT THE STATE HAS INVESTED
OVER THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
AND GPRS FUNDS TO DATE. JUST
TWO HUNDRED MILLION OF THOSE
FUNDS ABOUT ONE POINT 5% HAD
BEEN ALLOCATED TO THE DIGEST A
PROGRAM. THAT ONE PROGRAM THAT
DIGESTIVE PROGRAMS PROVIDING
MORE THAN 29% OF THE TOTAL
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
RICHIE FROM ALL THE INVESTMENTS
UNDER THE PROGRAM. IT'S JUST
PUT SIMPLY ONE POINT 5% OF THE
INVESTMENTS IS GENERATING 29%
OF THE RETURNS. ARGUMENTS AS
YOU JUST HEARD TO NOT FUND THIS
PROGRAM ARE MISGUIDED AND
CONTRARY TO THE STATE CLIMATE
POLICY GOALS. THE TREMENDOUS
RETURN ON INVESTMENT QUITE THE
CONTRARY WOULD ARGUE FOR
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
INVESTMENTS WE APPRECIATE THE
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED AMENDING
COURAGE THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY. TO INCREASE THAT
AMOUNT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. ONE SIXTY THREE. SEPT
NATURE WORK OUT INSTEAD OF
STATION WAGON WENT COUNTY FIRE
CHIEF BY SECURITY SUFFICIENT
HELP ARE CONTRACT COUNTIES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF
WILDLAND FIRE PREVENTION
PROTECTION EFFORTS STATEWIDE.
THAT CAL FIRE CONTRACT COUNTIES
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES ORANGE
KERN VENTURA SANTA BARBARA AND
RIGHT AFTER YOUR FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION ABOUT FUELS GROUP
FUNDING REQUEST FOURTEEN POINT
THREE. MILLION ANNUAL AND
ONGOING WHICH IS COMPLEMENTARY
OF CAL FIRE'S PARKER PCP.
CONTRACT COUNTY FIELD CREWS
WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL FUEL
REDUCTION WORK IN RESPONSE TO
WILDFIRES DIRECTLY SUPPORTING
THE STATE MISSION. EACH COUNTY
WILL STILL BE MAKING
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS THEN THE FUNDS
BEING REQUESTED TO MAINTAIN AND
ENHANCE THE RESPECTIVE. FIELD
PARK GROUP PROGRAMS. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT. ONE SIXTY. THANK YOU
CHAD NUMBER PERFECT AWESOME
SUMMER WITH CLASSIFIED ACTION
NETWORK COMMENTING ON ISSUES.
FORTY EIGHT FORTY NINE EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO MAKE OUR
AGRICULTURAL SYSTEM PROJECT AND
MORE TAN A BALL WITH A
STRONGLY SUPPORT HERE AT THE
FED MURPHY THE PENNANT PROPOSED
PLAN INCLUDES ITEMS THAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT INCLUDING
TECHNICAL RESEARCH I DON'T HAVE
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS MANAGE
COSTS BASICALLY ACCORDING TO
COURT AGAIN ARMING AGAIN. A
PART OF A BRIBERY TO SUPPORT.
ON THE POLLINATOR HOBBY PROGRAM
CLASSIFIED UNDER THE NUMBER.
AND EXPAND CLASSIFIED- MY
NETWORK. WHICH AGREE WITH
INCLUDE BUDGET BUT LANGUAGE
LINK AT OUR MONITORING AND
ENFORCEMENT. HOWEVER WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE PROPOSAL
AMID FUNDING FOR DIRECT
PROTECTION FOR COMMUNITY OF
CRIMES. THAT YOU. REQUIRE AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION AND
THE PACKAGE FOR COMMUNITY
SUPPORT AND- HELP COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED BY HEART. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE CONCLUDE OUR PUBLIC
HEARING WE APOLOGIZE TO ANY
FOLKS THAT WE WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR PLEASE CONTACT THE SENATE.
OR THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR COMMENTS
WILL BE MADE PART OF THE PUBLIC
RECORD- WITH THAT WE'LL GO TO
OUR VOTE- ON PART EIGHTY. N.
THE CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN. A
MOTION TO APPROVE ISSUES NUMBER
TWO. FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT NINE
TEN AS WELL AS THIRTEEN CENTER
DOLLY SEND A MOTION. SOME MOVED
BY SENATOR DONNELLY MISS ROY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
ISSUES TO FIVE THROUGH TEN AND
THIRTEEN. CASKEY HI S. CI DALLI
DALLI EIN MCGUIRE. HI STERN
STERN I CLOSE REAL TALLY THE
VOTES. FOUR ZERO THE EYES HAVE
IT THAT WOULD TURN THE ISSUES
ANOTHER MOTION ON ISSUE. ONE
THREE FOUR AND ELEVEN IS THAT A
MOTION CENTER STERN. MOVED BY
SENATOR STERN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BY CASKEY HI STI DALLY
DELHI NOW THE CLIENT. REQUIRE
ICE STERN. STERN I CLOSE REAL
TELLY VOTE. THE EYES HAVE A
THREE TO ONE. I NOW FINALLY ON
OUR PART A ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
CENT REQUIRES EMOTIONS. SOME
MISS ROY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE BY
CASKEY BY ASKING I AM
THOROUGHLY. DELHI NOT LOADING
THE GLAMOUR REQUIRED I STERN.
STERN I CLOSE RULE TELEPHONE.
THREE ZERO THE EYES HAVE IT NOW
LET'S MOVE TO PART B. THIS IS
ISSUES NUMBER. TWO THROUGH TEN
ISSUE TWELVE ISSUE FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN ISSUE. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
AND TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY AND
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX AND
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY NINE AND.
824-034-0650. 1-545-565-6760.
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY THREE
AND SEVENTY FOUR. IN ISSUE
NUMBER 82% OF MOTION CENTER
DOLLY TO GROUP APPROVE THOSE
ISSUES- BY SENATOR DOLLY
MYSTERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I
CASKEY HI S. CI DIALING.
DIALING NINE THE CLIENT THE
CLIENT STERN. STERN I CLOSE
ROLE TELEPHONE THE I. SEVEN
FOUR ZERO NOW ANOTHER MOTION ON
ISSUE ONE ISSUE. ELEVEN SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX TWENTY
NINE ISSUES FORTY EIGHT AND
FORTY NINE ISSUE SIXTY NINE AND
SEVENTY IN ISSUE EIGHTY FIVE
CENTER STERN IS AN OCEAN. MOVED
BY SANDERSON PLEASE CALL
ROMANCE ROY CASKEY HI ASKING
NINE DELHI DELHI NOW REQUIRE.
REQUIRE HIGH STERN. CLOSE REAL
TALLY THE VOTES. THREE ONE THE
I. SEVEN THREE ONE NOW ON THE
REMAINING ISSUES ISSUES.
THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO AND. THIRTY THREE
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT FORTY
ONE FORTY FIVE FIFTY FIFTY TWO
FIFTY THREE. FIFTY SIX THROUGH.
SIXTY ONE SIXTY FOUR SIXTY SIX
ISSUE SEVENTY SIX SEVENTY TWO.
ISSUE SEVENTY FIVE TH THROUGH
EIGHTY ONE ISSUE EIGHTY FIFTH
THREE AND EIGHTY FOUR AND
ISSUES EIGHTY SIX THROUGH
EIGHTY NINE IS THAT EMOTIONS
THAT ARE REQUIRED. MISS ROY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I CASKEY
HI S. CI TALLY. KELLY NOT
LOADING THE GLAND HI THE CLIENT
STERN STERN I CLOSE RULED TELL
YOU TO VOTE. THE I. SEVEN THREE
ZERO NOW ON ISSUE NUMBER ON THE
ISSUES FROM THE DISCUSSION.
ISSUE NUMBER NINETY THE
GOVERNOR'S WATER RESILIENCY AND
THROUGHOUT THE PACKAGE- IS
THERE A MOTION. SENATOR MCGUIRE
MOVES ISSUE NUMBER STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND ISSUED
NUMBER NINETY. DESTROYED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL I CASKEY HI
ASKING HIGH VALLEY. DELHI NOT
LEARNING THE CHOIR. THE CHOIR I
STERN. STERN I CLOSED GOAL
TALLY THE VOTES. THE I. SEVEN
THREE ZERO ON ISSUE NINETY ONE
THE GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE EXPENDITURE
PLAN. THE TOP STAFF
RECOMMENDATION CENTER STIRS
EMOTIONS. MISS ROY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CASKEY HI OKAY I AM
SORRY NOT VOTING GOING NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE. REQUIRE ICE
DURING THIRTY NINE CLOSE REAL
TELL YOU VOTE. ZERO A. I. SEVEN
THREE ZERO ON ISSUE NUMBER
NINETY TWO IS THE GOVERNOR'S
CLIMB INTERESTS RESILIENCE
PACKAGE. IS THAT A MOTION
CENTER REQUIRE EVER MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MISS
FLORES IS SET UP THE- STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. WHAT KASKY BY
STI DOLLY. KELLY NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE THE CARD I A STERN- AND
I. THREE ZERO CLOSE ROLLED TO A
VOTE THE AYES HAVE IT THREE
ZERO AND FINALLY OUR LAST ISSUE
ISSUE NUMBER NINETY THREE WHICH
IS THE SENATE'S CLIMATE PACKAGE
SIR MOTION CENTER STERN. WE DID
THE GOVERNORS CLUB PACKAGE
THIS. IS THE MOST PERCENTAGE
TURN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CASKEY HI S. CI DELI. DELI NOT
VOTING THE FIRE. LANDLINE STERN.
HI CLOSE RULE TELL YOU TO VOTE
FOR. THREE ZERO THE ICE HAPPENS.
ALL THAT DOES IT THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
YOUR COOPERATION WE'VE
CONCLUDED GENDER OF TODAY'S.
HEARING THE SENATE BUDGET A
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO IS ADJOURNED.